[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour vivre le temps fort de la
semaine au Sénat les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement à 15h ne
manquez pas une heure d'échange direct
entre les sénateurs et le gouvernement
le thème principal l'attaque de la
préfecture de police de Paris et la
gestion de cette attentat par l'exécutif
les analyses les réactions c'est avec
Alice Bardot dans l'hémicycle et
Alexandre Poussard dans la salle des
conférences à tout de suite les suites
de l'incendie de l'usine Lubrizol à
Rouen des taux de dioxine élevés ont été
relevés hier Elisabeth borne a
particulièrement chargé l'entreprise
devant les sénateurs une commission
d'enquête va être mise en place on en
débat tout à l'heure
enfin à 16h30 le Sénat débat de la
politique migratoire Kota aide médicale
d'État coordination européenne tous ces
sujets seront abordés par Edward
Philippe et les sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle
et n'hésitez pas à réagir à toute cette
émission avec le hashtag QAG
[Musique]
et on va tout de suite rejoindre Alice
Bardot dans l'hémicycle du Sénat cet
après-midi elle est un petit peu
spéciale avec un programme
particulièrement riche à lisses et oui
chargé au Sénat aujourd'hui puisque
après les questions au Gouvernement un
débat sur l'immigration sera organisé au
Sénat alors avant d'échanger avec les
sénateurs le Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe rappellera les grandes lignes
de la politique migratoire du
gouvernement comme il l'a fait à
l'Assemblée nationale lundi puis ce sera
au tour de trois de ces ministres de
s'exprimer chacun dans leur domaine de
spécialité alors la sécurité intérieure
pour Christophe Castaner la politique
migratoire européenne pour Amélie de
Montchalin et la santé pour cristal
Dubos viendra ensuite le temps du débat
donc un sénateur par groupe politique
aura l'opportunité de débattre avec le
gouvernement mais avant cela Tam comme
je vous le disais ce sera le rendez-vous
heb des sénateurs avec les ministres les
questions au Gouvernement alors il va
évidemment être question de l'attentat à
la préfecture de Paris le Premier
ministre va être un interpellé mais
également Christophe Castaner qui a été
entendu hier par la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement mais
également par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée demain matin il va être
entendu par la commission d'enquête du
Sénat mise en cause pour sa gestion de
la crise de cette attentat il va
sûrement avoir à répondre au sénateur
cet après-midi merci beaucoup Alice pour
toutes ces explications et c'est
d'ailleurs le premier thème de cette
émission l'attentat de la préfecture de
police de Paris et les questions qui se
posent hier le gouvernement a été très
chahuté par sa gestion de cette attaque
le ministre de l'Intérieur Christophe
Castaner a été auditionné à deux
reprises à huis clos le matin par la
délégation renseignement puis il a fait
face au feu des questions des députés
devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée retour sur cette audition
avec Marion Vigreux nous cherchons tous
à comprendre ce passage à l'acte leur
audition a duré plus de deux heures ce
mardi le ministre de l'Intérieur
Christophe Castaner et son secrétaire
d'État Laurent Nunez ont répondu aux
questions des députés de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale des
questions pour faire toute la
transparence sur ce qui a conduit à
l'attaque de la préfecture de police de
Paris comme le fait que la
radicalisation du meurtrier n'est pas
été repérée vous nous dites
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas eu de
signalement mais dans ces secteurs qui
sont aussi sensibles que le secteur de
l'anti-terrorisme et du renseignement
n'y a-t-il pas des procédures c'est que
globalement dans le service il y avait
ce sentiment
qu'aucune alerte n'était nécessaire le
dysfonctionnement la faille je la pense
au moment où l'information n'a pas
franchi le pas qui permettait du coup de
déclencher ce qui aurait dû être
déclenché conséquence de nouvelles
mesures voient le jour comme ce
signalement automatique mis en place en
cas d'alerte peut-être qu'un signal
faible est en réalité un signal fort et
donc il faut qu'il y ait des alertes
systématiques lors de cette audition le
ministre en a profité pour faire le
point sur la surveillance des individus
radicalisés je peux vous donner ce
nombre de 40 individus radicalisés au
sein de la police la moitié sont partis
il reste 19 ou 24 qui sont suivis
attentivement sur lesquels les signaux
sont des signaux faibles qui ne
caractérisent aucune anomalie pénale
mais ils font l'objet d'une attention
toute particulière les députés ont de
leur côté demandé des précisions sur les
attentats déjoués par les services sur
les 59 attentats déjoués ce sont des
attentats terroristes islamistes la
révision des habilitations secret
défense a été évoquée ainsi que les deux
missions lancées par le Premier ministre
pour évaluer les agents de la lutte
antiterroriste Christophe Castaner et
Laurent Nunez seront de nouveau entendu
ce jeudi au Sénat cette fois-ci
et on va débattre de questions soulevées
par cette attentat quels sont les
failles dans la détection de la
radicalisation quel plan d'action
adopter Christophe Castaner peut-il
rester ministre de l'intérieur on en
parle avec nos quatre invités Françoise
Gatel bonjour vous êtes sénatrice UC
d'Ille-et-Vilaine membre de la
commission des lois qui va d'ailleurs
auditionner Christophe Castaner demain
également à mes côtés Alain Marc bonjour
sénateur les indépendants de l'Aveyron
vice-président de la commission des lois
également sur ce plateau Denis Jacob
vous êtes secrétaire général
d'alternatives police CFDT et enfin sur
ce plateau Michel bouton bonjour
sénateur socialiste de la Charente vous
êtes membre de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
délégation qui a auditionné hier matin
les ministres à huis clos Christophe
Castaner mais aussi Laurent Nunez est-ce
que vous les avez trouvées à la hauteur
des enjeux tout d'abord
vous savez que les propos qui sont tenus
à l'intérieur de la délégation
parlementaire renseignement sont
couverts par le secret défense
ce que globalement je peux dire c'est
que les questions qui ont été posées par
les différents membres de la délégation
parlementaires ont toutes trouvé une
réponse toute donc
je pense que les les deux ministres ce
sont livrés là à un exercice de vérité
qui est loin de toutes les polémiques
que l'on peut entendre actuellement donc
vous n'êtes pas dans le ton de la
polémique d'ailleurs comme beaucoup au
Sénat également hier Christian Cambon
disait que les réponses avaient été
précises et satisfaisante Denis Jacob
comment a-t-on pu arriver à une telle
situation comment expliquer un tel
dysfonctionnement dans la détection de
la radicalisation selon vous
c'est une interrogation aussi pour nous
policiers parce que effectivement avoir
un autre saint quelqu'un qui est
aujourd'hui clairement identifié comme
quelqu'un de radicalisé on s'interroge
et nous la question que l'on a posée dès
le début c'est pourquoi n'a-t-on pas
pris en compte la mesure de la gravité
des propos qui avait été rapportés en
2015 au prétexte que la procédure
interne administrative c'est de faire un
compte-rendu écrit pour signaler quelque
chose sauf que là je pense que la
situation en pleine période d'attentat
je le rappelle 2015 la situation
était suffisamment assez grave pour que
les autorités en tous les cas tous les
niveaux hiérarchiques puissent signaler
ou dans un premier temps au moins
rencontré cette agent et puis savoir
pourquoi il a tenu ses propos et essayer
d'identifier les raisons pour lesquelles
il les a tenu donc moi je suis surpris
aujourd'hui qu'on nous dit qu'il y a pas
eu d'écrit à propos de cet événement
mais qu'aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y a eu
des propos donc il y a un moment donné
que ça a bien été signalé à un niveau ou
un autre effectivement cette faille elle
est confirmée par le rapport de la
patronne du renseignement à la
préfecture de police regardez bien ce
qu'on dit le rapport il y en a un
certain nombre d'extraits monsieur
harpon a bien fait l'objet en 2015 de
discussion entre membres de son service
sur son éventuel radicalisation je saute
quelques mots tout ça n'a pas donné lieu
à des rapports écrits et qu'en tout cas
ils n'ont pas été portés au dossier
administratif et elle ajoute autre chose
elle-même n'avait rien constaté de
particulier c'est ce qu'elle dit dans le
rapport j'ai moi-même côtoyé monsieur
harpon depuis mon arrivée à la DRPP sans
constater la moindre difficulté
relationnelle ou professionnelle
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire Françoise
Gatel est-ce que c'est un
dysfonctionnement incompréhensible ou
est-ce qu'au contraire vous comprenez
comment ça peut arriver on le voit avec
parfois des collègues dont on est proche
et on ne repère pas forcément un certain
nombre de changements
on ne peut pas comparer une situation
entre collègues dans un milieu
complètement neutre avec ce qui peut se
passer et ce qui est acceptable à la
préfecture de police quand on a un
fonctionnaire qui habilité se crée
défense moi je pense dans les plus
hautes habitations de la préfecture de
police mais absolument moi je pense de
manière très tranquille et sans
polémique on peut quand même
s'interroger et s'inquiéter du fait que
des signes de radicalisation ont été
communiquées à partir de 2015 et que
dans un service de cette nature qui a un
service particulièrement névralgique qui
est chargé de protéger à une époque où
il y avait effectivement
cette phobie justifiée des attentats on
n'est pas pris soin de vérifier
c'est-à-dire que à un moment il y a un
signal faible dans un service de cette
nature on vérifie c'est vrai ou c'est
pas vrai mais on contrôle et c'est assez
surprenant monsieur Jacob l'a dit
qu'aujourd'hui
chacun reconnaît qu'il a bien été dit en
2015 qu'il y avait des signes de
radicalisation donc cela a été entendu
mais derrière il n'y a pas eu l'enquête
qui était nécessaire pour voir si les
filles étaient avéré ou non elle a
marqué dysfonctionnement pour vous aussi
incompréhensible au vu de ce que l'on
découvre oui et je rejoindrai le
syndicatiste politique est ici parce que
ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne fait pas un
rapport écrit que l'on doit rester sans
rien faire moi ce que je sais par
ailleurs un article d'ailleurs du Figaro
le révèle est hier c'est qu'il y a
d'autres dysfonctionnements des gens qui
sont très probablement radicalisés et
même certainement et des policiers ont
fait des rapports alors des rapports
oraux mais aussi je viens d'en avoir la
confirmation des rapports écrits ces
gens-là sont à des endroits très
stratégiques très stratégiques ils sont
au niveau informatique ils ont
connaissance de de beaucoup d'éléments
et ces gens là sont toujours en place or
il y a vraiment un dysfonctionnement
parce que certes il y a le cas de
Monsieur de Monsieur harpon mais il y a
aussi d'autres cas et aujourd'hui il est
temps que au-delà des mots au-delà de ce
que peut révéler la richesse de la
langue française est-ce que c'est écrit
est-ce que c'est pas écrit etc il y ait
des actes et je crois que c'est ce que
le plus important
quand bon hier à la suite de l'audition
a dit son inquiétude face à ce visage du
terrorisme qui a gagné bien certains
services de l'État je vous propose de
l'écouter et on revient juste après
nous sommes convenus de modifier notre
programme de travail cette année pour
faire en sorte de nous pencher sur les
conditions de sécurité des services de
renseignement français puisque
malheureusement à travers cet épisode
dramatique il apparaît que des drames
peuvent naître au sein même de ces
services alors que nous étions jusqu'à
présent plutôt habitués à des formes de
violence ou d'attentats qui touchaient
des lieux publics Michel bouton en a
donc compris un que la délégation
renseignement aller prendre en compte
bien sûr ce sujet dans son travail
l'ennemi donc aujourd'hui il est de plus
en plus à l'intérieur c'est donc
d'autant plus compliqué à gérer
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire qu'il soit
de plus en plus à l'intérieur il est il
a toujours été peut-être qui qui lui a
été mais le danger il est aussi exogène
il peut venir de groupe alors qui ont
plus de difficultés aujourd'hui à être
soutenu logistiquement par daesh qui a
été fait sur le sur le terrain mais vous
pouvez avoir quelques loups solitaires
alors
et partout cette personne là était-elle
un loup solitaire et à partir de ce
moment-là il est quand même toujours
difficile de savoir quelle est
l'intention de quelqu'un qu'elle même
les les services de renseignement les
plus compétents
ne parviennent pas à deviner l'intention
de de quelqu'un ceci ceci étant la
délégation parlementaire ou enseignement
pose très souvent cette question aux
autres services de renseignement est-ce
que vous êtes sûr de vous hommes et de
vous femmes
est-ce que les contrôles sont effectifs
c'est une question aujourd'hui qui qui
pouvait sembler banal il y a quelques
mois aujourd'hui elle est presque
essentielle parce que le vert est dans
le fruit Michael harpon d'ailleurs
devait avoir un renouvellement de ton
habilitation en 2020 et la dernière
datée de 2013 sachant qu'il y a les
services depuis 2003 tous les 7 ans
l'habilitation au secret défense
moulinette en quelque sorte pour
vérifier mais ceci étant si l'on se rend
compte qu'il y a quelques
dysfonctionnements dans le travail de la
personne on peut tout à fait ouvrir une
enquête à ce moment-là Denis Jacob hier
Christophe Castaner a dit que 40
individus radicalisés au sein de la
police ont été détectés la moitié sont
partis il parle aussi d'une vingtaine de
policiers encore attentivement suivie il
dit ils sont pas vraiment radicalisés
mais ils sont suivis par les services de
renseignement donc c'est pas fini
mais pour répondre aussi et compléter ce
que disait le sénateur Boutant il faut
que les choses soient très claires
à notre connaissance on n'est pas
infiltré Michael Michael harpon on le
savait ça a été signalé en 2015 donc il
n'est pas passé en entre les mailles du
filet c'est qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait et si je souscris aux propos du
président de la République sur une
société vigilante il faut avant tout que
nos administrations le soir voilà et
s'agissant des RA réaliser il y a une
véritable question est-ce que l'on peut
continuer à avoir des fonctionnaires
radicalisés notamment dans la police à
des endroits stratégiques ou même tout
court dans la police nationale mais se
pose le problème de fonctionnaires qui
ont passé un concours ils font le cadre
d'un droit de fonction publique on ne
peut pas les renvoyer comme ça au
prétexte que et puis sans défendre cela
parce que je le ferai jamais mais
radicaliser ne veut pas dire non plus de
terroriste voilà donc
la ligne est tenue puisqu'on sait que la
radicalisation conduit en général
à des actes beaucoup plus graves mettant
que il y a pas de signaux forts on parle
de signaux faibles mais si au fort c'est
très difficile de dire à quel moment la
personne peut potentiellement passer à
l'acte mais c'est un vrai sujet et qui
n'est malheureusement pas qu'au niveau
de la police on parle de la police parce
que malheureusement on a eu ce drame
mais on sait que d'autres
administrations ont aussi des personnes
radicalisées et puis dans des grandes
entreprises aussi privée je pense
notamment les entreprises de transport
commun ou aériens cet établi enfin voilà
il y a un vrai sujet et c'est pour ça
que je proposais il y a quelques jours
mais je crois savoir qu'il y a une
commission paritaire qui a été créée en
2018 par le Premier ministre sur ça a
priori elle se serait jamais réunie je
n'en connais pas les raisons mais moi je
proposais la création d'un service
interministériel si tenté que c'est
possible avec des agences spécifiquement
dédiées sur l'ensemble de la fonction
publique pour suivre l'ensemble des
personnes radicalisées voilà pour une
des pistes sur le plan d'action à
adopter Françoise Gatel tout même tout
d'abord vous allez demain auditionner
Christophe Castaner la commission des
lois va à l'auditionner vous sur quel
point voulez-vous accentuer vos
questions il y a notamment je pense
notamment aussi à la question de la clé
USB qui a été beaucoup mentionnée hier
matin et qui suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude c'est pas exactement ce
qu'il y a c'est bien les coordonnées ce
qu'il y a de d'autres agents de la
préfecture de police et ce qui en a été
fait de manière générale je pense ce que
nous allons interroger le ministre
intérieur sur ce qui me convient de
faire aujourd'hui pour que cette
situation qui a été une tragédie ce qui
a eu des morts et qui fragilisent et qui
inquiète aussi la population je pense
que ça contribue à entretenir un
sentiment d'insécurité qu'on y mettre
tout à l'heure mon collègue parlait de
loup solitaire alors effectivement il y
a des loups solitaires qui a un moment
peuvent basculer pour des raisons X ou Y
on a du mal à anticiper mais quand même
cette personne il y a eu un signalement
en 2015 elle est reconnue comme
quelqu'un de fragile et donc je pense
que quand on a dans un service de cette
nature quelqu'un pour lesquelles on a
des un signalement qui a une certaine
fragilité il convient d'être plus que
vigilant c'est-à-dire de contrôler de
vérifier parce que c'est une personne
qui peut effectivement être soumis à la
manipule enfin plus facilement être
soumise à la manipulation
en gros donc moi je pense que plus que
de la vigilance dans un dans les
services de l'État et dans des services
de cette nature on doit avoir des
procédures de très haute sécurité et que
s'il ne se passe rien pendant tout le
temps ou quelqu'un bénéficie d'un
agrément et son renouvellement je pense
qu'on est un peu trop léger un peu
inconscient et qu'il convient il faut
que les policiers qui s'engagent dans
ces métiers sachent que ils sont
naturellement contrôlés parce que c'est
eux qui sont censés protéger et que
c'est quand même assez inquiétant de
savoir que cette personne elle a pu
diffuser par le biais d'une clé USB à
onsiki des informations qui relèvent de
la sécurité de l'État et que en 2015
c'est pas une question de gouvernement
en 2015 nous étions sous un autre
gouvernement avec cette phobie des
attentats à juste titre et je pense
qu'on est aussi victime dans ce pays et
dans beaucoup des services de ce que le
Figaro appelle le dennislamisme
c'est-à-dire que parfois les gens
n'osent pas par certaines
ils ont vraiment peur qu'on les qu'on
les taxe de racisme ou d'islamophobie il
faut qu'on ouvre les yeux qu'on soit
courageux et qu'on soit franc et clair
pour protéger pour protéger notre
société à la marque est-ce que pour vous
et bien toutes ces questions qui sont
posées la nécessité aujourd'hui une
commission d'enquête du côté du Sénat on
sait que c'est assez débattu il y a
celle qui va être constituée du côté de
l'Assemblée mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile compte tenu du fait qu'il y a
beaucoup d'éléments qui sont classés
aussi secret défense alors votre avis
probablement probablement mais je
voudrais juste revenir sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Jacob monsieur Jacob a dit la
ligne est tenue entre un individu
radicalisé et celui qui va passer à
l'acte mais bon ça bonsoir On est
peut-être en capacité nous demain les
législateurs de faire en sorte que
l'individu radicalisé ne soit pas à des
postes stratégiques névralgique ça pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'important et
ça ça peut être à nous à nous de la
mettre en place ensuite l'évaluation
comme l'a dit ma collègue la procédure
doit être permanente il ne viendrait
jamais à l'idée à des compagnies
aériennes de laisser des pilotes qui ne
seraient pas constamment évalués sur
leur capacité physique sur leur
capacités psychologique de la même façon
les avions sur lequel nous volons les
uns et les autres sont continuellement
soumis à des procédures donc il faut
qu'il en soit de même pour ces gens qui
sont de même ou qui sont toujours dit et
demain employés
à ces postes là alors quel plan d'action
adopter hier Édouard Philippe lors des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement a
commencé à en dire un mot écoutez-le
j'ai indiqué premièrement que je
souhaitais que l'inspection des services
de renseignement puissent déterminer le
plus précisément possible les éventuels
signals les éventuelles signalement
et les mesures qui ont été prises par
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité des
forces de renseignement au regard de ces
éventuels signalements c'est le but de
la mission de l'inspection des services
de renseignement elle nous aidera à
savoir à connaître et attirer les
conséquences je le redis monsieur le
député le tamis doit être très très fin
et notre filet doit avoir ses mailles en
permanence resserrer
alors qu'en pensez-vous à Michel bouton
c'est nécessaire certainement cette
mission de l'inspection des services de
renseignement mais ce n'est pas
suffisant
il y a une enquête judiciaire qui est en
cours donc qui va permettre
d'élucider un certain nombre de zones de
zone d'ombre ensuite comme vient de
l'indiquer mon collègue monsieur Marc il
y aura sans doute une réponse politique
soit à travers une un projet de loi ou
une proposition de loi
sur
la posture que toi adopter l'État que
doit adopter l'administration lorsqu'un
cas de radicalisation
avérées et signalée dans ces services là
vous pensez que ça peut venir en
discussion mais
ce n'est pas ça c'est une réponse un peu
plus sur du moyen terme on va dire mais
dans l'immédiat dans l'immédiat dans
l'hypothèse ou un certain nombre
d'informations auraient été communiqués
par harpon
ah on ne sait qui
mais on peut juger dans des dans des
dans des mains mal intentionnées c'est
terrible pour ceux qui travaillent à la
préfecture c'est également terrible sur
cette tour pour les pour les personnes
sur qui nous servent peuvent compter
pour recueillir du renseignement parce
que s'ils ont été désignés repérés vous
savez ce que ça veut ça signifie pour
eux c'est que du demain on a déjà vu ça
Magnanville un couple de policiers qui a
été qui a été assassiné et demain qui
nous dit que ce ne sera pas encore le
cas c'est en cela que c'est aussi
terrible cette ce drame là parce que il
y a effectivement ces quatre personnes
qui sont qui sont mortes qui ont été
assassinés dans les conditions
effroyables que l'on sait sur leur lieu
de travail et puis il y a tous les
autres
qui sont dans dans une dans une
situation qui peut plus que les les
préoccuper mais les inquiéter
profondément il y a une grande
inquiétude qui vous partagez Denis Jacob
pour bien tous ces fonctionnaires de
police qui sont susceptibles d'être sur
cette clé dans les coordonnées peuvent
être bien sûr qu'on le partage des gens
on ne sait pas combien de policiers sont
potentiellement ciblés dans cette liste
je rappelle qu'à la pépé on a un
logiciel de gestion du personnel est-ce
que harpon a eu accès à l'ensemble des
données professionnelles et personnelles
de tous les policiers affectés la
préfecture de police c'est-à-dire plus
de 26000 si je ne me trompe pas donc
c'est quand même phénoménal on a des
inquiétudes on a déjà des remontées il y
a des il y a des collègues qui
travaillent dans les services
spécialisés qui disposent d'une
habilitation secrète défense qui ne sont
pas forcément la Direction du
renseignement et qui se disent comme ces
sorties de la DRPP est-ce que nos noms
sont dedans qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quel moyen de protection on va mettre en
place pour nous nos familles parce que
s'il a eu accès à des données
personnelles on peut potentiellement
avoir accès aux nombre d’enfants vivant
au foyer la femme l'adresse personnelle
les numéros de téléphone les adresses
mails enfin toutes les données que nous
donnons à l'administration dans le cadre
de notre suivi de carrière donc oui
c'est inquiétant pour autant je ne
minimise pas la gravité de la situation
mais je ne voudrais pas non plus qu'on
laisse croire qu'on tombe dans
dans une peur que nous ne sommes pas en
capacité de faire face et d'inquiéter
outre mesure la population faut pas non
plus céder un climat paranoïaque et de
psychose que les choses soient claires
on a des services de renseignement
malgré tout qui sont très efficaces et
il y a pas que l'adrpp il y a la DGSI il
y a lasdate enfin il y a voilà ça ne
manque pas au sein de l'institution
policière et voilà relativisons aussi
même si la situation est grave justement
à ce propos je voudrais que l'on écoute
il y a un extrait de l'hommage car fait
Emmanuel Macron au matin il a appelé les
Français à se mobiliser contre lead
islamiste pour lui mais ça va au-delà
simplement de nos services de police
écoutez les institutions seules
ne suffiront pas
l'administration seule et tous les
services de l'État
ne seraient venir à bout
de l’hydre islamiste non
c'est la nation tout entière
qui doit s'unir faisons bloc sans
relâche
contre l'islamisme contre ces idéologies
mortifères qui ne reconnaissent ni nos
lois ni notre droit
ni notre façon de vivre
votre réaction Françoise gatthalassée
propose du président de la République il
appelle tout le monde a être extrêmement
attentif et en même temps attention à ne
pas non plus rentrer dans un grand
climat de suspicion ou de paranoïa alors
où est le juste équilibre mais c'est
justement pour éviter qu'on rentre dans
un climat de paranoïa et de peur qu'il
faut que l'État décrivent un plan
d'action qui soit acceptable et qui
mettent en place des mesures nécessaires
pour assurer enfin moi je partage
j'aurais peut-être pas dit comme ça mais
ce qu'a dit le président de la
République c'est-à-dire je pense que il
fut un temps où vous vous rappelez on
parlait de cinquième colonne
c'est-à-dire des géants qui s'infiltrer
un peu partout dont on ne se méfiait pas
moi je dis pas aujourd'hui qu'on a faire
une cinquième colonne mais on parle d'un
hydre islamique sincèrement on a vu le
sujet quand on a travaillé sur la
réglementation de l'ouverture des écoles
privées hors contrat c'est bien parce
qu'il y avait au sein de l'Éducation des
choses qui débordaient quand j'entends
de nombreux
qui dit comme d'autres mers on a signalé
qui avait des images qui avait des
discours extrêmement radicaux et on
imagine bien que ces discours peuvent
séduire des personnes un peu fragiles
qui à un moment peuvent basculer dans
cette sorte d'idéal qui qu'il porte mais
qui est comment dire extrêmement
dangereux pour nous donc je crois qu'il
faut que chacun soit paisible mais un
peu comme on dit à chacun soyez
vigilants quand il y a à côté de vous à
bagages abandonné soyez paisible soyez
tranquille mais
osons dire les choses tranquillement
c'est comme ça je crois qu'on rassurera
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens vous
parlez d'imam radicaux à la marque
justement il a été question ces
dernières heures de cet imam de Gonesse
la mosquée qui était fréquentée par
Michael harpon il était fiché s depuis
2015 pour son fondamentalisme religieux
selon les informations du poids il faut
l'objet d'une mesure d'obligation de
quitter le territoire français en 2015
ça n'a jamais été exécuté est-ce que
c'est inquiétant pour vous aussi bien
cette situation et qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça dit c'est inquiétant ça
dit aussi notre naïveté
parce que chaque fois qu'il y a une
mesure administrative il faudrait quand
même qu'elle soit exécutée et on sait
pour être à la commission des lois avec
avec Françoise que malheureusement ce
n'est pas toujours le cas c'est vrai
qu'il y a des recours et qu'un droit
français on a droit à chaque fois à
recourir à une décision pour continuer
une décision mais c'est vraiment
inquiétant moi je je me dis qu'il
faudrait que une fois pour toute nous
cessions toute naïveté toute
complaisance et que les actes prennent
le pas prennent le pas sur sur ce
discours ambiant qui ferait que chaque
fois que nous lisons quelque chose
contre l'islamisme radical nous passions
pour des gens qui
seraient voilà un mot sur cette
manifestation aussi agonase de ninja
comme cette manifestation organisée en
soutien à Michael harpon par Adama
Traoré manifestation finalement
interdite Christophe Castaner l'a dit ce
matin était
indécent l'organisation d'un tel défilé
dans ce contexte
c'est une apologie au terrorisme pas
plus pas moins le droit il est très
clair le fait de soutenir un terroriste
et quand monsieur harpon pour avoir
écouté personnellement sa déclaration
sur facebook dit que Michael harpon
n'est pas un terroriste c'est faux et on
peut pas accepter et quand le président
de la République dit les administrations
toutes seules ne pourront rien je veux
bien le croire mais qu'elle commence
déjà à faire à faire ce qu'elle doit
faire c'est à dire le préfet du Val
d'Oise le préfet du Val d'Oise n'aurait
même pas dû attendre de savoir si on
arrive même pas empêché
c'est un assassin c'est un assassin
qu'on vient même c'est ce n'est qu'un
assassin on n'autorise pas une
manifestation en soutien d'un assassin
là on est dans le terrorisme donc le
préfet il aurait dû prendre la décision
immédiatement quand il a eu connaissance
de cette déclaration de manifestation ça
n'aurait même pas dû arriver au niveau
du ministre de l'Intérieur
cette situation c'est quand même un
petit peu surréaliste quelques jours
après
soutenir un criminel s'il s'agit d'un
criminel il a tué quatre personnes il en
a blessé une une cinquième je ne vois
pas comment décemment on peut organiser
une manifestation pour pour soutenir
cette individu plus largement maintenant
on parle beaucoup
d'Islam d'Islam radical
la radicalité est une chose est-ce que
la pratique de l'islam doit
systématiquement systématiquement
conduire à une forme de suspicion
vis-à-vis de cette de cette religion
alors non mais sauf qu'en ce moment ce
qui vient de se passer
et après tous les attentats qui se sont
produits en France on sent bien que
petit à petit l'état d'esprit change il
faut quand même que l'on fasse attention
dans l'histoire de l'humanité à bien des
reprises on a
stigmatisé un certain nombre de
religions de groupes de groupes de
personnes parce que un arbre caché la
forêt
méfions-nous même si aujourd'hui ces
propos sont peut-être considérés comme
comme trop sage mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'il y a eu une exéction comme celle-ci
il faut vraiment tout rejeter en et
transformer tout le monde en suspect
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat effectivement attention à ne pas
stigmatiser aussi bien sûr une religion
une population merci beaucoup Michel
bouton merci à la marque merci Françoise
merci Denis Jacob d'avoir participé à ce
débat on poursuit sur ce même thème en
rejoignant la salle des conférences du
Sénat avec vous Alexandre car vous êtes
avec Philippe Bas le président les
républicains de la commission des lois
pour continuer à parler des suites de
cette attentat et oui Philippe puisque
la commission des lois va auditionner
demain matin Christophe Castaner et
Laurent Younes sur cette attentat qui a
frappé la préfecture de police de Paris
quel est l'enjeu de cette audition qui
sera retransmise
il y a eu ce massacre terrible tous les
Français je crois ont à l'image la
souffrance des familles des enfants des
conjoints des mères qui étaient hier à
la cérémonie de la préfecture de police
et c'est avant tout ces images
ce deuil de ces familles ce deuil que
partage les Français que nous avons à
l'esprit pour dire
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour que notre organisation
interdise l'irruption de l'intérieur
même de nos services de renseignements
de criminels qui en quelques minutes
peuvent arracher la vie à plusieurs de
leurs collègues de travail et blessés et
notre collègue
le ministre de l'Intérieur
a reconnu publiquement
que de son point de vue il y avait eu
des failles le parquet national
antiterroriste et saisit la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement que
préside Christian Cambon à laquelle
j'appartiens à auditionner le ministre
pour que nous puissions recueillir dans
le contrôle parlementaire des
informations qui ne peuvent pas être
dévilgés et demain nous additionnerons
le ministre pour que
avec la plus grande transparence
possible ils puissent informer le Sénat
et à travers le Sénat les Français qui
suivront l'audition de son analyse mais
aussi des décisions que sans retard
il a décidé de prendre il doit prendre
pour remédier aux failles qu'il a
diagnostiquée vos collègues députés les
républicains ont pointé la
responsabilité du ministre de
l'Intérieur dans cette affaire et ce
qu'ils ont raison selon vous mais le
ministre de l'Intérieur le gouvernement
à chaque fois qu'il y a eu un attentat
et malheureusement la France a subi
cette épreuve à plusieurs reprises ces
dernières années sont naturellement en
responsabilité mais pour autant ce qui
nous paraît essentiel c'est d'avoir une
appréciation plus précise plus
rigoureuse de ce qui doit être réformé
nous sommes là nous pour aider les
tasses réformer à chaque fois qu'il y a
une difficulté pour dire au ministre de
l'Intérieur quels sont nos
recommandations et demain à travers les
informations qu'il nous communiquera en
réponse à nos questions nous serons dans
cette disposition d'esprit qui est
d'être constructif le problème
aujourd'hui c'est bien celui de ce qui a
de ce qui a dysfonctionné et rendu
possible ce massacre en dernier mot sur
une éventuelle création d'une commission
d'enquête au Sénat sur cette affaire
comme c'est le cas à l'Assemblée est-ce
que vous êtes favorable
nous verrons bien en fonction des
informations que nous recueillerons si
nous estimons que des investigations
supplémentaires doivent être conduites
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignements à déjà délibéré sur la
nécessité de posséder à d'autres
auditions dans le cadre du secret qui
permet de préserver les méthodes
d'action de nos services pour pas les
hébruiter ce qui est important et
nous-mêmes nous verrons s'il y a lieu
d'aller plus loin pour l'instant cette
question pour ce qui concerne le Sénat
n'est pas une question d'actualité nous
avançons au fur et à mesure en fonction
des exigences de notre fonction de
contrôle parlementaire et de proposition
à l'égard de l'organisation de la
sécurité intérieure très bien merci
beaucoup Philippe pour toi pour votre
réponse
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour cette
interview dans cette salle des
conférences où l'on voit peu à peu
affluer du monde à une demi-heure des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement on
voit d'ailleurs la garde républicaine
qui est en train de se préparer pour
accueillir l'ouverture de la séance et
dans une demi-heure et on passe tout de
même bien au deuxième débat de cette
émission également dans l'actualité les
suites de l'incendie de Lubrizol à Rouen
des taux de dioxine élevés ont été
relevés à préau au nord au nord-est de
Rouen hier Elisabeth borne a
particulièrement chargé l'entreprise
devant les sénateurs une commission
d'enquête sénatoriales va être mise en
place on en débat tout de suite mais
d'abord Adrien devellet vous fait le
point l'entreprise n'a pas été à la
hauteur dans la gestion de cette
catastrophe pendant deux heures devant
la commission d'enquête du Sénat la
ministre de la transition écologique a
tenu l'entreprise doublement responsable
responsable probable des conditions de
déclenchement de l'incendie responsable
aussi des réparations on est dans
l'application du principe
pollueur-payeur l'industriel aura à
indemniser les préjudices notamment ceux
subi par les agriculteurs car la crainte
c'est que des dioxines soient retrouvées
sur les cultures une analyse a révélé
mardi à taux 4 fois plus élevé que la
normale dans l'air la ministre se veut
prudente les premiers résultats dont
nous disposons aujourd'hui sont
inférieurs au seuil existant pour les
produits agricoles nous avons besoin de
plusieurs campagnes pour pouvoir se nous
prononcer dans la mesure où les dioxines
peuvent s'accumuler dans les animaux et
dans les végétaux prudence également sur
la nature des 5253 tonnes de produits
chimiques qui ont brûlé notamment se
présente chez Normandie logistique une
entreprise mitoyenne à l'usine Lubrizol
classée sesveso et pourtant peu
contrôler Elisabeth burn a annoncé la
mise en place d'un comité de suivi en
collaboration avec les ministères de
l'Agriculture et de la santé l'enquête
sur le terrain pour identifier l'origine
de l'incendie a débuté ce mardi et pour
débattre des suites de l'incendie de
Lubrizol j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir en
plateau Pascal Martin bonjour vous êtes
sénateur hussier de la Seine-Maritime
encore patron du département de la
Seine-Maritime pour quelques jours
quatre jours et membre de la commission
de l'aménagement du territoire également
à nos côtés ronandante avec bonjour
sénateur RDSE de la Loire-Atlantique
vous êtes vice-président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire première question pour vous
Pascal Martin votre réaction à cette
information sur les taux de dixing qui
sont élevés dans l'air à Rouen et aux
alentours la concentration est 4 fois
supérieure au seuil habituel est-ce que
cela vous inquiète alors bien sûr que
cela inquiète parce que ce feu s'est
incendie gigantesque j'ai été au contact
puisque dès le jeudi midi j'étais auprès
des sapeurs-pompiers pour
vous même pompier d'ailleurs
tout ce qui peut
générer de l'inquiétude et tout à fait
légitime de la part des populations
parce que les conséquences de cet
incendie et elles sont sanitaires
environnementales économiques et donc
nous attendons chaque jour parce qu'il
faut du temps entre les débuts des
analyses et les conclusions de ces
analyses pour pouvoir en tirer toutes
les conséquences Agnès buzat a
d'ailleurs tenté de rassurer sur ce
sujet ce matin je vous fais réagir tout
de suite pendant tac mais on écoute la
ministre de la Santé ce matin chez nos
confrères de France Info
nous allons évidemment attendre les
nouveaux prélèvements mais je tiens
quand même à dire que c'est plus
important que la normale mais cela reste
dans les seuils admis de toxicité donc
enfin en dessous des seuils admis
toxicité en tous les cas d'après les
informations que j'ai
à ce que cela peut suffire à rassurer la
population d'être en dessous des seuils
de toxicité d'autant qu'il y a aussi des
médecins qui mettent en garde sur un
risque cancérogène à long terme s'il y a
une exposition mais dans la durée moi je
crois que on est on a plusieurs
difficultés sujets par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé à Rouen il y a effectivement
les conditions de l'accident parce que
l'entreprise a respecté tous les process
il y a les conditions de la surveillance
il y aura des décisions à prendre on en
a beaucoup parlé hier soir sur pour y
revenir quelques minutes sur les
conditions de l'alerte et de la mobilité
comment on répond la population et puis
il y a cette question effectivement de
l'inquiétude et y compris qui nous
interpelle nous on en parlait à
l'instant c'est dire qu'est-ce que nous
on dit si on dit il y a pas de risque
évidemment tout le monde va venir c'est
pas sérieux si on ne fait que souligner
des risques potentiels ont participé de
du caractère anxiogène
transparence doit être fait dans la
longue durée Pascal Martin hier
également la ministre Elisabeth borne
qui a été assez longuement auditionnée à
charger l'entreprise elle compte bien
faire appliquer à Lubrizol le principe
du pollueur payeur elle juge que
l'entreprise n'a pas été à la hauteur
dans la gestion de cette catastrophe
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors c'est
vrai que ce principe de de peleur payeur
étant hondables maintenant il faudra
connaître les causes réelles du début
d'incendie puisque c'est de tout cela
qui dont il s'agit en ce qui concerne
Lubrizol j'ai cru comprendre que le
directeur général du groupe Lubrizol qui
est un groupe américain c'était engagé à
apprendre
toute sa part de responsabilité parce
qu'il y aura encore une fois des
conséquences à court à moyen et à long
terme et donc moi je trouve tout à fait
normal que la ministre rappelle la
responsabilité de l'entreprise
Renan Dantec mais n'y a-t-il pas aussi
une responsabilité du gouvernement et du
lég quand on voit par exemple que le
projet de loi sur la société de
confiance à assoupli les normes
appliquées au site ceveso cela a permis
que le préfet de Seine-Maritime donne
l'autorisation à l'usine d'accroître ses
capacités de stockage sans qu'il y ait
une réelle évaluation des risques alors
je crois que cette question dans le cas
de la commission d'enquête va être une
question tout à fait centrale je me mets
un candidat pour représenter le groupe
RDSE en tant que c'est nature écologiste
rattaché gros RDSE pour y participer moi
il me semble qu'on a une vraie question
aujourd'hui déjà sur la qualité du
contrôle c'est-à-dire le ministère de
l'Environnement a perdu beaucoup de
poste
les DREAL donc les directions régionales
de l'environnement qui sont chargées de
la surveillance ont perdu des moyens
humains alors pas obligatoirement dans
les derniers mois mais quand même dans
la durée ont perdu des moyens humains et
qu'effectivement moi je ne me satisfais
pas de la réponse de la ministre hier
soir qui dit mais finalement si on
simplifie les procédures ça veut dire
moins de paperasse pour les agents des
et donc plus de contrôle sur le terrain
je trouve que c'est une
réponse un peu raccourci je crois qu'il
faut aujourd'hui se poser la question
des moyens humains du contrôle ça ça me
semble tout à fait central parce que moi
je ne suis pas pour qu'on déplace ces
entreprises ailleurs soit en milieu
rural en consommant l'espace agricole
soit dans d'autres pays moins regardant
parce que l'environnement global il
perdrait donc moi je pense que on a
surtout un enjeu très fort sur le
contrôle qu'on n'a pas obligatoirement
les moyens de se contrôler et notamment
les moyens du contrôle d'une approche
systémique on ne sait pas ce qui s'est
passé d'où est parti l'incendie une tête
pas partie de l'entreprise elle-même ce
qui veut dire qu'on avait peut-être une
analyse de risque juste dans
l'entreprise mais une analyse de risque
insuffisante sur ce qui pouvait se
passer à l'extérieur tout ça il faudra
qu'on le voit mais cette question des
moyens humains et je crois qu'il faut
d'ores et déjà un moratoire dans la
durée sur les moyens des dréals et les
reconsidérer au vu de ce qui s'est passé
à Rouen effectivement il y a eu un
problème peut-être aussi de perception
du risque sur une autre zone d'ombre
c'est l'entreprise Normandie logistique
voisine de Lubrizol parce qu'elle Martin
elle n'a pas communiqué les matières
combustibles qu'elles stockées ni là
dangerosité des produits stockés
calez-vous votre niveau d'information
sur ce sujet qui vient le même que votre
la police des installations classées des
établissements ces vaisseaux relèvent
des pouvoirs de l'État donc de son
représentant dans le département le
préfet du département de la
Seine-Maritime et donc j'ai découvert
comme vous parce que le département de
la Seine-Maritime concentre sur son
territoire près de 60 établissements ces
vaisseaux et le président du conseil
départemental que je suis encore pour
quelques jours où le sénateur depuis
quelques jours également n'avait pas
connaissance de ces données mais là
aussi
j'ai souhaité être membre de cette
commission d'enquête ce sera une des
questions que nous serons amenées à
examiner durant cette enquête une
commission d'enquête qui va s'intéresser
aussi à l'ensemble des sites cesveso je
voudrais que l'on regarde une carte qui
montre un petit peu et bien la façon
dont ces sites ces vaisseaux sont
présents en France aujourd'hui en France
il y a pas moins de 1312 dont 705 en
seuil de risque haut sur la carte on le
voit il y a beaucoup de sites en
Seine-Maritime en Rhône-Alpes ou encore
également en région parisienne Ronan
Dantec on le voit c'est donc un sujet
qui concerne de très nombreux élus
locaux j'ai été vice-président de Nantes
métropoles en charge du risque donc mais
si c'est réseau je les connais on a même
connu
un nuage toxique à Nantes où il y a
quelques points de comparaison possible
avec ce qui s'est passé à Rouen c'était
en 1987 moi je pense que aujourd'hui il
faut que l'État et les collectivités
territoriales se remettent autour de la
table sur la gestion du risque et la
gestion de la crise moi ce qui me semble
très important dans notre commission
d'enquête c'est qu'on regarde aussi
comment a été géré la crise où là
vraiment
après AZF j'étais déjà le vice-président
on a mis en place un centre de gestion
de crise qui fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
qui s'appelle le créole qui sert à la
fois pour des crises majeures mais aussi
qui sert finalement pour les crises du
quotidien je pense que c'est cet outil
là qui est ma connaissance n'existait
pas sur l'agglomération de Rouen il faut
qu'on le met dans le pot commun de la
réflexion aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit
bien qu'on a des crises technologiques
toujours possible et le fait qu'on est
des bâtiments classés chez les autres
c'est une bonne chose ça veut dire qu'on
les connaît ça veut dire qu'on les
surveille mais on a aussi des risques
climatiques ça on l'a vu et on a dû un
risque terroriste dans tous les cas
comment donc des temps court on fait en
sorte que la population et les bons
gestes qui sont pas obligatoirement les
mêmes d'une crise à l'autre ça veut dire
qu'on a une capacité à prévenir et
simplement une à 3h du matin ça ne
marche pas ça vraiment et c'est ce qu'on
a dit à la ministre ça doit être dans
les conclusions du débat qu'on doit tout
savoir après cette crise là ça sera au
coeur des travaux certainement de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale dont
vous serez a priori tous les demandes
tout à fait normalement donc qui cherche
en cette commission d'enquête également
à tirer les conséquences de ce terrible
événement et les enseignements pour
l'avenir merci à tous les deux pour ce
débat et tout de suite nous allons
rejoindre Alexandre Poussard dans la
salle des conférences du Sénat à un
quart d'heure de questions d'actualité
vous êtes avec Didier mandeli sénateur
les républicains de la Vendée parce que
lui aussi il s'interroge après ce
terrible incendie de Lubrizol mais oui
toujours sur cette incendie de l'usine
Lubrizol alors le gouvernement c'est
depuis le début de cette incendie c'est
voulu rassurant sur la toxicité de
l'événement mais on a appris hier soir
que les seuils de dioxine était 4 fois
plus élevés que la normale au nord-est
de Rouen c'est inquiétant sur le bout
inquiétant on dépasse pas pour l'instant
les seuils de toxicité mais ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre que le
gouvernement a parlé quatre voies dans
cette affaire dès le début avec des
messages discordants quelquefois et je
pense qu'une seule une seule voie aurait
été plutôt préférable non pas pour
rassurer à tout prix la population mais
pour lui dire la vérité tout simplement
en disant que les tests et les analyses
qui allaient évidemment intervenir
permettrait de faire la lumière est-ce
que justement la commission d'enquête
qui va être créée au Sénat sur cette
affaire doit éclairer sur les failles de
la gestion de l'État sur cette accident
industriel oui je pense que des
responsabilités évidemment sont
partagées mais on a j'ai dû d'ailleurs
la ministre hier soir manque de culture
du risque et des démarches de prévention
dans notre pays surtout les sujets y
compris les catastrophes naturelles et
donc je pense que on a failli sans doute
à ce niveau là en terme d'information
aux populations sur sur les risques et
puis l'industriel évidemment une grande
part de responsabilité puisque
les éléments que révèleront sans doute
les analyses et les documents de la
Commission en 4 permettront sans doute
de faire la lumière encore plus alors on
parle beaucoup de Lubrizol mais moins de
l'usine voisine Normandie logistique qui
a aussi été incendié qui contenait des
produits dangereux mais selon la loi
elle n'était pas obligée de déclarer ces
produits dangereux qu'elle stockaient là
encore il y a une faille dans le système
ouais ce qui est très surprenant sur un
site classique réseau que le voisin
immédiat à proximité immédiate qui
stockait des produits de de l'entité
classique n'est pas cette obligation
alors que les sites sont vraiment très
très proches donc ça paraît très
surprenant ce stade
la loi la loi 2018 pour une société de
confiance a assoupli ses normes ces
autorisations environnementales autour
des usines à risque est-ce que le
gouvernement a sa part de responsabilité
dans cette assouplissement des normes
sur ces usines globalement je pense que
nous avons tous une part de
responsabilité parce que nous souhaitons
tous simplifier
accélérer les procédures etc et que
peut-être que ce drame cette catastrophe
va alerter chacun d'entre nous pour dire
voilà très bien il faut que nous
puissions travailler rapidement dans de
meilleures conditions mais pas n'importe
quel prix non plus très bien merci
beaucoup Didier mandeli pour vos
réponses
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour cette
nouvelle intervention et j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau Benjamin
Morel bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférence en droit public à Paris 2 on
va parler ensemble et bien des thèmes
qui vont être balayés lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement une science qui va
commencer dans 10 minutes maintenant
d'abord votre commentaire tout de même
sur et bien cet incendie de Lubrizol on
a dit que cette projet de loi sur la
société de confiance à laver assoupli
les normes dans la gestion des sites CV2
cet assouplissement des normes c'est
beaucoup demandé par les élus c'est
souvent demander par les législateurs
mais on voit qu'il y a tout de même des
limites oui les normes si vous voulez ne
sont pas non plus que des gènes pour les
élus locaux ou que des gènes pour
pour les personnes privées ce sont des
une façon pour l'État et par la loi et
bien de pouvoir contrôler justement ce
qui relève d'activités qui peuvent être
des activités problématiques du point de
vue de l'intérêt général du bien commun
et éventuellement également du coup du
point de vue de la sécurité donc là il y
a probablement une évaluation à avoir
sur ce qui a conduit à cet incident à la
fois du point de vue des
dysfonctionnements administratifs du
point de vue des éléments de cette loi
qui pourrait éventuellement être revu la
très clairement ce qui est en train de
se mettre en place tant à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat cette évaluation
de cette incidence un peu plus à froid
est un élément essentiel et ça fait
partie du pouvoir de contrôle du coup du
Parlement
de la commission d'enquête sénatoriales
alors que l'on voit et bien arriver de
plus en plus de monde dans la salle des
conférences du Sénat tout à l'heure on a
vu d'ailleurs le secrétaire d'État
Laurent Nunez qui arrivait salle des
conférences la séance devrait s'ouvrir
sur une question portant sur et bien
l'attentat de la préfecture de police de
Paris est-il intéressant pour vous que
des parlementaires cherchent à
constituer une commission d'enquête sur
ce sujet elle est actée à l'ASSE
international c'est plus en débat au
Sénat mais cela pose tout le problème de
l'articulation entre cette commission
d'enquête et la question du secret
défense oui et si vous voulez ça va
également poser la question de
l'articulation entre les questions
d'aujourd'hui et l'audition demain donc
là on a vraiment une interrogation et
très clairement pour le Sénat
aujourd'hui il s'agit sur ce sujet
extrêmement politique extrêmement
polémique et bien dater une présence
d'acter réellement une réflexion mais
fondamentalement là-dessus le Parlement
est dans son rôle parce que on a des
dysfonctionnements administratifs je
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le l'une des fonctions du
Parlement Christophe partenaire
justement dans la salle des conférences
du Sénat Benjamin Morel l'une des
fonctions du Parlement c'est de dévaluer
les politiques publiques et de contrôler
le gouvernement alors ce contrôle c'est
pas seulement un contrôle politique
c'est également un contrôle des
éventuels dysfonctionnements
administratif la très clairement ce que
l'on voit c'est que et bien vous avez eu
des dysfonctionnements concernant le
secret des fonds bien ce secret défense
vous savez que lorsque il y a des
auditions à la Commission de la Défense
la commission des affaires étrangères
mais elle arrive que c'est commissions
se tiennent à huis clos que certains
l'occurrence la délégation au
renseignement hier matin à auditionner
les deux ministres c'était complètement
à huis clos bien sûr vous n'avez pas de
compte rendu en tout cas pas de
compte-rendu qui paraissent donc il peut
y avoir un contrôle du Parlement et ce
contrôle du Parlement il peut se faire
au-delà de ces questions de secret
défense dans un dans un environnement
qui est un environnement clos mais qui
n'exclut pas évidemment contrôle donc
une commission d'enquête qui est souvent
rendue publique tel qu'on a pu le voir
par exemple sur l'affaire Benalla ça
paraît beaucoup plus compliqué alors ça
paraît plus compliqué mais vous pouvez
avoir des auditions à huis clos oui
effectivement et à partir de là vous
pouvez si tout le dossier se situe dans
le champ du secret défense évidemment il
va être compliqué d'avoir une quelconque
publicité de la Commission et vous
pouvez avoir des auditions à huis clos
et à partir de là vous pouvez avoir une
commission qui s'enrichit de réflexion
tenue à huis clos et qui font des qui
fait des qui qui en vient à des
préconisations qui allait évidemment
sont publiques tandis que l'on voit
Christophe Castaner dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat en discussion avec Jean-Paul
Delevoye ainsi que le patron du groupe
de la République en marche François
Patriat c'est lui d'ailleurs qui devrait
ouvrir le bal des questions tout à
l'heure avec et bien justement une
question autour de l'attentat de la
préfecture de police de Paris comment
est-ce que vous jugez justement la
gestion de l'exécutif sur ces sujets
régaliens on sait que c'était pas
forcément la spécialité d'Emmanuel
Macron il y a tout le débat autour de
Christophe Castaner est-ce que vous
jugez l'exécutif la hauteur c'est pas
moi d'en juger si vous voulez mais je
pense que pour le coup il y a une
transformation de la stratégie du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que pendant
les deux premières années on a vu
qu'Emmanuel Macron et bien s'adresser
d'abord et avant tout à sa base
électorale cette base électorale elle
est composée essentiellement des
lecteurs de centre droit et d'élection
de centre des lecteurs de centre gauche
la synthèse macronienne est vraiment
cette synthèse descente on a vu lors des
dernières européennes qu'Emmanuel Macron
avait perdu une grande partie
d'électorat de centre gauche qui s'est
réfugiée dans l'abstention ou pour une
grande partie d'entre lui dans le vote
europécologie les Verts donc aujourd'hui
on va arriver également Édouard Philippe
le Premier ministre voilà en train de
saluer les uns et les autres dans la
salle des conférences du Sénat Benjamin
je vous laisse poursuivre donc du coup
avec cette mise en avant des sujets
régaliens vous avez une volonté
d'élargir la base électorale d'Emmanuel
Macron pas seulement sur une partie de
la droite partie de la droite qu'il a
réussi à récupérer aux élections
européennes mais également à d'autres
couches de la société quand vous écoutez
le discours d'Emmanuel Macron au
parlementaire il y a à peu près un mois
il disait très bien ça il disait grosso
modo aujourd'hui la République en marche
ne doit pas être un parti bourgeois
c'est-à-dire que ça ne doit pas être
seulement un parti qui s'adresse à la
bourgeoisie ça doit être un parti qui
s'adresse également au classement
moyenne au classe inférieur et ces
classes moyennes s'éclass inférieures
sont aujourd'hui assez sensibles à ces
sujets régaliens que ce soit sur les
questions migratoires sur les questions
de sécurité et donc à partir de là il
faut développer un discours et ce
discours là par contre son problème son
c'est qu'il risque de troubler une
partie des parlementaires d'Emmanuel
Macron une partie de sa base aujourd'hui
tout les tensions à la République en
marche effectivement cette phrase sur le
fait que lrem n'est pas un parti de
bourgeois il l'a dit à propos de la
tenue de ce débat sur l'immigration un
débat qui s'est tenu à lundi à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui va se tenir
à 16h30 ici dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
vous l'avez dit ce débat et bien il
trouble un petit peu la majorité entre
une aile droite qui a peut-être pas
envie de parler de la me de la question
des quotas et puis de l'autre côté une
aile gauche qui a beaucoup plus envie de
parler intégration ou ne pas parler
d'immigration oui c'est toute la
difficulté d'Emmanuel Macron si vous
voulez Emmanuel Macron a été élu avec
une synthèse qui tout de même était
plutôt une synthèse de centre gauche et
les membres de sa majorité même au Sénat
sont composés d'abord et avant tout de
parlementaires qui viennent plutôt du
centre gauche aujourd'hui son électorat
est plutôt de centre droit voire plutôt
de droite donc arriver à conjuguer cette
transformation du discours et en même
temps le maintien d'une majorité dont on
a vu qu'elle pouvait être tremblante sur
la question du CETA sur la question de
la loi il est immigration c'est l'une
aujourd'hui des grandes difficultés de
la majorité se débat là et bien il est
assez compliqué d'autant que et bien
tant pour la gauche que pour la droite
qui fond de cette question une vraie
question d'identité politique et bien
c'est évidemment une façon d'exister
politiquement de montrer qu'elles sont
en désaccord avec la majorité et d'aller
du coup et bien chercher la difficulté
la faille dans ce aujourd'hui le coffre
fragile de la majorité et bien merci
beaucoup Benjamin Marel pour votre
analyse alors que dans quelques minutes
vont commencer les questions d'actualité
au gouv
erneur rejoindre Alexandre Poussard dans
la salle des conférences du Sénat il y a
un autre sujet qui intéresse les
sénateurs ce sujet c'est l'agriculture
et vous êtes avec Franck motoget
sénateur socialiste pour en parler
alors que les agriculteurs ont manifesté
hier contre la grille bashing il y aura
beaucoup de questions cet après-midi sur
le malaise des agriculteurs est-ce que
l'agribashing est une des causes
principales de ce malaise
non moi je pense que le malaise vient de
plus loin les agriculteurs nous disent
leur malaise leur incompréhension et moi
je pense que ce qui se passe là
s'inscrit dans une crise de civilisation
voilà tous les tous les domaines de la
société sont concernés par les problèmes
liés à la transition au climat
etc et moi je considère que les
agriculteurs ne doivent pas être les
books émissaires de problèmes à
caractère généraux qui concerne en
réalité l'ensemble de la communauté des
citoyens voilà les paysans ne sont pas
le problème les paysans sont une des
solutions aux problèmes divers complexes
auquel la communauté des citoyens est
confrontés mais alors justement dans ce
débat de civilisation sur le
réchauffement climatique notamment sur
l'utilisation des pesticides il ne faut
donc pas dénigrer les agriculteurs
je pense qu'il faut être il faut être
prudent dans la façon dont on s'exprime
à leur égard d'abord l'agriculture et
les diverses voilà il faut pas tout
mettre dans le dans le même sac moi je
note et j'étais député à l'époque que
l'agriculture française a su prendre des
orientations extrêmement fortes que
d'autres secteurs de la société n'ont
pas prise je veux faire allusion à la
loi de 2014 que qu'apportait Stéphane Le
Foll et que le ministre de l'Agriculture
actuelle Didier guilhomme a apporté en
tant que rapporteur au Sénat il était à
l'époque dans les sur les sièges du du
Parti socialiste au Sénat voilà
l'agriculture s'est engagée dans
l'agroécologie de manière extrêmement
forte elle ne demande qu'à poursuivre
dans ce sens-là mais il faut savoir
aussi l'entendre la comprendre par
rapport à certains sujets qui sont d'une
grande grande complexité technique très
bien merci beaucoup Franck montoger pour
votre réponse et on écoutera tout à
l'heure votre question au ministre de la
Culture Didier Guillot mais on va tout
de suite se rendre dans l'hémicycle avec
Alice Bardot qui va nous présenter le
programme de ces questions d'actualité
oui Alexandre alors lors des questions
au gouvernement comme vous l'avez dit il
sera justement question du malaise des
agriculteurs alors entre la perspective
des zones de la mise en place des zones
de non traitement pesticides et des
accords de libre-échange ainsi que la
grille bashing les raisons de leur
colère sont multiples et les sénateurs
s'en feront le relais cet après-midi
mais la séance sera ouverte par une
question du président du groupe de la
République en marche au Sénat au Premier
ministre au sujet de l'attentat à la
préfecture de police de Paris alors hier
lors des questions au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale Édouard Philippe a
longuement répondu au député les
républicains Éric Ciotti lui affirmant
qu'il assumait tout ce qui a été fait
dans l'État au nom du gouvernement et je
cite toujours qu'il n'y aurait pas
chercher
prétendu responsabilité de tel ou tel
dans telle service le Premier ministre a
également reconnu un dysfonctionnement
d'État alors le ministre de l'Intérieur
aura également à faire face au sénateur
cet après-midi et sera entendu donc
aussi demain je le rappelle par la
commission des Lois du Sénat alors hier
devant celle de l'Assemblée nationale il
a reconnu lui aussi de
dysfonctionnements alors concernant
cette fois-ci donc le suivi du tueur de
la préfecture de police de Paris Michael
harpon donc selon lui son mariage en
2014 aurait dû provoquer un nouveau
contrôle dans le cadre de son
habilitation secret défense la cloche va
bientôt sonner tout de suite les
questions au Gouvernement
[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée nous n'avons pas reçu à cette
heure d'observation il y en a t-il en
séance
je n'en vois point il est donc adopté
sous les réserves d'usage
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité ou gouvernement
notre science et naturellement
retransmise en direction publique Sénat
sur notre site Internet et chacun sera
attentif au respect du temps nous sent
que nous sommes dans une séquence de 15
questions
et naturellement respect des uns et les
autres je donne immédiatement la parole
au président François Patriat pour le
groupe de la République en marche
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues 7 minutes
7 minutes ont suffi pour plonger la
préfecture de police dans l'un dans la
des drames les plus douloureux de son
histoire et la France dans
l'incompréhension et dans la stupeur ce
sont les mots du chef de l'État ils ont
été forts ils ont été justes au nom des
sénateurs du groupe la République en
marche de tous mes collègues je souhaite
joindre notre solidarité unanimement
exprimée à l'égard des familles des
victimes et de l'ensemble des forces de
l'ordre le 3 octobre la France a été
frappée au cœur des symboles même de
l'ordre républicain leur est à la peine
l'heure est à la douleur nul doute que
l'enquête judiciaire permettra de faire
toute la lumière sur les circonstances
de ses actes et sur les motivations de
leur hauteur mes chers collègues nous
devons faire bloc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaiterais saluer le
travail des services de renseignement
qui quotidiennement des joues nombre
d'attentats et ceux aux quatre coins de
l'hexagone 59 attentat déjoué depuis
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
rappelé ou combien l'état entends lutter
avec force et détermination contre les
dysfonctionnements éventuels dans
l'ensemble de nos institutions
sachant traqué partout au cœur des
services de l'État dans nos écoles nos
transports nos hôpitaux la
radicalisation nous devons pour se faire
trouver les moyens permettant de lutter
efficacement
ce fléau vous avez saisi vous avez saisi
l'inspection des services des
renseignements d'une double mission
Monsieur le Premier Ministre une centrée
sur les fêtes qui se sont déroulées à la
préfecture de police de Paris sur les
éventuels signalement une sur l'ensemble
des services de renseignements
spécialement impliqués dans la lutte
contre le terroristes alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pouvez-vous évoquer les
pistes de travail mises en place pour
prévenir les dérives et les
dysfonctionnements potentiels dans ce
domaine ou combien difficile je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier Ministre
Édouard Philippe monsieur le Premier
ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président patriar faire bloc faire bloc
c'est
l'un des termes que le Président de la
République a utilisé hier dans la cour
de la préfecture de police de Paris
pour dire quelle était la réaction de la
nation face à cette attentat commis en
plein cœur d'un des symboles d'un des
moteurs de l'ordre républicain en France
faire bloc
c'est d'abord faire bloc avec
ceux qui restent
la famille des quatre agents
tués brutalement jeudi dernier avec
les époux ou les conjointes avec les
enfants avec les parents les amis avec
les collègues avec tous ceux qui ont
assisté
à l'attentat
ou avec tous ceux qui n'étant pas
présent
doivent continuer à vivre avec cette
brutalité et cette absence
faire bloc c'est aussi assumer
que la nation dans son ensemble
l'État mais au-delà de l'État la nation
sont unanimement soudés par le désir de
gagner ce combat ce long combat se
difficile combat qui a été engagé par
notre pays par notre société par notre
état par notre République contre
l'islamisme radical le terrorisme qui
est au nom du dévoiement d'une religion
en temps remettre en cause ce que nous
sommes et ce à quoi nous aspirons
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le Président hier
à l'Assemblée nationale et aujourd'hui
devant le Sénat je veux dire que le
gouvernement ne se placera jamais dans
la position de dire que tel ou tel
à telle époque ou dans tel service
aurait en la matière était
n'aurait pas été à la hauteur des enjeux
je veux le dire très simplement
très sincèrement
à partir de 2015 les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés ont fait de leur mieux
pour parer les
urgences les plus pressées pour éviter
dans toute la mesure du possible la
commission de nouveaux attentats et même
si l'on peut et c'est bien légitime dans
une démocratie les critiquer
politiquement
il faut dire et assumer et probablement
être fier collectivement de ce que fasse
à ses horreurs et face à ses actes ils
ont pris des décisions qui toutes
allaient dans le bon sens je veux le
dire très simplement mais très
sincèrement de la même façon monsieur le
Président j'ai dit que faire bloc ça ne
voulait pas en la matière aller chercher
telle ou telle responsabilité dans tel
ou tel bureau
je ne veux pas faire l'enquête
judiciaire j'en suis incapable au sens
technique et au sens juridique
mais je sais je sais que lorsque des
signaux faibles comme on dit c'est à
dire des signaux qui ne se traduisent
pas nécessairement par des signalements
mais des signes faibles sont émis
je sais qu'il est parfois difficile
c'est vrai probablement dans un service
de renseignement c'est vrai dans une
collectivité territoriale c'est vrai
dans une administration c'est vrai dans
une association c'est vrai partout
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
vous le savez tous qu'il est parfois
difficile de traiter ces signaux faibles
de transformer ces signaux faibles en
une action et je ne veux pas pointer la
responsabilité de ce qui s'étend poser
des questions aurait le cas échéant
omis de transmettre cette information
parce que monsieur le Président je veux
que nous fassions blocs les services de
renseignement les forces de l'ordre
remportent semaine après semaine des
victoires face aux terrorisme elles sont
toujours discrètes et parfois nous n'en
parlons pas mais elles sont réelles
leurs échecs
eux sont toujours spectaculaires et
dramatiques
et nous avons et vous avez la
responsabilité de poser des questions et
nous avons la responsabilité d'y
répondre mais je crois que
collectivement nous pouvons dire que
fairblock c'est soutenir les forces de
l'ordre et les services de renseignement
pas simplement quand ça va bien
mais quand c'est difficile enfin
monsieur le Président ferblock ça veut
dire aussi mettre en place des mesures
pour que ces choses cette absence de
signalement lorsque des signaux faibles
peuvent avoir été émis ne se
reproduisent pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé
d'une part qu'une inspection des
services de renseignement soit mis en
place afin de déterminer exactement
parallèlement à l'enquête judiciaire
mais déterminer comment la chaîne
identification d'éventuelles signaux
faibles signalement et action a pu être
mise en oeuvre à la préfecture de police
dans ce cas et que dans un deuxième
temps plus exactement parallèlement
c'est la deuxième décision qui a été
prise j'ai souhaité qu'une revue
générale de l'ensemble des services de
renseignements du premier cercle et
d'une partie du deuxième cercle soit mis
en oeuvre de façon à ce que avec
l'encadrement avec l'encadrement
intermédiaire au plus près de tous ceux
qui vivent et qui travaillent dans les
services de renseignement il soit permis
d'identifier
d'être certain que nous identifions
absolument tout les éventuels signaux
faibles qui seraient émis et qui ne se
serait pas traduit par des signalements
de façon à ce que là encore nous ne nous
retrouvions pas dans la situation qui a
peut-être été à l'origine de ce drame le
président de la République hier à la
préfecture de police a eu des mots forts
il a eu des mots justes il nous revient
c'est la responsabilité de ce
gouvernement c'est la responsabilité de
l'ensemble de ceux qui contribuent à la
sécurité de la nation il nous revient de
les mettre en oeuvre je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Premier ministre
la parole
est à notre collègue Henri Cabanel pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture non partage de
la valeur allez acclimatique aller à
sanitaire lourdeur administrative c'est
à et maintenant zone de non traitement
hier les agriculteurs ont crié leur
détresse
arrêtons de tirer sur l'ambulance un
agriculteur se suicide tous les jours
cela ne suffit pas que veut cette
société qui se clive dangereusement
faire disparaître notre agriculture
s'alimenter des produits importés ne
respectant pas nos exercices sanitaires
pourquoi accuser inlassablement nos
agriculteurs
je rappelle qu'il n'utilise que des
produits homologués par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire
sanitaire seul légitime pour les
autorisations de mise en marché il n'y
aura pas de transition écologique sans
nos paysans ils l'ont compris ils
veulent jouer un rôle fondamental et ils
veulent répondre à la tente sociétale
pourquoi ne parle-t-on pas de tous les
efforts entre-pris depuis des années
pour s'inscrire dans une agriculture
durable pourquoi ne cibler que le
mauvais sans jamais parler du bon le bon
c'est par exemple viti rêve projet de
territoire innovation de la grande de
grande ambition en Gironde que ma décrit
ma collègue Nathalie Delattre ou partout
en France l'agriculture raisonnée la
haute valeur environnementale il faut
agir collectivement avec un véritable
une véritable stratégie co-construite
avec la filière les consommateurs les
distributeurs les industriels avec une
ligne unifiée et partagée monsieur le
ministre personne ne peut nier votre
soutien aux agriculteurs votre combat
dans l’agribashing est constant
mais quelle cohérence quand les temps
courage une transition agroécologique et
quand même temps il vit de les Chambres
d'agriculture de leur contenu et de leur
proximité dans une seule logique
budgétaire ce projet ambitieux ne pourra
être réussi sans les chanter cultures
monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous faire aboutir un vrai
partage des valeurs objectifs essentiels
comment comptez-vous faire appliquer
l'article 44 cette même loi qui concerne
l'étiquetage mais qui bien plus
globalement pose le problème de la
concurrence déloyale face à des dangers
importés traités avec des produits
interdits en France et consommés par des
consommateurs qui les refusent pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
d'agriculture et d'alimentation Monsieur
Didier Guillaume vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cabanel vous avez eu raison de
à travers votre question qui a été à
peine de poser un constat le constat qui
est celui de la coupure aujourd'hui
entre une partie de la population et ses
agriculteurs et aujourd'hui le cri
d'alarme que je veux lancer à travers
votre question ici au Sénat il faut que
nos concitoyens aiment leurs
agriculteurs et aiment l'agriculture
pourquoi je dis cela tout simplement
parce que pour la troisième année
consécutive pour la troisième année
consécutive l'agriculture française a
été lui a été décerné agriculture la
plus durable du monde que l'alimentation
fournie par nos agriculteurs et la plus
sûre la plus saine et la plus durable
d'Europe et oui vous avez raison ce
dénigrement cet agribashing est
absolument insupportable et nous devons
essayer d'avancer le plus possible pour
y faire face pour le combattre il est
absolument inadmissible que des gens
envisagent découvert entre dans des
élevages ouvre les portes comme je suis
allé d'autres jours dans l'ordre mettre
le feu à des bâtiments d'élevage ce
n'est pas acceptable la justice doit
faire son travail et doit condamner ses
actes je voudrais saluer les
agriculteurs et leurs syndicats qui hier
étaient dans la était dans les rues pour
crier leur colère face à ce dégrement et
face à cette agribashing les
manifestations sont tenues avec le plus
grand calme possible et je veux
féliciter les organisateurs il y aura
d'autres rendez-vous avec ce que je veux
affirmer ici hier le Président le
premier ministre l'a évoqué devant la
l'Assemblée nationale la lutte contre le
dénigrement est un combat constant du
gouvernement le fait d'arriver à faire
en sorte que la loi egalim
fasse son œuvre et que le revenu de
l'agriculteurs augmente c'est le
deuxième sujet et quand on reste
toujours l'occasion d'en parler à
nouveau parce que le temps est écoulé
mais franchement aimons notre
agriculture parce que si ce n'est pas
nos agriculteurs qui nous fournissent
l'alimentation elle viendra d'ailleurs
et elle sera moins bonne
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à notre collègue Christine pruneaux pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologiste avait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre après avoir donné son accord à
la Turquie de pénétrer dans le nord-est
de la Syrie afin de créer une dite zone
de sécurité le président des États-Unis
semble rétropédaler pour autant
aujourd'hui des chars et des véhicules
blindés se dirigent vers la frontière
inoffensive est imminente pour les
Kurdes cette zone de sécurité équivaut à
une zone de péril et de mort certaine
États-Unis ou pas de toute façon
Erdogan se moque totalement du droit
international et salissant vergogne avec
des mouvements islamistes contre les
Kurdes pourquoi ce priverait-il
d'ailleurs à chaque nouvelle offensive
aucune sanction réelle la communauté
internationale
l'abandon programmé des cures de syrien
ne constituent pas seulement une faute
morale mais aussi une faute stratégique
rappelons-nous bien que s'il est à
islamique n'existe plus aujourd'hui
c'est en grande partie grâce au
combattant et combattants de Kurdes ces
femmes formidables faut-il désespérer de
l'influence de notre gouvernement dans
ce conflit le groupe CRCE attend une
protection immédiate de l'ONU de nos
amis Kurdes seul symbole d'une véritable
future démocratie laïque au Moyen-Orient
et il faut des sanctions financières
lourdes voire un blocus une mise au banc
carrément de la Turquie ne rien faire
monsieur ménis c'est le déshonneur de la
France ne rien faire c'est abandonner la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
voire même l'encourager indirectement
nous avons malheureusement en France
dans notre pays des exemples monsieur le
ministre le retour de la paix dans cette
région exige maintenant des décisions
fortes il est grand temps du
gouvernement français et de la
communauté internationale j'ose espérer
que vous allez encore me répondre
comment vous pourriez agir sur ce
conflit je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au secrétaire
d'État auprès du ministre de l'Europe
des Affaires étrangères monsieur Lemoine
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice permettez-moi au préalable
d'excuser Jean-Yves Le Driant qui est à
la conférence de reconstitution du fond
mondiale aujourd'hui à Lyon un immense
respect je crois que c'est ce que nous
partageons très largement vis-à-vis des
combattants et des combattantes comme
vous l'avez souligné des forces
démocratiques syriennes dont les Kurdes
qui ont joué un rôle clé un rôle
déterminant pour permettre la défaite
territoriale
daesh avec le soutien de la coalition
internationale le courage de ces hommes
de ces femmes des FDS les sacrifices
qu'ils ont consentis très clairement
appellent notre reconnaissance et le
président de la République a pu leur
témoigner à plusieurs reprises au nom de
la nation on les recevant au Palais de
l'Élysée très récemment encore hier le
président de la République a reçu la
porte-parole des FDS il a marmhd et il
est très préoccupé s'agissant de
l'opération turque très préoccupée car
le combat contre daesh se poursuit aux
côtés des FDS et reste la première de
nos priorités en Syrie et donc il est
important de préserver CFDs dans ce
contexte que vous avez rappelé alors
l'immense respect il appelle aussi et
bien à faire respecter ces femmes et ses
hommes et c'est ce que nous disons aux
Américains c'est ce que nous disons au
Turc avec clarté avec franchise et très
clairement
c'est seul le dialogue politique qui
permettra dans la durée de garantir une
place au kurde dans la série ainsi
qu'aux autres minorités notamment les
chrétiens le courage les sacrifices des
Kurdes nous obligent ils nous ont obligé
hier ils nous oblige aujourd'hui et nous
oblige pour demain aussi merci monsieur
le ministre je vais passer la parole
notre collègue et Hervé gilet pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain c'est
sa première question et c'est son
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a quelques jours plus de
20000 policiers manifestés exprimant
leur malaise la crise dans la fonction
publique hospitalière est-elle que
madame la ministre des Solidarités de la
Santé reconnaît elle-même que le pacte
de refondation des urgences sera
insuffisant pour calmer les esprits
médecins infirmier pompier sont tous
exposés en première ligne à la précarité
aux violences de la société les drames
récents dans l'éducation nationale
illustre également ce désespoir lié à
l'absence de reconnaissance des
personnels enseignants dans ce contexte
de défiance la réforme territoriale de
la Direction des finances publiques
menées au patchage visent en réalité une
nouvelle fois à supprimer plus de 2000
postes dès l'année prochaine et 15000 à
terme monsieur le ministre personne
n'éduque derrière l'annonce de cette
réforme se dissimule un nouveau
transfert de charges vers les
collectivités territoriales et vous le
savez pertinemment que les dotations
financières de l'État pour le
fonctionnement des maisons France
service public seront largement
insuffisantes
les seuls interlocuteurs de nos
concitoyens seront des animateurs
généralistes dont nous ne savons rien
aujourd'hui ni de leur formation ni de
leurs compétences et avec cette
privatisation déguisée du service public
vous n'offrez aucune garantie en
particulier celle de la confidentialité
surtout quand ces tâches sont confiées à
des buralistes de moins en moins
nombreux dans un monde rural une
nouvelle fois discriminée et comment ne
pas évoquer un risque d'aggravation de
la fracture sociale si vous ignorez la
fracture numérique alors que c'est une
des clés de vos économies 20% de la
population ont décrochage numérique
comme le rappelle le Défenseur des
droits rien n'est prévu pour leur prise
en charge qui reviendra dans les
accueils de nos communes qui assument
sans moyens infectés le rôle d'écrivain
public Les Numériques monsieur ministre
quelles sont vos objectifs de réduction
d'effectifs et de maintien des services
publics de proximité quelle garantie
nous apportez-vous comment repensez-vous
le rôle des communes et des EPCI qui
devront suppléer aux difficultés
d'accessibilité numérique
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'action des comptes publics
monsieur Darmanin vous avez la parole
ce premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur Sator
bienvenue et je voudrais répondre à
votre question sur votre département de
la Gironde il touche celui-ci en
particulier et sur la réforme en général
des finances publiques dont vous savez
que la direction générale des finances
publiques est à la fois la fusion de la
comptabilité publique et du service des
impôts ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
monsieur le sénateur n'est pas
acceptable dans les années qui nous ont
précédé quel que soit d'ailleurs les
gouvernements c'était une fermeture de
213.oris par an quel que soit ces
gouvernements et nous avons dû nous
adapter par un supplie chinois
territorial puisque je suis moi-même élu
local à une manque de vision sans doute
d'une partie de l'organisation de nos
réseaux et la suppression des effectifs
n'y est pas pour grand chose Monsieur le
Sénateur dans la perspective de leur
enfant de trésorerie il y a des
transformations et je pense que chacun
de nos concitoyens les voit du réseau
des finances publiques qui sont nés la
transformation de Bercy l'impôt à la
source je crois souhaiter notamment par
votre groupe politique voilà quelques
mois encore la déclaration tacite du
revenu à partir de l'année prochaine
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
je rappelle que 4000 agents des finances
publiques s'occupent de la taxe
d'habitation et de son contentieux quel
est le premier contentieux qui arrive
dans les bannettes si j'ose dire des
agents des finances publiques quant aux
auront supprimé cette taxe d'habitation
il y aura évidemment un certain nombre
d'agents qui doivent faire autre chose
ou en tout cas différemment et vous en
avez bien loin monsieur le sénateur de
la vision simplement numérique ou pas
numérique et la maison les maisons
France services seront des maisons qui
remplaceront en partie mais pas
totalement bien évidemment ce que nous
faisons mal jusqu'à présent puisque dans
les trésories je regardais notamment
votre département 4 au moins trésorerie
rural que qui sont dans votre salle
d'influence quand on veut dire ainsi le
seul sénateurs sont ouvertes deux
après-midi seulement par semaine jusqu'à
16h30 et donc les Français qui
souhaitent s'y rendre doivent prendre
une demi-journée de congés et je pense
que ce n'est pas le bon service public
que nous devons rendre on doit adapter
ce service public j'ai pris l'engagement
qu'en 2020 il n'y aura aucune fermeture
de trésorerie aucune fermeture de
trésorerie
en 2020
il y aura aucune
je sais que ça vous surprendre mesdames
et messieurs parce que c'est pas arrivé
depuis 21 ans en 2020 il y aura aucune
fermeture de trésorerie et nous
signerons avec les prisons du Conseil
départementaux qui seront d'accord les
nouvelles cartes il y en a une quinzaine
déjà de présidents qui m'ont donné leur
accord tous les autres y compris la
Gironde nous continuons de discuter
merci vous avez 9 secondes monsieur
gilet si vous voulez répliquer et comme
c'est votre anniversaire vous avez trois
secondes de plus voilà
merci merci une nouvelle fois monsieur
le Président tout simplement monsieur le
ministre moi je crains simplement que
ces mesures vont continuer à creuser la
fracture territoriale a renforcer
l'insécurité financière et juridique des
citoyens et des élus locaux surtout ceux
qui sont éloignés des centres de
décision et c'est en total contre sens
des attentes actuelles merci
la parole est à notre collègue Danny
waterblay pour le groupe Les
Indépendants les République et le
territoire vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre le 15 et 22 mars
prochain les Français vont vivre
vraiment de démocratie très importants
celui de renouveler sur tout le
territoire les conseils municipaux de
chacune de nos villes de nos communes de
nos villages cette période électorale
approchant de nombreux mers indépendants
sans étiquette et non inscrit m'ont
interpellés quant à la nuance politique
qui leur sera attribuée par
l'administration en effet c'est le
mystère d'intérieur qui procède
attribution des nuances politiques dans
un cadre strictement défini
juridiquement
présenterait toutes les garanties
nécessaires en matière de respect de la
vie privée liberté publique ainsi la
diversion de la CNIL du décembre 2013
qui a remplacé l'ancien décret du 30
août 2001 pourtant création aux missions
d'intérieur d'un fichier des élus et des
candidats aux élections au suffrage
universel a confirmé tout l'intérêt de
la solution de ces nuances
lors du dépôt de candidature le candidat
déclare s'il se présente avec
l'étiquette politique et il peut se
déclarer sans étiquette ou indépendant
ce sont alors les préfets sans vouloir
remettre en cause leurs dons de
discernement qui attribue la nuance sur
des critères suivants connaissance
historique des candidats programme du
candidat investir ou soutien reçu pour
les communes de 1000 habitants et plus
avant le scrutin pour les communes de
moins de 1000 habitants après l'élection
du maire
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre si vous souhaitez intégrer dans
la grille de nuance poétique les
classifications sans étiquette
indépendants où non inscrit en dehors du
divers droites ou du divers de gauche
que le connaissons et si oui à quelle
date cette grille sera communiquée et le
sera-t-elle dans le mémento mémento qui
a 6 mois de l'échéance n'est toujours
pas disponible et ne figure pas les élus
ni les candidats
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur mini l'intérieur monsieur
Castaner merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'abord je voudrais
vous rassurer sur le même manteau comme
l'usage le veut les services du
ministère de l'Intérieur sont en train
de l'affiner pour qu'il soit au mieux
parfait et qu'il puisse être mise à
disposition dans le délai de six mois
donc dans les semaines qui viennent dans
les jours qui viennent il sera
communiqué il sera disponible vous
m'interrogez plus globalement sur cette
question d'attribution politique je dis
d'attribution politique parce que c'est
une fonction ancienne qui remonte à la
Troisième République parce que depuis la
Troisième République on a voulu avoir un
suivi non pas d'identification de tel ou
telle mère mais en réalité un suivi du
mouvement politique que notre pays
connaissait c'est vrai que cela a permis
de faire en sorte que on est un système
d'information élection qui puisse
identifier les appartenances politiques
et pourtant vous le savez effectivement
et vous l'avez dit ce n'est pas
forcément simple parce que beaucoup de
citoyens s'engage en politique comme
beaucoup de politiques sont aussi et
avant tout des citoyens et que du coup
vouloir rentrer dans le cadre d'une
étiquette n'est pas toujours un exercice
facile la CNIL dans la préparation du
décret de 2014 qui a organisé cela
effectivement prévu expressément que
l'on demande aux candidats qui déposent
la liste et la structure administrative
pour les municipales sous-préfecture ou
préfecture qui reçoit les candidatures
interroge le candidat pour qu'il précise
dans quelle catégorie politique il
entend être inscrit mais effectivement
il y a la possibilité pour le préfet si
le candidat ne le souhaite pas de
rechercher un certain nombre d'éléments
et vous les avez cités qui permettent de
donner une attribution politique et nous
savons tous ici en particulier au Sénat
que pour les plus petites communes ce
système n'est pas forcément adapté je
sais que vous aurez l'occasion dans
quelques jours de travailler sur le
texte des relations avec les
collectivités locales et que vous
souhaitez aborder ce sujet je veux vous
indiquer que je suivrai avec attention
cette discussion que mon cabinet est à
votre disposition et que nous pourrions
parfaitement envis ager de fixer un
seuil à 3500 à 9000 habitants en deux ça
duquel l'appartenance politique au grand
courant que nous connaissons n'est pas
indispensable je suis sur ce sujet
totalement à votre écoute
monsieur neufs
les 9 secondes vous
pour dire c'est mon anniversaire quand
même j'aurai trois secondes de plus donc
peu importe si 35 ou 5000 il y a des
gens qui s'engagent dans des livres
d'intérêt communaux et qui veulent être
sans étiquette voilà et on les met dans
une case et après dans leur lit ils ont
des gens qui sont deux d'appartenance
différente donc ça pose problème voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire merci
la parole est à notre collègue Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne pour le groupe les
républicain
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres j'aurais aimé ne pas avoir
à reprendre la parole dans cette
émission après une nouvelle frappe de
l'islam radical malheureusement
l'histoire béguée a préparé après Nice
après Magnanville après
Saint-Étienne-du-Rouvray après
Strasbourg après Marseille après
Carcassonne après Toulouse après Trèbes
c'est au cœur d'un service
anti-terroriste qu'un islamiste a tué
nous pensons bien sûr aux quatre
policiers lâchement assassinés à leur
famille et à l'ensemble de leurs
collègues endeuillés le président de la
République parle de bâtir une société de
vigilance est-ce à dire qu'il entend
exonéré sa propre responsabilité et
qu'il veut faire porter injustement une
part de responsabilité aux Français or
ce qui s'est passé dans la préfecture de
police c'est la longue dégradation le
compromis la chape de plomb qui fait
vous êtes dans l'espace public le
politiquement correct ce n'est pas en
jetant à la figure de ceux qui
s'inquiètent du désarmement moral de
notre société et de sa communauté
islamophobes que nous gagnerons cette
guerre c'est au contraire en renonçant
et enolérant plus aucune manifestation
aucun signe de ce qui conduit et annonce
la radicalisation des esprits que nous
nous protégerons vos mots ne suffisant
ne suffiront plus et ce sont vos actes
désormais qui seront jugés alors
Monsieur le Premier Ministre allez-vous
vraiment vous attaquer au terreau de
l'islamisme et à toutes les formes de
communautarisme
pour vous répondre
la parole communiste de l'intérieur ce
Castaner c'est le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
vous avez évoqué évidemment le drame et
chacun a en tête ses victimes et chacun
en tête toutes les victimes et je pense
aussi au moment où je vous parle assez
de victimes et cela devrait être
confirmé devant une synagogue en
Allemagne qui sont tombés aujourd'hui
aussi sur les coups de terroristes
évidemment nous ne sommes qu'au début du
constat mais je sais que le procureur
terroriste a été saisi en Allemagne je
pense à cela aussi mais je vais répondre
très concrètement à votre question il
nous faut sur ce sujet nous armer
totalement nous armées en termes de
moyens de renseignements et vous le
savez près de 1900 emplois seront créés
sous ce quinquennat pour lutter à
travers le renseignement contre le
risque du développement du radicalisme
et de l'islamisme radical de la même
façon nous renversons l'ensemble des
moyens de disposition pour circuler un
certain nombre d'agents qui peuvent
présenter un risque à travers les moyens
qui seront consacrés au Cinéas plus
globalement le Premier ministre m'a
rappelé il n'y a pas un jour une heure
ou nos services ne sont pas mobilisés
pour déjouer un risque et qu'un risque
éventuel ne devienne pas un risque avéré
le premier sera rappelé les 59 attentats
terroristes qui ont été neutralisés par
l'intervention de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure mais nous devons
effectivement être extrêmement vigilant
et ne rien laisser passer qui soit une
atteinte à la République et une menace
pour les Français je voudrais être très
factuelle madame la sénatrice et vous
donner quelques indications depuis 2018
362 personnes qui étaient inscrits au
fameux fichier ffprt ont été éloignés et
on les a fait en sorte qu'il quitte le
territoire depuis 2017 quatre mesures
ont été prononcées pour expulser des
prédicateurs radicalisés depuis 2018 129
débits de boissons 12 lieu de culte ont
été fermés 9 établissements culturels et
associatifs ont été aussi des écoles ont
été fermées 503 contrôle Koda ont été
mises en oeuvre et je conclure en vous
disant que c'est en mettant tous ces
moyens et en les mobilisant tous que
nous looterons pans à pan mètre carré
par mètre carré pour qu'aucun mètre
carré de notre République n'échappe à
nos valeurs républicaines
[Applaudissements]
je suis au regret de vous dire qu'il y a
une
naïve et qu'il faut véritablement passer
des paroles aux actes vous le savez très
bien aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
continuer à vous défausser sur la
société et l'État lui seul doit prendre
toutes ses responsabilités utilisez tous
les moyens qu'il a sans possession pour
rendre ces moyens beaucoup plus
efficaces et pour véritablement lutter
contre cette radicalisation des esprits
qui gangrène tous nos territoires merci
la parole est à notre collègue Nadia
sologo pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les paysans étaient hier dans
la rue ils sont dans un contexte
difficile multifactorielle dont il ne
voit pas l'issue ils sont coincés entre
des forces contraires on leur demande
plus de qualité mais avec chaque jour
plus de contrainte la loi egalim devait
leur permettre de gagner leur vie et les
cours se sont effondrées on leur
demandait très exemplaire et de ne pas
craindre des concurrents qui le seraient
moins on leur demande de nous nourrir et
on les suspecte de nous empoisonner et
maintenant cette terrible sécheresse
achève de les mener au désespoir et de
nouveau des forces contradictoires d'un
côté vous monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture que j'ai entendu dire on
ne peut pas regarder pendant 6 mois
tomber l'eau et six mois la chercher et
de l'autre côté sur le terrain les
instructions du ministère de l'écologie
pour faire démonter tous les seuils
interdire les retenues d'eau et même le
nettoyage des points d'eau qui
permettrait simplement d'abreuver les
animaux
monsieur le ministre les paysans vont
très mal ils ne sont pas en situation de
se trouver coincé entre des injonctions
contradictoires alors je fais porter ma
question sur un point précis pour se
préparer à la prochaine sécheresse qui
sera peut-être dans quelques mois l'eau
on la retient ou on la laisse s'écouler
je vous remercie
merci
c'est le ministre de l'Agriculture
Guillaume de la parole Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
comme le sénateur Cabanel tout à l'heure
je crois que nous sommes tous d'accord
pour partager le constat que vous faites
de la situation actuelle mais je
voudrais vous répondre très clairement
sur sur l'eau il n'y a aucun problème
aucune différence aucune divergence
entre le ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire et le ministère
de la Culture et de l'alimentation tout
simplement tous
mais je vais vous je vais vous répondre
très très clairement et vous le savez en
plus monsieur Bizet tout simplement
parce que le premier ministre arbitré et
qu'aujourd'hui les services de l'État
doivent mettre en oeuvre ce qui a été
arbitré il y a de cela quelques mois et
vous le savez madame la sénatrice et je
vous sais très investi dans ce domaine
non on ne peut pas regarder l'autre
ambigu du ciel pendant 6 mois et après
il a changé les six autres mois on sait
très bien on sait très bien que le
réchauffement climatique va continuer et
que si nous voulons que l'agriculture
française soit résiliente alors il
faudra qu'elle soit irriguée et ça c'est
la position de tout le gouvernement mais
en même temps on ne peut pas faire tout
et n'importe quoi et je veux saluer là
encore les agriculteurs je veux saluer
encore les agriculteurs qui en disant en
dépensé 30% de moins d'eau pour irriguer
leur culture voilà une des innovations
aussi de l'agriculture donc pour ce
faire pour l'année 2020 nous avons
annoncé la possibilité de créer 60
retenues d'eau sur le territoire
national
oui oui oui je sais de quoi vous voulez
me parler 60 60 retenue d'eau afin de
pouvoir ne pas aller au-delà de la
substitution mais de retenir l'eau au
moment où elle tombe et de pouvoir la
restituer au moment où il y a la
sécheresse si nous avions fait cela les
dernières années et je rappelle que ça
fait 20 ans que les retenues d'eau sont
interdites si vous avez en fait ça les
dernières années alors dans le Massif
central où jeter la semaine dernière les
bêtes qu'on pourrait continuer à être
sur les prairies je vous remercie
madame monsieur
merci Monsieur le Ministre oui c'est
bien les chiffres que j'avais on parle
de s'entretenues d'eau donc pour toute
la France c'est-à-dire pas même une par
département donc ce mauvais jeu de mots
je dirais que c'est une goutte d'eau
dans cette catastrophe donc ce qui
serait très intéressant mais vous me
rassurez sur ce point je me demandais
s'il a une prochaine fois il fallait que
je pose la même question au ministre de
l'écologie pour voir si j'aurai la même
réponse
en tout cas j'étais quand même très
heureuse que vous me répondiez dans ce
sens et je suis convaincu qu'il faut
qu'on vous laisse monsieur le ministre
avancer sur ce point dans le sens que
vous nous indiquez je suis rassurée
faute de quoi nous allons tuer nous à
notre agriculture à coups de paperasse
paperasse qui ne cache peut-être qu'une
incapacité à mettre à se mettre d'accord
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
la parole est notre collègue Cédric
Perrin
bon le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur
Jeudi 3 octobre monsieur le ministre
l'inimaginable s'est produit au cœur de
la préfecture de police frappé par un
ennemi de l'intérieur
je voudrais tout d'abord m'incliner
devant la douleur des familles leur
exprimer ma solidarité et saluer au nom
de mes collègues sénateurs le sacrifice
des victimes Aurélia trifiro Damien
Ernest Anthony Lancelot Brice le meska
et permettant permettez-moi d'avoir moi
aussi une pensée pour nos amis allemands
victimes d'une attaque de l'attaque
d'une synagogue monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais que nous puissions nous en
tenir au fait et comprendre ce drame
gravissime depuis 2015 des dizaines
d'attentats ont été déjoués grâce au
service de renseignement je souhaite
saluer le travail de nos forces de
l'ordre mais comment un membre de ses
services a-t-il pu prendre pour cible
ses camarades comment un terroriste
a-t-il pu travailler dans un lieu dont
la mission est celle d'identifier les
individus dangereux
cet attentat implique de surcroît un
informaticien qui disposait de l'accès à
un nombre important d'informations
sensibles à quel fichier avait-il accès
avez-vous
identifié ces contacts en France à
l'étranger quelle protection est mise en
œuvre pour les petits policiers
potentiellement en danger j'aimerais
saluer à ce sujet le travail de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement et du président Cambon qui
préside cette délégation et qui
contribue à cette affaire monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez rendu par service à
personne en répétant le mantra quelques
heures après les faits il n'y a ni faute
ni dysfonctionnement ni angle mort vous
expliquer avoir dit la vérité des
éléments connus au moment où vous vous
exprimiez mais aviez-vous interrogé le
scrt ou la DGSI placée sous votre
tutelle pour savoir si l'auteur des
faits était connu de leur service
n'aurait-il pas été plus prudent de vous
en tenir à la compassion et au constat
de la gravité de la situation
le phénomène de radicalisation existe au
sein de l'administration dans des
secteurs stratégiques nous devons être
en capacité d'écarter ces personnes
radicalisées porteuses d'une idéologie
claire celle de détruire notre société
démocratique et les valeurs qu'elle
représente alors monsieur le ministre
pour terminer un peu d'introspection
quel phénomène de cécité de faiblesse de
l'acheter de crainte a-t-il pu conduire
à l'absence de réaction je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Laurent du nez secrétaire d'État après
du ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cédric Perrin
d'abord merci d'avoir rendu hommage aux
victimes de l'attaque terroriste de
jeudi dernier je vous en remercie nous y
sommes très sensible bien évidemment
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
dire est le ministre l'a rappelé que
tout est fait maintenant depuis 2014
depuis 2015 pour lutter contre le
terrorisme en matière de moyens humains
de moyens budgétaires en matière de
personnel ou nous mobilisons énormément
d'effectifs en matière d'échange
d'information entre les services et tout
est fait pour que nous soyons le plus
performant possible et ce sont de
nombreux services qui travaillent sur
ces questions concernant l'attaque de la
semaine dernière et bien évidemment
pardon cette action va se poursuivre
vous l'imaginez bien concernant
l'attaque de la semaine dernière vous
posez un certain nombre de questions
extrêmement précises et vous vous doutez
bien que je ne peux pas répondre à
toutes ces questions mais certaines oui
au moment où avec Christophe Castaner
nous rendons à la préfecture de police
de Paris jeudi dernier bien évidemment
le ministre consulte moi-même nous
consultons les services spécialisés qui
ne connaissent pas cet individu il n'est
pas connu du renseignement territorial
c'est la question que vous posez il
n'est pas connu de la direction générale
de la sécurité intérieure service que
j'ai dirigé il n'est pas connu pour une
simple et bonne raison c'est que les
signaux de radicalisation de cet
individu pour des raisons qu'il va
absolument nous falloir déterminer ne se
sont pas transformés en signalement
comme le préciser monsieur le Premier
ministre et c'est bien là toute la
difficulté de cette affaire et c'est
pour cela que une enquête judiciaire est
en cours qui nous permettra de
déterminer les relations qu'a eu cet
individu et nous pourrons répondre à
votre question sur ces contacts bien
évidemment de la même façon que une
inspection du service du renseignement
va diligenter une enquête auprès de la
Direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de Paris pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi ces
signaux ne se sont pas transformés en
signalement ce qui je vous le conseille
peut paraître extrêmement aberrant dans
un service en charge de la lutte
antiterroriste et c'est tout cela qu'il
nous faudra illicider quand aux
transmission de données auxquelles il a
pu procéder l'enquête judiciaire nous
éclairera très vite maintenant nous
souhaitons avec Christophe Castaner que
sur ce sujet là pour la protection de
ton fonctionnaire de police les choses
puissent aller le plus vite possible
merci
[Applaudissements]
notre collègue maintenant la parole
n'adigne Groslay certonnay pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres ma chère collègues ma
question s'adresse à la ministre des
Solidarités de la Santé qui n'est pas là
aujourd'hui l'offre de soins est en
train de se renforcer et les Français se
voient le voit déclaré madame la
ministre il y a moins d'un mois
sans vouloir gâcher cette optimisme je
souhaiterais attirer votre attention sur
la situation catastrophique de nos
services d'urgence un peu partout en
France depuis 6 mois nous constatons
tous la recrudescence de
dysfonctionnement à répétition dans les
services d'urgence hospitaliers
c'est le cas demander département la
Sarthe à l'hôpital du Bailleul hôpital
pour lequel j'avais alerté l'année
dernière quant à l'accès à l'IVG en
raison d'un manque de médecins et
maintenant c'est au tour du SMUR qui est
à l'arrêt faute de médecins urgentiste
véritable hôpital de proximité le pôle
santé sarteloir dessert un bassin de vie
de plus de 150 000 habitants dans un
territoire rural une réorganisation des
personnels ne réglera pas cette
dégradation constante de l'offre de
soins qui ne cesse de s'aggraver vous le
savez aussi bien dans la Sart que dans
l'ensemble du territoire français en
revanche les personnels vous demandent
depuis des mois des mesures très
concrètes en termes de lit de
recrutement de revalorisation salariale
ou encore de moyens supplémentaires
vous pensiez que le mouvement allait
s'essouffler alors que la crise
s'intensifie votre pacte de refondation
ou encore le PLFSS 2020 ne répond ni à
leur exigence ni au respect de principe
d'égalité d'accès aux soins après le
désertification médicale nous arrivons à
un nouveau stade de la décomposition du
paysage sanitaire face à un maillage qui
craque les mesures proposées ne
répondent pas à l'anxiété grandissante
des populations qui voient leur service
d'urgence fermer un à un je pense
notamment à l'hôpital de Saint-Calais
dont la fermeture temporaire a été actée
très récemment dans un contexte de
déménagement du territoire des services
publics ne croyez-vous pas madame la
ministre qu'il est temps de prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour ses services en
investissant massivement pour résoudre
cette crise et pourquoi pas envisager
des états généraux de l'hôpital
pour vous répondre la parole de la
secrétaire d'État porte-parole du
gouvernement madame siegendaï vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice gruellet certenay je
vous prie bien sûr d'abord d'excuser
l'absence de Maya manège Busin qui
actuellement participe à la
reconstitution du fond mondial à Lyon la
colère que vous exprimez l'anxiété qui à
travers votre voix s'exprime qui est
celle de nos concitoyens qui est celle
de nos personnels soignants évidemment
nous la comprenons et c'est la raison
pour laquelle depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant la ministre de la Santé s'est
attachée à y apporter des réponses
extrêmement concrètes la situation que
traverse en particulier votre territoire
résulte d'un manque structurel de
médecins auquel notre pays fait face et
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs en Europe ce
constat il est celui que vous avez dans
la Sarthe mais il est également celui
que nous avons dans de nombreuses
régions de France nous manquons
cruellement d'urgentiste dans la Sarthe
en particulier depuis le 24 septembre
nous ne pouvons plus assurer la présence
d'un médecin la nuit entre 20h30 et 8h30
du matin cette situation nous la
connaissons malgré les efforts de
l'établissement que vous n'êtes pas sans
ignorer qui a été appuyé très largement
par la RS l'agence régionale de santé et
par les autres hôpitaux du Groupe
Hospitalier de territoire il s'est avéré
pour l'instant impossible d'avoir un
médecin qui permet d'assurer la nuit
dans cette hôpital or cette présence
vous en conviendrez madame la sénatrice
est indispensable pour assurer la
sécurité des patients dans l'attente que
nous avons souhaité faire c'est que les
urgences puissent rester ouvertes la
journée avec la présence d'un médecin et
que la nuit une infirmière et une
aide-soignante permettent d'orienter les
patients évidemment en lien avec la
plateforme du 15 vous le savez la
ministre a eu la ministre a eu
l'occasion de présenter un plan d'action
pour les urgences qui est doté à hauteur
de 750 millions d'euros qui permettra de
réaliser des recrutements en nombre 80%
de ce plan est consacré à des ressources
humaines nouvelles et dont soit ils ont
assuré la sénatrice nous sommes en
quelque sorte bien sur le ballon et nous
allons le continuer merci la parole est
notre collègue Jean-Pierre Vogel
pour le gros plaid républicain on avait
la parole
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Solidarités de la Santé
nous ne pouvons naturellement nous
satisfaire de la réponse qu'il vient
d'être faite à notre collègue dont le
Saunier fermeture de la deuxième ligne
du SMUR Ploërmel fermeture du SMUR cet
été Sisteron fermeture des urgences de
nuit de films de juillet lance fermeture
partielle des urgences cet été Toulouse
fermeture temporaire des urgences de
nuit Mulhouse Sud Alsace fermeture
temporaire des urgences je pourrais
encore poursuivre car la liste est
longue notamment sarde comme ça a été
rappelé depuis le 24 septembre après
20h30 toute la nuit et pour plusieurs
semaines le Smur et le service des
urgences du pôle santé sarteloire sont
fermés cela met en péril la prise en
charge médicale du patient
25000 personnes se présentent chaque
année aux urgences de cet établissement
qui dessert un bassin de population de
150000 habitants il manque 9 médecins
urgentistes plus généralement c'est donc
la double peine pour les territoires
ruraux leur médecin généraliste qui
partent en retraite ne sont pas
remplacés et les services d'urgence de
leurs hôpitaux ferment dans nombreux
départements lorsque les urgences ne
sont pas fermés par manque de médecins
urgentistes elles sont en grève la
réponse gouvernementale n'est pas à la
hauteur des attentes des professionnels
de la santé et des territoires
aujourd'hui les personnels sont au bord
de l'épuisement que comptez-vous faire
madame la ministre pour juguler ce
mouvement qui s'amplifie que
comptez-vous faire face à la pénurie de
médecins urgentistes dans nos hôpitaux
madame la secrétaire d'État
[Applaudissements]
porte-parole du gouvernement de la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénor vosgels la situation
a bien au contraire c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle ce gouvernement a
réalisé en matière de santé des efforts
considérables je veux vous rappeler
quelques faits nous sommes depuis 10 ans
le premier gouvernement à avoir augmenté
les tarifs hospitaliers à avoir restitué
aux hôpitaux la totalité des critiques
qui ont été mis en réserve monsieur le
sénateur l'ONDAM dans le précédent
quinquennat flirtait aux alentours des 1
à
1,5%. depuis que nous sommes en
responsabilité l'ondamment en moyenne a
toujours été au-dessus de la barre des
2%, l'année dernière il était à cette
année il est à 2,5% et l'année prochaine
à
2,3%. évidemment je ne méconnais pas la
situation particulière de tel ou tel
territoire et en particulier celle des
territoires ruraux c'est pourquoi nous
avons décidé avec la ministre de la
Santé d'alouer des crédits budgétaires
nouveaux pour recruter revaloriser et
soulager les personnels des urgences et
donc ainsi assurer un meilleur service à
la population dans les trois ans qui
viennent ces mesures vont être portées à
750 millions d'euros d'ores et déjà et
c'était les premières annonces qui
avaient réalisées la ministre de la
Santé les personnels soignants des
urgences ont vu apparaître cet été sur
leur fiche de paye une prime de risque
d'un montant de 100 € net sans compter
la prime de coopération qui leur sera
attribué de manière générale oui nous
allons ouvrir des postes des postes pour
gérer des lits des postes pour le
nouveau service d'accès aux soins des
postes pour étendre l'usage de la
télémédecine et nous allons recruter là
où c'est nécessaire nous devons le
regarder au cas par cas la difficulté
c'est aussi celle de recruter c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons fait
sauter le verrou du numérus clausus qui
depuis bien longtemps pose problème dans
notre pays nous ouvrons des lits
post-urgence lorsque c'est nécessaire
une transformation en profondeur est
engagée soyez assurés que nous allons la
poursuivre
monsieur Vogel
vous avez 27 secondes
la crise des services d'urgence est sans
précédent nous sommes à un point de
rupture mais l'évidence le gouvernement
ne mesure pas le niveau d’alerte vos
propositions ne répondent en Rouin en
rien aux besoins des professionnels de
santé et des populations pire la
présentation du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2020 dévoile un plan d'économie de plus
de 4 milliards d'euros qui toucheront
encore le secteur de la santé et dans ce
tableau déjà sombre ce sont les
établissements de santé qui seront les
moins bien lotis ce sont donc encore les
personnels hospitaliers les patients qui
devront supporter les conséquences de
ces économies avec tout ce que cela
implique en termes de prise en charge du
malade auquel vous faites prendre des
risques inconsidérés
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Anne-Catherine Loisier pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste il y avait
la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues à
Biarritz comme à la tribune des Nations
Unies le président Macron n'a pas manqué
de souligner l'importance de la forêt en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique alors où l'Amazonie brûle les
forêts européennes aussi sont en danger
et n'ont jamais été aussi vulnérables
plusieurs effets se conjuguent
sécheresse à répétition forte chaleur
attaque parasitaire dégâts de gibier
croissants aujourd'hui plus aucune
essence plus aucun territoire n'était
parié à ce stade les dégâts dans les
grandes régions forestières se chiffra
plus de 2 millions de mètres cubes et on
prévoit 5 à 6 millions soit plusieurs
années de récolte au printemps prochain
car beaucoup d'arbres ne repartiront pas
à la catastrophe écologique s'ajoute le
désastre économique des communes
forestières privées de recettes des
marchés saturés des prix qui chutent et
demain des trous de production qui ne
permettront plus d'alimenter les besoins
en construction en charpente
le risque incendie aussi s'intensifie et
se répand menaçant des régions beaucoup
plus au nord face à ces réalités liées
au changement climatiques qui
s'accélèrent il nous faut dès à présent
adapter nos forêts privilégiez des
essences plus résistantes plus sobre en
eau diversifier et mélanger nos essences
l'Allemagne vient de mobiliser 800
millions pour soutenir sa filière et
plantent 300 millions d'arbres la
Pologne amillard pendant que la France
en France 70 millions car ces pays ont
bien compris l'enjeu d'une forêt
renouvelée productrice de bois d'oeuvre
et puis de carbone le gouvernement
musulministre tarde à s'emparer de ce
sujet voici des mois que les forestiers
tentent de récolter et de transformer
les arbres qui peuvent encore l'être
c'est une course contre la montre
pourtant des d'endiguer la propagation
des parasites chercher des débouchés
mais pour cela il faut un accompagnement
de l'ingénierie sur les territoires pour
conseiller les propriétaires
la une forêt qui sert à la fois les
intérêts environnementaux économiques et
sociétaux mais une forêt qui n'est
toujours pas reconnue pour ses bienfaits
à quand donc monsieur le ministre une
valorisation des forêts et du matériau
bois puis de carbone à Caen un plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique
pour renouveler nos essences et assurer
nos capacités de production à quand un
ONF restructuré pour tracer la voix
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'Alimentation monsieur Guillaume
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci pour votre question nous
étions ensemble hier une grande partie
de la journée pour le comité stratégique
forêt bois mais nous étions pas que tous
les deux il y avait aussi Daniel
grimillet et beaucoup d'autres et une
centaine d'autres personnes pour
justement tracer des perspectives de la
forêt française et notamment le plan
national forêt bois auquel vous avez
participé au sein duquel vous êtes
présidente d'un comité stratégique pour
garder ce que va devenir la forêt
française dans les années qui viennent
oui nous regardons ce qui se passe dans
cette forêt il y a deux problèmes vous
le connaissez ça bien mieux que moi
premièrement le problème parasitaire
avec les scolites nous essayons d'y
répondre nous venons de mettre 16
millions d'euros en argent sonnant et
trébuchant sur la table pour aider la
filière et la filière la très bien
prière nous en avons parlé ensemble et
puis le problème plus structurel que va
devenir cette forêt avec le
réchauffement climatique avec sa
dégénérescence et vous y avez beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet nous devons
repenser la forêt française le risque
c'est que cette forêt disparaisse ne
soit pas résiliente aussi le travail que
nous menons dans le plan national forêt
bois 2016-2026 le travail que nous
venons que nous venons avec toute la
filière d'amant en aval c'est tout
simplement de réfléchir quel devront
être de mains les essences qu'elles
devront être demain l'organisation de la
filière afin que cette forêt soit
régénérée c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans les jours qui viennent une nouvelle
organisation de l'ONF va être mise à va
être mise en place je vous le dis dans
les dans les jours qui viennent il y en
aura besoin de travailler entre l'ONF
les propriétaires privés les communes
les communes forestières c'est
absolument indispensable et puis madame
la sénatrice savait aussi et je le dis
là très tranquillement nous ne pouvons
pas continuer avec une filière forêt
bois d'amants en aval aussi déstructuré
sans aucune contractualisation sans
aucun travail commun ce n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est que ce sont les pays
étrangers de la Slovénie et autres qui
sont en train de d'exporter vers nous du
bois et des ce n'est pas possible donc
cette restructuration que j'appelle de
mes vœux faisons là ensemble merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
Olivier Paco pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
sur le ministre le 21 septembre dernier
dans le huis clos de son école vide à
Pantin une directrice se donnait la mort
elle s'appelait Christine Renan à laver
58 ans le même jour à Nice à son
domicile professeur de biologie disait
adieu à la vie s'appelait Frédéric
Boulay il avait aussi 58 ans chaque
semaine la liste des fonctionnaires qui
se suicident s'allonge policier soignant
enseignant parce qu'ils sont à bout
épuisés parce qu'il se sentent de moins
en moins considéré parce qu'ils sont mal
payés parce qu'ils sont parfois insultés
agressés parce qu'ils sont stigmatisés
alors qu'ils sont tout sauf des
privilégiés comme nos amis agriculteurs
si chaque suicide garde une part de
mystère Christine renon n'est pas parti
dans le silence laissant une lettre à
ses collègues un appel à ouvrir les yeux
je n'en lirai qu'une phrase je dois dire
aussi que je n'ai pas confiance au
soutien et à la protection que devrait
nous apporter notre institution depuis
des années dans l'éducation nationale
les réformes se succèdent s'accumulent
pourtant le malaise persiste et même
empire la confiance dont parlait
Christine renom et qui ornait le titre
de votre loi est rompu je sais votre
attachement au professeur mais que
répondez-vous à ces directeurs et
enseignants en souffrance se plaignant
de ne pas être écouté de voir toutes ces
réformes élaborées sans leur accord
tandis que l'école est le réceptacle de
tous les mots de la société
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse que le ministre
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Olivier Pacaud cette question est très
importante elle fait référence à un
événement dramatique le suicide d'une
directrice d'école j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce point
bien entendu c'est toute la société qui
doit être derrière son école dans ce
genre de circonstances
d'après les éléments dont je dispose il
n'y a pas d'augmentation du nombre de
suicides dans l'éducation nationale donc
je pense qu'il ne faut pas faire de
généralité à partir de ce que vous avez
dit ensuite et de toute façon nous
aurons un comité technique au ministère
d'éducation nationale pour établir la
réalité de des chiffres sur cette
question mais je pense qu'il faut à la
fois être dans le soutien au directeur
d'école et ne pas monter en généralité
comme vous l'avez un peu fait dans votre
question par exemple dans ce même
hémicycle vous avez voté à l'unanimité
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans c'est
une réforme importante de l'école
primaire en aucun cas on peut dire que
cette qu'une réforme comme celle-ci mais
une pression intolérable sur le système
il est donc je pense
inutile d'amalgamer des problèmes qui
n'ont pas de rapport les uns avec les
autres en revanche en revanche sur la
question de la direction d'école j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que ce problème
devait avoir une solution nous en avons
parlé dans ce dans cette hémicycle il y
a eu un rapport de sénateur Max Brisson
et Françoise Laborde qui est une
référence importante pour le futur j'ai
donc dit aux organisations syndicales
comme à la représentation nationale que
nous allions travailler sur ce sujet au
cours des prochaines semaines j'espère
pouvoir dégager un consensus c'est un
sujet qui n'a pas fait l'objet de
consensus dans le passé de façon à faire
évoluer et le statut et la fonction
directeur d'école mais aussi l'aide à
laquelle en effet ils ont droit
j'observe que ce problème n'a pas eu de
solution depuis plusieurs décennies et
que nous allons nous travailler à cette
solution nous devons le faire avec
humilité humilité humanité aussi et
aussi avec le sens de l'intérêt général
parce que nous avons besoin d'avoir
toute la société française derrière son
école nous devons donc être à la fois
solidaire vis-à-vis de ce qui s'est
passé vis-à-vis des proches de Christine
renom mais nous devons aussi être
solidaire dans notre manière de répondre
à ces problèmes et nous le ferons et le
processus est engagé je vous remercie
monsieur Paco
ne Nyons pas la souffrance dans le monde
enseignant ce que demande directeur et
enseignants monsieur le ministre c'est
d'être mieux protégé et soutenu lorsque
leur autorité est contestée par certains
parents ou même élève c'est d'être mieux
payé moins de 2000 euros mensuels au
bout de 20 ans de carrière avec bac + 5
pour un professeur des écoles c'est ça
la réalité c'est aussi tout simplement
pouvoir transmettre leur savoir à leurs
élèves au lieu de transmettre des
statistiques et des rapports à leur
hiérarchie qu'il est harcèle et qui ne
les comprend plus ce mal être de notre
école il n'est pas un exotique si nous
enseignants ne sont plus les hussards
noirs conquérants du temps Jules Ferry
il demeure les piliers de la République
lorsqu'il vacille
la parole est notre collègue Olivier
Léonard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre et je
souhaite y associer ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol depuis plusieurs mois le
peuple algérien se mobilise massivement
chaque semaine de manière exemplaire
pacifique dans les plus petits villages
comme dans les grandes villes pour
conquérir sa liberté si personne ne
demande à la France d'agir en lieu et
place de la société algérienne le
silence du gouvernement sur ces
événements et chaque jour plus gênant
depuis quelques semaines un nouveau cap
a été franchi par la jinte au pouvoir
avec des arrestations arbitraires et
l'incar l'incarcération pardon de
citoyens algériens qui expriment
leur opinion des militants associatifs
du rassemblement Action Jeunesse ou de
la Ligue algérienne des droits de
l'homme ces gens-là eux aussi sont
arrêtés alors chacun connaît les liens
de la France avec l'Algérie notamment
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
mais pour autant ne laissons pas le
cynisme politique l'emporté sur
l'honneur de notre pays il est temps de
condamner clairement les agissements
contre le mouvement démocratique à la
faute morale n'ajoutons pas une faute
politique n'oublions jamais que c'est le
peuple algérien notre allié et pas la
jante qui est en place il faut tendre la
main au peuple algérien c'est ça
l'intérêt de la France c'est bien le
peuple algérien qui sera au pouvoir tôt
ou tard cette inéductable c'est lui
notre parti notre partenaire c'est lui
l'avenir ne passons pas de du silence
gêné au silence coupable alors Monsieur
le Premier Ministre ma question est
simple le gouvernement compte-t-il
condamner les arrestations et les
incursations l'opposant politique en
Algérie
bon vous répondre à la parler au
secrétaire d'État au Premier ministre de
l'Europe des Affaires étrangère monsieur
Lemoine merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur la
situation est complexe depuis plusieurs
mois vous l'avez rappelé pour resituer
les choses rappelons la démission du
président Bouteflika puis la décision du
Parlement réunit en congrès de désigner
un président par intérim et il a été
constaté que le terme de la période
d'intérim prévu par la Constitution pour
l'organisation des élections
présidentielles a été franchie le 9
juillet dernier alors deux voies
parallèles continuent à coexister celle
de manifestants qui expriment une
aspiration forte profonde à ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre de l'histoire de
l'Algérie et celle des autorités qui
reposent sur la volonté de faire en
sorte que la Constitution algérienne
puisse s'appliquer en l'état alors dans
ce contexte le seul souhait de la France
c'est que les Algériens trouvent
ensemble les chemins d'une transition
démocratique
c'est ce que nous espérons pour
l'Algérie justement compte tenu de la
densité des liens humains de la
profondeur des liens qui nous rattachent
à ce pays c'est ce que Jean-Yves Le
Drian a dit récemment à son homologue
algérien ça brille beaucoup pardon
lorsqu'il l'a rencontré à la gmu et nous
sommes confiants oui dans l'esprit de
responsabilité de civisme de dignité qui
prévaut depuis le début des
manifestations et qui suscitent et qui
suscite effectivement l'admiration et
nous sommes attentifs à ce que cet
esprit puisse continuer à s'exprimer
pacifiquement dans le respect de la
liberté d'expression et de manifestation
la solution il n'y en a qu'une c'est le
dialogue démocratique et nous
continuerons de nous tenir au côté de
l'Algérie et des Algériens dans le
respect et l'amitié qui préside à nos
relations
monsieur Léonard vous avez quelques
secondes allez
la question
la question était très simple
qu'allez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour faire que
ces opposants c'est citoyens algériens
puissent être libéré dans la mesure où
ils sont aujourd'hui en prison sans
aucune sans aucune raison et je compte
avoir de conclure un peu plus précise
que celle que vous venez nous donner
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
Montauger pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues depuis des
siècles en mesure que l'agriculture
contribuait par ses évolutions au
progrès de l'humanité l'activité des
hommes et des femmes qui l'incarnaient
étaient banalisées petit à petit
dévalorisé pour finir par être
aujourd'hui vilipendée stigmatisé voire
incriminer c'est cette incompréhension
que nous disent ces jours-ci les
agriculteurs qui se mobilisent au regard
du temps long et des enjeux que nos
sociétés doivent relever aujourd'hui
dans l'urgence le malaise qui prouve les
agriculteurs s'inscrit en réalité dans
une crise de civilisation nous devons
tous collectivement faire évoluer le
paradigme dans l'agriculture bien sûr
mais aussi dans les transports le
logement l'énergie etc s'il y a Malaise
dans la civilisation et je pense qu'à
bien des égards nous en sommes là les
agriculteurs ne doivent pas être les
books émissaires d'une problématique qui
concerne en réalité l'entière communauté
des citoyens les paysans ne sont pas le
problème
ils sont une des solutions aux problèmes
que nous devons résoudre collectivement
et dans l'urgence alors monsieur le
ministre dans ce contexte quel est votre
stratégie quel est votre plan d'action
ou en êtes-vous des prestations pour
services environnementaux acronymes PSE
qui permettrait que je sois reconnu ce
qu'apporte les agriculteurs à la société
dans son ensemble au-delà des biens
nourrissiés comment allez-vous compenser
la baisse des crédits de la pâte pour la
transition vers le bio ou la
compensation des handicaps naturels
quand visage vous pour la réalisation
rapide d'ouvrages hydrauliques enfin le
constat est en fait que le ruissellement
ne fonctionne pas non plus dans
l'agriculture comment envisagez-vous de
répondre à la question de la
revalorisation du revenu agricole pour
laquelle la loi egalim n'a produit à ce
jour quasiment aucun effet
la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture Monsieur Didier Guillaume
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur montoget à nouveau je ne peux
qu'être d'accord avec vous sur le
constat que vous avez fait comme
l'ensemble des collègues sénateurs
sénatrices sur tous les bancs mais je
vais répondre précisément aux questions
que aux questions que vous posez
aujourd'hui la transition agroécologique
elle est indispensable à notre
agriculture elle devra se faire dans
tous les domaines dans la rotation et
dans le changement des pratiques
agraires et dans le changement des
cultures évidemment aujourd'hui vous
m'interrogez sur le bio il n'y a jamais
eu autant d'agriculteurs qui sont passés
en bio l'année dernière 6000 de plus 10%
des agriculteurs de ce pays sont
aujourd'hui en bio
7,5% de la surface agricole utile est en
bio l'objectif c'est 15% en 2025 nous
nous en approchons et nous y arriverons
évidemment mais il faut aller plus loin
et pour aller plus loin il faut donner
les moyens aux agriculteurs et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la France se bat
bec et ongles afin que la le montant du
le cadre financier de la pacte ne baisse
pas je l'ai déjà dit ici évidemment il
va baisser à du concurrence du départ
des Britanniques mais la France
n'acceptera pas qu'une autre part de la
Pâque soit prise pour d'autres
politiques il est indispensable de
garder le montant de la Pâque ce qu'on
appelle à u27 Union européenne 27 et
lundi au Conseil des ministres de la
Culture à Bruxelles à Luxembourg je
porterai au nom de la France un
mémorandum concernant 20 pays européens
20 pays européens demandant à ce que le
cadre financier du budget européen de la
PAC reste le même à partir de là
évidemment à l'intérieur du budget de la
pacte nous souhaitons que le premier
pilier reste important il faut des aides
directes mais en même temps nous allons
entrer dans le premier pilier la
transition agroécologique avec ce qu'on
appelle dans le patois gersoit les
costume et que les costumes soient
obligatoire pour tous les pays pour tous
les pays de l'Union européenne nous
voulons une Pâques intégrer par 27 packs
différentes et évidemment à l'intérieur
du deuxième pilier les PSE seront mis en
place nous en avons déjà parlé ici à
votre initiative un débat s'est tenu au
Sénat et je suis toujours dans cette
perspective le gouvernement veut les
accompagner et nous le ferons dans le
cadre de la prochaine politique récolte
commune merci Monsieur Montauger vous
avez quelques secondes
merci monsieur le ministre vous étiez le
rapporteur de la loi de l'orientation
agricole de 2014 qui a donné le la en
matière de de d'agro d'agroécologie il
faut absolument poursuivre dans ce sens
et pour l'ensemble des Agriculteurs de
France merci je vais donner la parole
collecte pastel grunis et ensuite je
saluerai nos collègues à l'issue de sa
question de groupe d'amitié et de la
délégation parlementaire de Macédoine du
Nord madame la
madame la sénatrice
ma question s'adresse
aux 15 jours les agriculteurs subissent
de plein fouet les conséquences de
l'incendie de l'usine Lubrizol à Rouen
en Normandie et en Picardie plus de 900
exploitations agricoles sont à l'arrêt
près de 700 ml de lait sont détruits
chaque jour pour un coup déjà supérieur
à 3 millions d'euros les agriculteurs
attendent avec impatience et
appréhension les résultats des analyses
des suits retombées sur le sur les sols
vous les annoncez pour la fin de semaine
mais pour eux chaque jour qui passe est
un jour de trop et plus grave à ce jour
pas un centime ne leur a été versé vous
comptez faire payer le pollueur mais en
attendant c'est à la solidarité
nationale de prendre le relais monsieur
le ministre cette nouvelle crise
intervient alors que les agriculteurs
étaient hier dans la rue pour crier leur
détresse malgré leurs efforts
considérables depuis 30 ans pour bâtir
une agriculture durable et de qualité
l'agribashing qu'il subit c'est
insupportable si l'on y ajoute la loi
égaline qui n'a rien changé à leur
situation
vos conversations à Bruxelles qui font
craindre pour l'avenir de la Pâques et
l'inquiétude dans laquelle vous les avez
plongés avec le traité CETA je vous pose
cette question simple y a-t-il quelqu'un
dans ce gouvernement qui défend encore
nos agriculteurs et qui croient encore
en l'agriculture française merci
monsieur Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur c'est important cet
après-midi monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice je crois et je vais
répondre à votre question mais je crois
vraiment que lorsqu'on parle
d'agriculture il faut aussi parfois en
parler de façon positive et pas
totalement dire toujours ce qui ne va
pas parce que ce n'est pas comme ça que
nous y arriverons je vais répondre
précisément mais oui mais il y a une
réalité c'est pour ça que je vais
répondre ce n'est pas en criant avec les
looks en règle les problèmes c'est en
travaillant sur le terrain c'est la
raison pour laquelle concrètement le
gouvernement s'est mobilisé
immédiatement avec Lubrizol dans la
transparence totale les agriculteurs
sont des victimes ils ne sont pas
responsables et c'est pas ce qu'ils sont
des victimes qu'il doit être indemnisés
à 100% c'est l'engagement que nous avons
pris hier après-midi les dirigeants de
du brisol étaient au ministère de la
Culture et de l'Alimentation et ils ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient faire des
avances direct sur l'agriculture
deuxièmement sur la sur la filière les
les choses sont très clair vous le savez
nous avons travaillé avec le Cniel
l'interprétation laitière qui va prendre
le relais d'avance oui mais vous savez
très bien que l'État peut pas faire ses
déchets à chaque agriculteur tous les
jours c'est pour ça que les avances en
train de fait c'est vu avec
l'interprofession c'est vu avec votre
Président de Chambre d'Agriculture donc
voilà les choses avancent et le client
elle va faire les annonces sur le 400000
€ par jour vous pensez bien de les
détruire vous pensez bien que plus ça
ira vite moins il y aura besoin de le
dépenser et sur les autres sujets avec
notamment l'arboriculture et les autres
cultures nous avons travaillé hier
après-midi encore avec les présidents de
la Chambre d'Agriculture le Premier
ministre nous a demandé à Madame borne
madame Buzin et moi-même d'être présent
vendredi nous avons mis une cellule de
crise qui se réunit quotidiennement nous
mettons qu'une commission de
transparence et de vigilance et je l'ai
annoncé hier à nouveau tout sera fait le
plus rapidement possible pour que
l'indemnisation des agriculteurs soient
là et je l'ai aussi affirmé au nom du
gouvernement il sera inimaginable qu'un
seul agriculteur mette la clé sous la
porte parce qu'il n'aura pas eu de
trésorerie lui aidant à passer cette
crise donc nous ne le laisserons pas
faire cela ils sont victimes ils ne sont
pas responsables madame gruyer
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai plaisir de saluer la
présence dans la tribune d'honneur d'une
délégation du groupe d'amitié de
l'Assemblée de la République de
Macédoine du Nord conduite par le
président du groupe monsieur
Ivanov la délégation est reçue au Sénat
par le groupe inter parlementaire
d'amitié France balcon
occidentaux présidé par notre collègue
Martin décidra dont le président délégué
notre collègue Arnaud Bazin la
délégation aura l'occasion d'échanger
sur la version bilatérale mais aussi
d'évoquer les enjeux européens avec le
président de la commission des affaires
européennes gens Bizet ainsi que sur les
questions de politique étrangères de
défense avec président de notre
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et les forces armées Christian
Cambon je voudrais souhaiter
à cette délégation la plus cordiale
bienvenue et bien sûr l'occasion du
renforcement des liens entre nos
assemblées mais aussi nos deux pays
après qu'il y ait eu un débat autour du
dossier Macédoine du Nord qui forte
heureusement a été résolue dans un
esprit de d'ouverture et de solidarité
européenne ça démontre aussi la tension
que nous portons je le dis que je porte
à la région des Balkans occidentaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'attentat à la préfecture de Paris a
donc marqué ces questions au
Gouvernement tour à tour le Premier
ministre le ministre de l'Intérieur puis
son secrétaire d'État ont eu ta réponse
au sénateur sur ce sujet Édouard
Philippe a sensiblement répété la même
chose qu'à l'Assemblée nationale à
savoir que le gouvernement ne se plaira
jamais dans la position de dire que
telle ou telle gouvernement n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux je cite ils ont
pris des décisions qui toutes allaient
dans le bon sens et je ne veux pas
pointer aucune responsabilité a-t-il
affirmé Christophe Castaner à lui
répondu à la sénatrice les républicains
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne qui était
particulièrement offensive reprochant
notamment la naïveté coupable de l'État
le ministre de l'intérieur c'est
principalement contenté de dérouler un
bilan chiffré des actions du
gouvernement en matière de terrorisme
isme avant de céder la parole à son
secrétaire d'État à la question suivante
peut-être une manière pour lui de garder
ses forces avant son audition de demain
matin devant la commission des Lois du
Sénat
merci beaucoup Alice pour toutes ces
explications et ont poursuit le débrief
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement avec deux invités
Jacqueline stage brignaud bonjour c'est
natrice les républicains du Val-d'Oise
également sur ce plateau Rémy Ferro
bonjour vous êtes sénateurs socialiste
de Paris et nous allons parler ensemble
et bien du point marquant de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement c'était d'abord
l'intervention d'Edouard Philippe autour
bien sûr et bien de sa gestion de
l'attentat à la préfecture de police de
Paris le Premier ministre qui a appelé à
fairblock on l'écoute
je sais je sais que lorsque des signaux
faibles comme on dit c'est à dire des
signaux qui ne se traduisent pas
nécessairement par des signalements mais
des signaux faibles sont émis
je sais qu'il est parfois difficile
c'est vrai probablement dans un service
de renseignement c'est vrai dans une
collectivité territoriale c'est vrai
dans une administration c'est vrai dans
une association c'est vrai partout
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
vous le savez tous qu'il est parfois
difficile de traiter ces signaux faibles
de transformer ces signaux faibles en
une action et je ne veux pas pointer la
responsabilité de ce qui s'étend poser
des questions aurait le cas échéant
omis de transmettre cette information
parce que monsieur le Président je veux
que nous fassions bloque
chacune stage brino qu'avez-vous pensé
de cette avance de cette intervention du
Premier ministre est-ce que vous êtes
convaincu par la gestion de cette
attentat et de ses suites par l'exécutif
je pense que ça serait responsable à
part d'élus quel qu'il soit de faire une
polémique sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais sur ce sujet là on peut
quand même poser des choses nous parler
de signaux faibles et que moi je suis
j'étais longtemps et locale on a
énormément travaillé en banlieue sur
voilà la radicalisation on a formé le
personnel surtout ces sujets là mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des signaux
faibles et les signes on les connaît
sauf que les signaux faibles dont on
parle le ministre il n'était pas
n'importe où les signaux faibles quand
c'est dans une administration comme
celle de la préfecture de police il faut
quand même s'interroge quelqu'un qui se
convertit qui sert plus la main des
femmes c'était pas un employé un
supermarché il travaillait au sein d'un
service qui avait accès à des données
extrêmement confidentielles donc on peut
pas on peut pas dire c'est de signaux
bien évidemment les signaux faibles que
vous serrez pas l'armée des femmes que
vous avez terroriste mais à l'intérieur
d'un service comme celui-là on doit
obligatoirement se poser les questions
parce qu'on n'est pas n'importe où on
n'est pas n'importe où alors après je
voudrais juste dire deux choses sur la
suite parce que aujourd'hui c'est comme
ça et on fait quoi demain et là-dessus
j'aurais des choses à dire oui Rémi
Féraud vous entendez Jacqueline stage
briniaux sur bien la perception de ces
signaux faibles hier et bien Laurence
virginiewski a dit et bien est-ce que la
conversion à l'islam peut-être
considérée comme un signal faible est-ce
que on ne court pas le risque aussi de
stigmatiser une population non il s'agit
pas de stigmatiser une population il
s'agit
à partir de signaux faibles de voir
s'ils peuvent déboucher sur un
signalement et d'avoir une attention à
l'ensemble et des personnels mais de la
préfecture de police du renseignement
bien sûr soyons à ce stade un peu
prudent parce que il faut qu'on obtienne
l'ensemble des éléments d'enquête il va
y avoir des auditions des enquêtes
internes le service de l'état des
préconisations ensuite il faut tirer les
enseignements de chaque attentat ce que
je constate c'est que le premier
ministre a parlé de manière forte je
pensais aussi pour faire oublier un
flottement soyons gentil dans les termes
de communication
au tout départ voilà après l'attaque qui
nous demande de faire bloc et je pense
qu'il est important de faire bloc mais
je vais aussi dire que puisque ça a été
aussi un sujet très important abordé
dans les questions au Gouvernement cet
après-midi nous ne pouvons pas faire
bloc en France et penser que cela sera
efficace dans la lutte contre le
terroriste si parallèlement nous
abandonnons nos amis et alliés kurde
face au djihadistes en Syrie la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste avec
globale et elle doit être globale
extérieure lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement et
bien il y a également eu un échange
marquant entre Dominique estrosiason et
Christophe Castaner toujours autour de
cet attentat on l'écoute
ce n'est pas en jetant à la figure de
ceux qui s'inquiètent du désarmement
moral de notre société et de sa
communauté
islamophobe que nous gagnerons cette
guerre depuis 2018
362 personnes qui étaient inscrits au
fameux fichier fsrt ont été éloignés et
on les a fait en sorte qu'ils quitte le
territoire depuis 2017 quatre mesures
ont été prononcées pour expulser des
prédicateurs radicalisés depuis 2018 129
débits de boissons 12 lieu de culte ont
été fermés 9 établissements culturels et
associatifs ont été aussi des écoles ont
été fermées 503 contrôle Koda font été
mises en œuvre et je conclure en vous
disant que c'est en mettant tous ces
moyens et en les mobilisant tous que
nous looterons pans à pan mètre carré
par mètre carré pour qu'aucun mètre
carré de notre République n'échappe à
nos valeurs républicaines et pour
poursuivre autour de cet échange tout de
suite on rejoint la salle des
conférences se trouve Alexandre Poussard
avec Dominique estros que ça sonne et
oui Dominique Estrosi on vient d'écouter
votre question à Christophe Castaner
est-ce que vous avez été convaincu par
sa réponse sur la lutte du gouvernement
contre l'islamisme radical bien
évidemment non le ministre s'est
contenté de réduire la problématique de
l'islam radical à une question de moyens
aujourd'hui on s'est bien que ce n'est
pas un problème de moyens c'est avant
tout un problème de courage et de
responsabilité et malheureusement face à
l'islam radical qui porte atteinte aux
lois de la République qui a déclaré la
guerre à notre société c'est l'État qui
doit prendre toutes ses responsabilités
l'État et lui seul et pour se faire seul
l'état dispose de véritables moyens pour
lutter contre l'islam radical quitte
effectivement à proroger et à trouver
d'autres mesures pour être encore plus
efficaces mais encore une fois l'état ne
veut pas dire ne veut pas parler
d'islamisme déni l'islamisme et dans une
naïveté coupable et montre aussi que
l'autorité orité de l'État
malheureusement dans notre pays est
bafoué et qu'il faut absolument
aujourd'hui non seulement bien sûr dire
des mots comme l'a fait le président de
la République mais ce n'est plus
nécessaire il faut que les mots se
traduisent par de véritables actes si on
veut faire en sorte que notre société ne
reste pas dans cette indignation dans
cette stupeur et dans cette colère très
bien passé des mots aux actes merci
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
et oui les paroles ne sont pas
suffisantes du Dominique Estrosi ça
sonne Jacqueline stage brignaud
êtes-vous satisfaite par le fait que le
ministre de l'Intérieur Christophe
Castaner est finalement et bien obtenu
que soit annulé une manifestation qui
était prévue à Gonesse une manifestation
en soutien à Michael harpon vous-même
vous aviez demandé cette interdiction si
je n'étais pas intervenu cette
manifestation elle avait lieu parce que
en fait Gonesse c'est quand même mon
département et Gonesse il y a un nid de
falafiste tout le monde le sait l'imam
d'ailleurs ça l'affiche on sait même pas
où il est il a été frappé une obligation
qui était territoire il y a jamais parti
en 2015 effectivement pour des raisons
que tout le monde connaît mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce celui qui était à
l'initiative de cette pseudo
manifestation en soutien au terroriste
quand même Adama Traoré Adama Traoré
sa vidéo elle tourne sur Youtube depuis
dimanche depuis dimanche c'est une honte
qui les propos qu'il a enfin même
lui-même il devrait être probablement
condamné pour ses propos sauf que moi
j'ai appelé la préfecture du Val-d'Oise
hier matin et on me dit hier matin oui
c'est très compliqué d'interdire les
manifestations on sait jamais le théâtre
va pas nous suivre donc en fait si
j'avais pas fait ce communiqué de presse
que j'ai inondé partout le préfet alors
que le ministre sache pas qui est cette
manifestation prévue ça je l'entends et
en fait c'est parce que le ministère
soit à nos deux préfets interdire que le
préfet m'a appelé ce matin pour me dire
j'interdis mais c'est ça qui va pas dans
notre pays faut arrêter d'être dans le
déni il faut arrêter et tout celles et
ceux qui sont sortis de la ligne de la
République et bien il faut les dénoncer
les pointer et les sanctionner c'est
l'avenir de la cohésion de notre pays
qui est en jeu aujourd'hui c'est pas que
le terrorisme c'est ça parce que on
parle du terrorisme mais on parle pas
des pans entiers qui sortent de la
République de la laïcité et de ce qui
doit faire en sorte que nous puissions
vivre ensemble l'islam radical est un
fléau l'islam politique est un fléau
c'est pas des mots ce sont des actes
dont nous avons besoin Rémy Rémi
fais-moi
des mots qui auraient dû alerté
davantage sur Michael harpon c'est bien
le fait qu'il est justifié visiblement
auprès de certains de ses collègues de
travail d'attentat contre Charles
Hebdo c'est vraiment voilà il faut
vraiment qu'on soit terroriste il le
faut au nom d'un engagement religieux
c'est pas voilà il faut dire ce qu'il y
a derrière voilà faut pas nier ce qu'il
y a derrière et ça c'est un combat qu'on
doit tous mener l'État les élus les
habitants merci sans transition on va
maintenant revenir salle des conférences
Alexandre vous êtes avec François
Patriat le patron du groupe lrem car il
va se tenir et bien dans quelques
instants un débat sur la politique
migratoire à la demande du gouvernement
dans l'hémicycle
oui François Patriat qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de ce débat sur la politique
migratoire et ce que vous attendez des
mesures du gouvernement notamment sur
des quotas de migrants économiques ça se
fait un raccourci que vous me proposez
je crois que ce débat sur l'immigration
c'est le chef d'État qui l'a voulu
et il a bien dit qu'il serait répété
chaque année pour montrer que ce
gouvernement ne reporte pas le problème
et n'attend pas qu'on soit dans une
crise paroxystique pour débattre d'un
sujet qui intéresse tous les Français et
on voit bien qu'avec les dérives qui se
passent aujourd'hui quelques celles
qu'on vient de vivre dramatiquement il y
a quelques jours on voit bien que ce
sujet il faut s'en saisir tous les jours
sans saisir ici c'est le faire avec un
sens de la responsabilité et sans
naïveté c'est à dire ne pas rejeter les
problèmes ne pas se dissimuler et dans
le même temps ne pas faire tous les
jours du bouc émissaire et dramatiser
donc il faut prendre les choses avec
beaucoup de responsabilités de hauteur
et même temps en engagement donc il y
aura des mesures je crois que le premier
ministre on a déjà annoncé lors de ce
débat à l'Assemblée nationale il a parlé
de mieux accueillir de parler de l'aide
au développement qui permet aux gens de
rester chez eux il a parlé aussi de
demande de comment revoir Schengen comme
retrouver une unité européenne dans la
matière
également
durcir aussi que les conditions vous
savez que vous savez le nombre de gens
qui sont naturalisés par rapport aux
gens donc il demande et on voit bien que
c'est parce que il y a eu des demandes
de droits d'asile qui ont monté en
flèche de 22% depuis 3 ans que le
gouvernement a décidé de prendre
vraiment le problème d'un balcon il le
fait alors que dans le passé et avant on
est le sujet on le traitait de façon
soit provocatrice soit naïve là le fait
de traiter les sujets régaliens et
celui-ci en particulier dans un débat
qui j'espère aura de la tenue avec une
déclaration des ministres qui va donner
le tempo SDF qui va donner surtout la
politique de la France pendant les
oies les années qui c'est mais avec ce
débat annuel sur l'immigration est-ce
qu'il y a pas quand même un enjeu
électoral d'aller sur les terres de la
droite de l'extrême droite non mais
parce que ces sujets étaient est-il
réservé à un secteur à une partie de la
population politique non je crois que
l'immigration est un sujet qui préoccupe
les Français on l'a bien vu au moment
des gilets jaunes il apparaissait que 54
à 64% des Français se préoccuper sur
l'immigration on disait qu'on
accueillait trop d'étrangers donc c'est
bien un sujet qui intéresse les Français
et qu'aujourd'hui la majorité le
gouvernement sont des saisissent serait
alors une défaite politique et c'est
parce que fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui très bien merci beaucoup
François Patriat je vous laisse aller
dans l'hémicycle pour ce débat sur la
politique migratoire merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette nouvelle Inter
Jacqueline stage brino comment est-ce
que vous interprétez cet intérêt
d'Emmanuel Macron pour l'immigration il
en avait parlé des salaires français
l'ami au programme du grand débat quel
est l'objectif pour vous de la majorité
présidentielle en abordant ce débat ben
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien parce que
au-delà des mots pour vous mais au-delà
des mots il y a un vrai problème qu'il
faut régler mais au-delà des mots faut
juste nous expliquer comment parce que
effectivement l'asile les demandeurs
d'asile les chiffres ont exposés les
obligations qui étaient territoire sont
pas appliqués donc après tout ça c'est
bien gelé le constat où on le connaît
maintenant on fait comment on fait
comment donc pour l'instant j'ai pas
beaucoup d'idées je vous coupe
Jacqueline merci beaucoup Rémy frérot
Jacqueline ne stage Brignon on va tout
de suite rejoindre la séance car Édouard
Philippe va prendre la parole pour
ouvrir ce débat sur la politique
migratoire de la France
monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le président de la République a souhaité
qu'un débat parlementaire puisse être
organisé chaque année sur la politique
migratoire de notre pays lundi dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui au
Sénat nous nous livrons donc un exercice
qui est difficile
qui a sans doute ses limites
mais qui je crois profondément utile
c'est un exercice difficile parce que
nous le savons les questions migratoires
suscitent plus facilement l'affrontement
que le consensus
entre l'atlantisme ou l'angélisme d'une
part les postures clivantes d'autre part
j'en reste pour ma part à ces mots
prononcés par un de mes prédécesseurs
Michel Rocard en l'occurrence à
l'occasion d'un autre débat sur la
politique migratoire et à son objectif
je le cite d'assurer le triomphe de la
conception républicaine ouverte de la
nation celle qui assure des droits pour
chacun et fait accepter des devoirs pour
tous
c'est un exercice qui a ses limites le
débat vient à peine de commencer lundi
je le disais à l'Assemblée nationale et
déjà certains observateurs certains
commentateurs de la vie politique
regrettent que le calendrier des actions
n'est pas été annoncé dans ses moindres
détails
je ne doute pas que si nous avions
annoncé ces détails on nous aurait dit
que le débat était faussé ne servait à
rien
mesdames et messieurs
j'assume de prendre 72 heures pour que
ce débat ait lieu véritablement avant
d'en venir vite autant des décisions
l'essentiel c'est que ce débat est utile
parce qu'il nous permet de partager un
diagnostic documentaire
parce qu'il nous permet de réfléchir et
de construire ensemble une stratégie
générale et des réponses
et parce qu'il est
utile et précieuse me semble-t-il que ce
sujet des politiques de la politique
migratoire au sens le plus large soit
débattus au Parlement non pas
nécessairement à l'occasion de la
présentation d'un texte de loi ou d'une
série de mesures techniques mais bien au
contraire présenter dans sa plus large
conception depuis les relations que nous
entretenons avec les états d'origine
jusqu'à la question de l'intégration sur
notre territoire de ceux qui ont
vocation à rester ou le retour vers les
pays d'origine de ceux qui n'auraient
pas vocation à rester
ce débat
est utile et il est utile qu'il ait lieu
ici au parlant
nos concitoyens
parle de ces sujets
et si José mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je dirais que parfois
il n'en parle plus
et ça n'est pas forcément plus
réjouissant
j'ai le souvenir c'est un souvenir
personnel je m'excuse de d'en faire état
à la tribune j'ai le souvenir
de séquences dans le grand débat qui a
été organisé il y a quelques mois ou une
simple phrase une expression formulée
par un des participants sans jamais
avoir besoin d'insister sur ce qu'elle
pouvait impliquer était immédiatement
compris reçu partagé par l'ensemble de
l'assistance comme un non dit mais un
non dit qui aurait été consensus je
crois mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que parfois dans des réunions
dans des associations dans des réunions
publiques vous avez été témoins de ces
moments où le sujet n'est pas forcément
explicitement formulé mais où il est
dans tous les esprits
et je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit plus
favorable ou plus bénéfique au débat
public que le fait d'avoir un débat
explicite public devant la présentation
nationale
nos concitoyens
ils pensent en parle
il nous écoute ils écoutent ceux qui
disent les peurs et parfois les
encouragent ceux qui disent les vertus
et les chances et parfois les flattes il
est très facile je crois de tourner
presque à vide sur le sujet de
l'immigration en ressassant les mêmes
obsessions le fantasme durant
l'emplacement ou l'appel généreux et
général à ouvrir grande aux frontières
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
congédier toute forme de facilité ou de
rhétorique pour essayer d'agir avec
sagesse et bon sens c'est ce que mérité
évidemment nos concitoyens et c'est je
crois l'unique manière de bâtir une
Europe forte solidaire et crédible et
une nation
forte et solidaire qui resteront
attractive sans être débordés ni replié
sur elle-même
cette politique migratoire que nous
présentons et sur laquelle nous voulons
réfléchir avec le Sénat elle doit
d'abord s'inscrire dans le contexte
mondial et européen d'aujourd'hui mener
une politique d'immigration cohérente ce
n'est pas seulement une affaire de
procédure franco-française si j'ose dire
c'est comme nous nous efforçons de le
faire depuis deux ans comme cela est
nécessaire me semble-t-il mettre cette
question au cœur de nos relations
diplomatiques avec les pays d'origine
avec les pays de transit nous avons
d'ailleurs la matière obtenue quelques
succès mais ils ne sont pas à une
échelle telle que il serait définitif je
veux par exemple citer l'augmentation de
60% du nombre de laisser passer
consulaire obtenu dans le cadre de la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
tous ceux qui connaissent ces sujets
savent que le nombre de laisser passer
consulaire qui était demandé par
l'administration française était faible
et que sur ce petit nombre de laisser
passer consulaires demandés par
l'administration française au pays
d'origine le nombre de laisser passer
consulaires effectivement délivré était
encore plus faible
l'un nourrissant l'autre
le faible nombre de laisser passer
consulaire délivré créant comme une
incitation à ne pas demander de laisser
passer consulaire nous allons nous avons
essayé avec un certain nombre de mesures
nous pourrons entrer dans le détail
essayez de revenir sur cette mauvaise
mécanique pour faire en sorte que plus
de laisser passer consulaire soit
demandé et qu'un très grand nombre soit
accepté admis délivrer par les pays avec
lesquels nous sommes en relation et qui
sont directement concernés par cette
immigration irrégulière au-delà de cette
relation diplomatique forte avec les
pays d'origine je suis convaincu que
l'aide publique au développement pour
laquelle nous consentons des efforts
financiers croissants
et qui vont être croissants dans le
temps doit être mobilisé au service de
notre stratégie migratoire et oui cela
doit s'inscrire dans une relation
d'engagement réciproque avec nos
partenaires cette approche sera déclinée
dans le projet de loi de finance dont
vous apprêtez à débattre elle donnera
lieu aussi à un projet de loi de
programmation et d'orientation en
matière de développement que nous vous
proposerons d'examiner au cours de
l'année 2020 c'est là la première
orientation de la stratégie que vous
propose le gouvernement cette question
est souvent discutée elle est parfois
contestée il nous semble que nous devons
assumer de faire de l'aide publique au
développement un des éléments un des
éléments pas le seul et il ne peut pas
servir uniquement cela mais un des
éléments assumé d'une politique
migratoire générale pensée par notre
pays
dans ce contexte mondial la situation de
l'Europe est particulière nous ne sommes
plus au cœur de la crise des réfugiés
des années 2015 et 2016 mais les
problèmes restent là et parfois entier
nous avons construit l'Europe de la
libre circulation c'est bien nous devons
aujourd'hui construire l'Europe de la
protection des frontières extérieures
c'est urgent et à l'intérieur de
l'Europe nous devons traiter le problème
des mouvements secondaires qui sont le
symptôme et parfois la conséquence d'une
gestion encore insuffisamment coordonnée
entre les États
dès que la nouvelle Commission
européenne sera installée 1er novembre
prochain nous ferons valoir nos
propositions de renforcement juridique
et opérationnels de la protection des
frontières extérieures et Dieu est de
réforme du régime d'Asie européen nous
veillerons à un bon équilibre entre
responsabilité et solidarité pour la
gestion des mouvements migratoires à
l'intérieur de l'Europe c'est pour moi
le deuxième axe nécessaire de notre
avant
nos concitoyens veulent aussi que nous
soyons capables de mieux accueillir et
de mieux intégrer mieux accueillir c'est
d'abord réduire des délais d'instruction
de demande d'asile qui sont bien trop
longs
cette année encore nous avons autorisé
le recrutement de 150 officiers de
protection à l'ofra et des agents qui
sont nécessaires à l'ouverture d'une 23e
chambre à la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile
alors que le nombre de demandes d'asile
est en très forte augmentation
ces efforts constants ont permis de
stabiliser les délais mais nous ne
sommes pas dans le raccourcissement des
délais que nous souhaitions parce que ce
que nous avons gagné à l'instruction
nous l'avons perdu au contentieux pour
dire les choses de façon un peu crue
l'instruction est plus rapide qu'elle
n'était auparavant mais le contentieux
des mesures qui sont prises lui a eu
tendance à s'allonger en raison à la
fois un mouvement de grève qui a
frapper la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile et aussi en raison d'un
contentieux très massif
des décisions qui sont prises par
lofpride dans le cadre du droit des
c'est le troisième volet de notre
stratégie que nous devons nous devons
garantir l'atteinte des objectifs que
nous sommes déjà fixés c'était notamment
au moment du vote de la loi du 10
septembre 2018 atteindre un délai moyen
de 6 mois au terme duquel l'ensemble de
la procédure est accompli
mieux accueillir consiste surtout à
mieux intégrer ceux qui ont vocation à
rester
nous avons déjà fait beaucoup en donnant
une nouvelle ambition au contrat
d'intégration républicaine qui repose
désormais sur trois piliers la langue
française le travail et les valeurs
républicaines pour la langue française
nous avons doublé le volume horaire des
cours destinés aux primo arrivants qui
en ont besoin
le respect de nos valeurs républicaines
n'est pas non plus négociable par
exemple quand il s'agit de laïcité ou du
droit des femmes
ce qui demande pour certains
une forme d'éducation républicaine et ce
n'est pas péjoratif
ou scandaleux de le dire c'est un fait
nous vivons avec un certain nombre de
valeurs auxquelles nous tenons elles
sont
elles sont dans notre conception
universelle au sens où elles ont
vocation à s'appliquer universellement
mais elles ne sont pas toujours
partagées connues et connu et interprété
exactement de la façon dont nous le
faisons par ceux qui viennent chez nous
et nous ne pouvons pas nous ne voulons
pas nous ne devons pas négocier sur
l'interprétation de ces valeurs et sur
la réalité des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et auxquelles bien entendu chacun
doit se plier dans le respect de ces
valeurs lorsqu'il veut s'installer ou
vivre dans notre pays
tous les étrangers qui arrivent en
France mesdames et messieurs et vous le
savez parfaitement ne sont pas comme le
jeune Albert Cohen qui débarquant de
Corfou à Marseille vont être un
véritable culte à la France
le code nous raconte qu'il avait même
érigé un petit hôtel à la France avec
des figures aussi diverses que Victor
Hugo Jeanne d'Arc ou Napoléon alors je
n'en demande pas tant à ceux qui
arrivent aujourd'hui quoique s'ils
veulent apprendre les Contemplations par
cœur ce sera toujours bienvenu
mais en revanche
nous leur demandons et nous n'avons pas
d'autres choix que de leur demander de
d'adhérer aux valeurs qui ont fait la
France c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons modernisé doublé la durée de
la formation civique mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous devons être
inflexible sur cette exigence
nous le savons aucune intégration ne
saurait être durable et réussie sans
accès au monde du travail c'est là notre
quatrième axe l'intégration par le
travail nous avons ajouté un volet
insertion professionnelle au contrat
d'intégration républicaine pour les
demandeurs d'asile nous avons déjà
réduit de 9 à 6 mois le délai au terme
duquel ils peuvent accéder au marché du
travail et nous soutenons de très
nombreux projets d'intégration par
l'emploi comme souvent les initiatives
qui apportent des solutions émanent de
nos territoires elle nous ouvre la voie
mais elle ne suffisent pas il faut donc
faire plus et faire mieux les procédures
d'accès des étrangers au monde du
travail doivent être plus globalement
repensé
je propose que nous réinventions le
système d'autorisation de travail pour
les métiers en tension la révision de
cette liste devrait ainsi permettre de
mieux intégrer les étrangers présents en
France et d'attirer lorsque c'est
nécessaire les talents dont notre pays a
besoin
mieux accueillir c'est aussi assumer un
pilotage par objectif de l'admission au
séjour nous savons que la logique des
quotas ne peut s'appliquer ni en matière
d'asile ni en matière d'immigration
familiale
mais pour attirer les talents qu'il
s'agisse d'étudiants ou de compétences
rares
ou de compétences dont nous avons besoin
on doit pouvoir réfléchir à des
objectifs quantitatifs c'est là notre
cinquième orientation on doit pouvoir
adapter et dynamiser nos procédures
d'immigration professionnelle en
fonction des besoins des secteurs
d'activité on doit pouvoir se fixer des
objectifs en nombre d'étudiants
accueillis en nombre de passeports
allant délivrés ou encore sur la
proportion de l'immigration qualifiée au
sein de l'immigration professionnelle
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il
ne doit pas y avoir d'angle mort dans
notre débat et l'accès à la nationalité
ne doit pas être un angle mort
j'ai affirmé lundi je le redis
aujourd'hui
à cette tribune mon opposition à la
suppression du droit du sol mais je suis
favorable à ce que nous élevions les
critères de naturalisation par décret
notamment en ce qui concerne le niveau
de maîtrise de la langue française et
nous irons dans cette direction il n'y a
pas de tabou non plus sur l'immigration
familiale nous devons lutter fermement
contre les fraudes et les abus et nous
pouvons et nous devons resserrer les
critères là où cela ça s'avère là où
cela s'avère pardon nécessaire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
bien accueillir il faut se donner les
moyens d'une meilleure maîtrise des flux
migratoires
nous devons d'abord comprendre pourquoi
le système français d'asile est
actuellement saturé
les mouvements migratoires secondaires
expliquent une part importante de la
situation en 2018 30% des demandeurs
d'asile avait en France avait déjà
déposé une demande dans un autre État
membre et ne relevez donc pas de la
responsabilité de la France et beaucoup
de ces demandeurs sont issus de pays que
l'OFPRA considère comme sur
il y a probablement plusieurs
déterminants à ces phénomènes mais nous
devons regarder les choses en face et
assurer une plus grande convergence
européenne des conditions d'accueil des
étrangers ce sera notre sixième axe nous
voulons que la France ne soit ni moins
accueillante ni moins attractive que ses
voisins cela concerne notamment l'accès
au système de santé l'aide médicale
d'État ou encore les conditions d'accès
des demandeurs d'asile à la protection
maladive des pistes sont à l'étude la
secrétaire d'État Christelle Dubosc il
reviendra sans doute nous aurons sur ce
sujet une discussion précise lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
maîtriser les flux migratoires c'est
bien évidemment aussi renforcer notre
efficacité dans l'éloignement des
étrangers en situation irrégulière j'ai
parlé de l'action diplomatique mais nous
avons aussi renforcé nos outils
juridiques avec la loi du 10 septembre
2018 les éloignements contraints ont
ainsi augmenté de 20% en 2 ans cette
augmentation se poursuit d'ailleurs sur
la même tendance en 2019 mais nous
voulons faire mieux en tirant le
meilleur parti des outils que nous nous
sommes donnés et en menant un nouvel
effort capacitaire par exemple sur le
nombre de places de rétention
administrative
nous devons apporter une réponse adaptée
à la problématique des mineurs non
accompagnés
j'évoquais tout à l'heure Victor Hugo à
propos des Contemplations j'aurais pu
citer cette phrase que nous lui
connaissons tous les crimes de l'homme
commencent aux vagabondages de l'enfant
nous avons créé un outil technique
d'appui à l'évaluation de la minorité
pour distinguer les vrais mineurs les
demandeurs en réalité adulte pour lutter
contre les fraudes et les détournements
et nous avons renforcé notre solidarité
financière vis-à-vis des départements en
la matière aujourd'hui nous devons aller
plus loin
pour nous assurer que le nouvel outil
technique déploie sa planification et
donc inciter à son utilisation partout
sur le territoire
mais aussi pour redéfinir les critères
selon lesquels s'opèrent au niveau
national la répartition entre
département des mineurs à accueillir
nous présenterons des solutions dans les
prochaines semaines dans le prolongement
de nos échanges les plus récents avec
l'Assemblée des départements de France
j'attire aussi votre attention sur la
nécessité d'affiner la réponse qu'il
convient d'apporter à certains
territoires et notamment les outre-mer
le gouvernement n'a pas hésité à décider
d'adaptation nécessaire pour répondre à
leur spécificité c'est ainsi que pour
Mayotte nous avons engagé une action
globale de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine qui mobilise les forces
armées aux côtés de la police et de la
gendarmerie cette action globale passe
également par une coopération renforcée
avec l'Union des Comores je veux aussi
relever que nous avons décidé d'adapter
les modalités d'accès à la nationalité
française pour les ressortissants
étrangers nés à Mayotte je voudrais
saluer le travail législatif mené ici
notamment à l'initiative de votre
vice-président animali
dans l'océan Indien nous avons conduit
une action de coopération
de coopération avec les autorités du Sri
Lanka pour éviter les départs de
migrants depuis ce déplie en direct
depuis ce pays en direction de La
Réunion je n'oublie pas non plus la
Guyane qui est exposée à un flux
important de demandeurs d'asile dont un
très grand nombre sont déboutés nous y
avons lancé l'expérimentation de la
prise de décision en deux mois le signal
a été clair et les demandes d'asile ont
sensiblement diminué nous allons étendre
ce dispositif au département français
des Antilles
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je ne sais pas si les échanges seront
vifs ici comme à l'Assemblée au cours de
ce débat sur l'immigration j'espère si
tel est le cas que cette vivacité sera
féconde en solution je suis sûr que la
Haute Assemblée a une contribution
originale à apporter à ce débat en
exprimant le ressenti des territoires et
en se faisant l'écho du point de vue des
élus locaux notamment nos concitoyens
ont les yeux rivés sur les réponses que
nous apporterons ensemble et l'équilibre
l'équilibre et l'efficacité de notre
politique dépendra en partie de la
qualité des échanges que nous pourrons
avoir je vous remercie d'ores et déjà à
la fois de votre attention et des
éléments que vous pourrez changer avec
le gouvernement merci beaucoup merci
monsieur le Premier ministre
la parole est maintenant
au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Christophe Castaner
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames les ministres
j'aimerais partager avec vous quelques
convictions sur la politique
d'immigration la première c'est que
notre politique migratoire et et doit
être une question globale et
qu'évidemment elle ne concerne pas un
ministère ou une politique publique mais
demande une approche globale le travail
et la mobilisation de tous la deuxième
conviction c'est que ce sujet appelle
évidemment comme la rappeler le Premier
ministre à la sérénité et au sérieux
parler d'immigration c'est souvent
parler aussi de sa propre histoire avec
son propre vécu par les d'immigrations
c'est un sujet qui nous touche et qui
touche chacun et chacune d'entre nous et
nous devons l'aborder par les faits en
nous tenant éloigner des a priori et des
idées reçues nombreuses sur ce sujet
notre politique d'immigration c'est
d'abord une question internationale et
c'est au cœur de cette ordre
international que se trouve un acteur
sur ce sujet absolument incontournable
pour la question migratoire l'Europe
d'abord c'est la question de Schengen
Schengen vous le savez s'est construit
sur deux piliers la libre circulation
des personnes à l'intérieur des
frontières et la protection des
frontières extérieures malgré des
avancées fortes indéniables puissantes
sur le premier pilier
jusqu'il y a peu le second n'avait été
qu'insuffisamment traité
malgré des contrôles extrêmement
strictes dans certains points quelques
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne que nous appelons des
frontières vertes sont encore
insuffisamment contrôlées c'est pour
cette raison que le Président de la
République s'est engagé très fort très
tôt pour la réforme de Schengen
notamment notamment afin d'encourager
l'établissement de centre contrôlés aux
frontières extérieures de l'Europe de
mieux nous appuyer sur l'Agence
européenne des gardes frontières et de
créer une agence européenne de l'asile
enfin pour poser la question de la prise
en charge financière des procédures
corollaire nécessaire de la réforme de
Schengen nous devons revoir nos règles
en matière de droit d'asile
fixant un principe en apparence simple
le pays de première entrée d'un
demandeur d'asile traite sa demande le
règlement Dublin voulait au fond
rappeler un principe simple mais c'est
avéré extrêmement difficile dans sa mise
en œuvre ainsi comme les exemples
italiens et grecs nous l'ont montré dès
lors que les arrivées sont massives un
traitement adapté des demandes et
compromis si on ajoute à cela les
demandes multiples introduites par les
demandeurs d'asile et l'action
innommable des trafiquants d'êtres
humains les principes de solidarité
entre les États membres ont été
totalement compromis pourtant il est
possible de le faire vivre j'étais il y
a une dizaine de jours à La Valette avec
plusieurs de mes homologues européens
nous avions des intérêts parfois
divergents mais nous avons trouvé des
premières solutions ensemble au Conseil
des Ministres des Affaires intérieures
hier ou Amélie de Montchanin
représentait la France nous avons exposé
notre souhait de poursuivre cette dy
pour mener une réforme globale et
durable du système d'asile sur les deux
fondements karaté le Premier ministre
solidarité et responsabilité en effet il
nous faut dès l'installation de la
nouvelle Commission européenne être prêt
à proposer des solutions pour avancer
sur la refondation de Schengen et sur la
réforme du régime d'asile européen mais
là mes messieurs les sénateurs la France
sera au rendez-vous la responsabilité en
quelques mots cela signifie que des
règles effectives doivent déterminer les
compétences respectives des États
membres pour l'examen des demandes
d'asile certains pays ont plaidé pour
une augmentation de la durée de
responsabilité celles-ci devra
naturellement s'effectuer dans une
proportion raisonnable pour réduire les
mouvements secondaires nous
rechercherons des solutions en proposant
par exemple qu'un demandeur d'asile ne
puisse pas bénéficier des conditions
matérielles d'accueil que dans un seul
État celui responsable de sa demande la
solidarité cela signifie qu'une
suggestions ordonnée des migrations à
l'échelle de l'Europe supposent que nous
cherchions à aider vraiment les états de
première entrée la France se prononcera
en faveur d'un mécanisme de solidarité
un mécanisme qui devra être obligatoire
mais obligatoire dans son principe cette
solidarité pouvant bien évidemment se
manifester par des formes différentes
selon les états mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous ne pourrons pas
envisager notre politique d'immigration
sans connaître ce contexte européen mais
nous ne pouvons pas débattre sans partir
des faits des faits tels que nous les
connaissons dans notre pays le premier
fait que je voudrais évoquer devant vous
ce sont les entrées régulières sur notre
territoire en 2018 256
000 personnes sont arrivées
régulièrement parmi eux 90 000 sont
arrivés par la voile d'immigration
familiales c'est un chiffre qui est
stable depuis de longues années
83000 étudiants ont été accueillis c'est
un chiffre en augmentation cette année
tout comme 33000 personnes pour des
motifs économiques c'est deux chiffres
sont eux en net os je l'ai dit pour le
premier je vous le dis pour le second et
cela reflet des choix d'attractivité que
nous avons fait 256
000 c'est donc deux fois plus que la
demande d'asile sur laquelle bien
souvent nous nous arrêtons mais il faut
noter que la demande d'asile en France
présente plusieurs singularités la
première c'est son augmentation il y a
eu l'année dernière 123000 demandes
d'asile en France est un record et c'est
une hausse de 20% par rapport à 2017
alors même
que la demande d'asile en Europe avait
significativement baissé
j'ajouterai même que dans certains pays
comme en Allemagne elle baisse de près
de 18% sur la même période ces données
doivent nous interroger car elles ont
des conséquences sur nos capacités à
traiter convenablement les demandes et à
traiter dignement celles et ceux qui ont
besoin de protection mais là n'est pas
tout la seconde singularité de la
demande d'asile en France tient du fait
qu'elle provient en partie deux pays dit
sur cette liste des pays sûrs est
établie par l'Office français de
protection des réfugiés à patrides mais
découle aussi chacun le sait je pense de
la jurisprudence du Conseil d'État elle
est la liste des pays où l'État de droit
est garanti où l'État n'est pas une
menace pour ses citoyens ainsi
aujourd'hui un quart un quart de notre
demande d'asile provient de pays
d'issure et notamment de Géorgie et
d'Albanie deux pays
depuis lesquels la demande est en forte
augmentation à ces demandes s'ajoute la
défaillance du système Dublin puisque
30% des demandes d'asile effectuées le
sont par des personnes déjà qui ont déjà
introduit une demande dans un autre pays
ces chiffres ont donc un sens que nous
devons affronter il est possible que
notre système d'asile soit en partie
dévoyé soit en partie détournée et une
pression très forte s'exerce sur nos
services publics notamment les
préfectures ou notre système de santé
nous avons pris les choses en main nous
avons augmenté nos capacités
d'hébergement pour les demandeurs
d'asile et les réfugiés et nous nous
sommes emparés dès le début du mandat
des questions d'immigration d'asile et
d'intégration la loi pour une
immigration maîtrisée un droit effectif
à l'asile et une intégration réussie a
été une première étape elle est
aujourd'hui pleinement entrée en vigueur
toutes les mesures réglementaires
nécessaires et son application ont été
prises et les cré budgétaire les moyens
matériels les moyens humains et les
mesures d'organisation ont été au
rendez-vous ce texte a permis des
avancées fortes nécessaires utiles je
pense notamment l'allongement de la
durée maximale de rétention de 45 à 90
jours qui a permis des éloignements que
nous n'aurions pas pu réaliser autrement
je pense également à la possibilité
offerte au préfet de prendre des
certains cas des mesures d'éloignement
après la décision de l'OFPRA confirmée
par les juridictions depuis son entrée
en vigueur 3000 au qtf ont pu être
prises sur ce fondement j'ajoute que les
lois de finances successives ont
concrétisé nos efforts en matière
d'asile d'immigration et d'intégration
et qu'ils seront encore amplifiés dans
le PLF 2020 concrètement ce sont 480
places en CRA supplémentaires depuis le
début du mandat ce sont 229 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour la date
dont 112 cette année 63000 places
supplémentaires pour les centres
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile et 5000
places d'hébergement supplémentaires
pour les réfugiés ce sont des
engagements forts significatifs ce sont
des engagements concrets
je veux dire aussi que nous multiplions
les déplacements avec Laurent Nunez pour
améliorer nos coopérations avec les pays
d'origine nous utilisons également
toutes les options qui nous sont
offertes pour lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière qu'il s'agisse
de l'aide au retour volontaire du
contrôle des frontières intérieures ou
des éloignements forcés dont le nombre a
augmenté comme la rappeler le Premier
ministre de 10% en 2018 et progresse
encore un peu plus cette année mesdames
et messieurs je crois aussi et je veux
le dire fermement que nous pensons notre
politique d'immigration pour réussir
notre politique d'intégration sur ce
point notre gouvernement s'est engagé
fortement les crédits budgétaires
dévoluent à l'intégration ont été
portées à des niveaux sans précédent une
hausse de 75% sur les crédits
d'intégration depuis 2017 nous avons
revu notre parcours d'intégration pour
doubler le Premier ministre va rappeler
le nombre d'heures de français
d'instructions civiques et dans certains
cas pour aller jusqu'à 600 heures de
formation pour accompagner ces
politiques d'intégration nous avons
renforcé les programmes qui favorisent
l'insertion professionnelle ils font
désormais pleinement partie de nos
politiques d'intégration et nous devons
je le pense aller plus loin encore pour
les femmes notamment où les réfugiés
qualifiés à cette fin nous avons engagé
une réflexion pour simplifier les
procédures et revoir la liste des
métiers dit en tension enfin nous devons
prendre en compte le désir exprimer par
de nombreux réfugiés de résider dans des
grands centres urbains c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire en termes de
gestion nationale nous recevons bientôt
avec Julien de Normandie des mers qui
sont engagés pour y contribuer ainsi que
ceux qui font face à des situations
d'une particulière complexité
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
question de notre politique migratoire
est une clé c'est une clé à mon sens
pour notre pacte républicain une clé
pour notre intégration une clé pour la
confiance entre les dirigeants et les
Français nous ne transigerons pas sur
nos valeurs nous aborderons toutes les
solutions avec sérieux et sérénité sans
caricature le Premier ministre a dessiné
quelques pistes lundi à l'Assemblée
elles se sont poursuivies cet après-midi
devant vous nous avons besoin de
regarder cette question en face sans
passion excessive sans fantasme
entretenu nous avons besoin de faire
preuve de courage d'avancer des
propositions et d'aborder tous les
aspects du débat sans exception je vous
remercie
merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole va être
maintenant madame Amélie de Montchalin
secrétaire d'état chargé les affaires
européennes
même la ministre de la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Premier ministre le gouvernement a donc
tenu à ce que ce débat sur les
politiques migratoires puissent avoir
lieu devant la représentation nationale
d'abord et avant tout parce que cette
question vous l'avez dit est un sujet de
préoccupation pour nous de concitoyens
et pour vous aussi élus qui représentait
des élus et des citoyens dans tous les
territoires français mais aussi parce
qu'il est important comme la vie Premier
ministre d'en revenir au fait et pour
débat de ce sujet comme l'a dit
Jean-Yves Le Drion devant l'Assemblée
nous avons d'abord besoin de clarté et
je concentrerai mon propos sur sa
perspective internationale et en
particulier européenne clarté d'abord
sur la situation réelle des migrations
vers l'Europe et vers la France les
mouvements migratoires vers l'Europe
d'abord diminue ainsi alors que le
nombre d'entrées irrégulières sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne
s'élevèrent un million 820 000 en 2015
il est retombé à
[Applaudissements]
ou la Géorgie clarté ensuite au-delà de
la situation des chiffres clarté sur nos
valeurs sur notre histoire et sur nos
principes notre responsabilité à cet
égard c'est de toujours appeler ce que
nous sommes et d'y rester fidèle
rappelez nos valeurs humanistes
inscrites dans notre Constitution ces
valeurs que la France que l'Europe ne
peut renoncer ses valeurs que nous
auxquelles nous pouvons renoncer sans
renoncer à nous-mêmes alors que nous
fêtions les 70 ans du Conseil de
l'Europe mardi dernier à Strasbourg nous
ne pouvons relâcher ses principes
auxquels nous avons adhéré en tant
qu'État mais également en tant que État
membre d'organisations internationale et
européenne et qui nous oblige rappelez
également notre histoire d'ouverture ce
qui pense que le continent européen ce
qui pense que la nation française s'est
construit dans le repli ou dans le rejet
de l'autre méconnaissent notre passé car
le passé de la France son identité ont
été forgés comme beaucoup de d'autres
pays européens par la contribution
irremplaçable de celles et ceux qui sont
venus d'ailleurs
clarté enfin et je crois que c'est la
l'essentiel aujourd'hui sur ce que
doivent être les grandes orientations de
notre action aujourd'hui un constat
s'impose le système d'accueil et
d'intégration que nous avons édifié pour
que ces valeurs ses principes et cet
héritage ne restent pas l'être morte et
mis à l'épreuve il nous faut agir et il
nous faut agir maintenant agir pour
conserver notre capacité à accueillir
dans les meilleures conditions ceux qui
ont droit à l'Asie dans notre pays agir
pour pouvoir continuer à intégrer à
notre société ce qui viennent d'obtenir
la nationalité française ou un titre de
séjour régulier et surtout surtout agir
en européen et en Europe si nous
n'agissons pas nous risquons de voir
l'espace Schengen implosé et l'Europe se
défaire
les Européens doivent avancer ensemble
sur ce sujet sans attendre qu'une
nouvelle crise se profile il ne peut y
avoir parmi les États membres européens
ni ceux qui choisissent la résignation
ni ceux qui choisissent l'indifférence
nous devons être capables de nous
organiser pour offrir humanité à ce qui
demande protection et fermeté absolue
contre les trafiquants et les passeurs
qui exploitent la détresse de ceux qui
souffrent c'était l'objet des
discussions du conseil justice et à
faire intérieure auxquels je
représentais Christophe Castaner hier à
Luxembourg alors pour conjurer ce risque
nous devons être à la fois efficace et
juste notre approche doit prendre en
compte l'ensemble des géographies
concernées les pays d'origine et transit
la Méditerranée et l'Union européenne
sur ces trois volets l'Europe a un rôle
essentiel à jouer il n'y aura pas de
vraies solutions au défi des migrations
si les Européens ne font pas le choix
explicite d'agir ensemble alors comment
pouvons-nous agir d'abord agir en amont
le partenariat que nous construisons
avec les pays d'origine et de transit
reposent sur une action commune en
faveur du développement l'aide publique
au développement a bien sûr un objectif
propre la lutte contre la pauvreté et la
réduction des inégalités mais elle est
aussi un levier essentiel de notre
politique migratoire et ce pour trois
raisons d'abord elle nous permet de
mener les actions humanitaires au plus
près des populations la France s'est
engagée engagement répéter le 22 juillet
dernier à Paris avec le
Haut-commissariat au réfugiés et
l'organisation internationale des
migrations à réinstallé 10 000 réfugiés
en 2018 et 2019 et 8500 personnes l'ont
déjà été effectivement ensuite notre
aide publique au développement permet à
nos partenaires du Sud de se doter des
capacités indispensable pour maîtriser
eux-mêmes les flux migratoires car on le
sait le défi migratoires est d'abord un
défi pour les dépays du Sud et tout le
sens de notre action et de les aider à y
faire face enfin la de développement est
essentielle pour traiter dans la durée
des causes profondes des migrations ils
irrégulières nous devons aider les
populations tentées par les migration
par désespoir à retrouver des
perspectives un avenir et des conditions
économiques de développement là où ils
vivent et c'est pour mieux affronter ces
défis que notre aide publique au
développement se rapportait à 0,55% de
la richesse nationale d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
ce partenariat avec les pays d'origine
transit nous y travaillons au plan
national mais également au plan européen
et notamment dans le cas du prochain
cadre financier pluriannuel le budget
européen 2021-2027 qui prévoit des
instruments de financement dédiés au
sujet migratoires notamment sur les
enjeux capacitaires c'est-à-dire la
capacité des pays du Sud à avoir de
réels systèmes de gestion de leur
frontières et un renforcement de leur
état civil c'est 10% de l'enveloppe de
cette nouvelle instrument de coopération
de développement international que la
France demande à voir alloué à ces
questions c'est une priorité des
négociations que je porte avec mes
homologues sur ce budget deuxième enjeu
européen d'action c'est l'action que
nous devons mener ensemble face aux
situations d'urgence comme en
Méditerranée l'an dernier 2000 personnes
ont péri en mer aux portes de notre
continent cette inacceptable et nous
devons nous mobiliser nous devons comme
la rappeler Christophe Castaner mettre
en place un mécanisme de sauvetage et de
débarquement pérenne et efficace le
président de la République a proposé
afin de trouver une solution européenne
collective de responsabilité de
solidarité des avancées ont été obtenus
le 23 septembre à La Valette mais les
migrations ne sont pas seulement la
question de ces quatre pays l'Allemagne
l'Italie Malte et la France c'est pour
cela qu'hier au Conseil j'aille à
Luxembourg avec le soutien d'autres
États membres nous avons réussi à créer
une dynamique positive et je peux ici
vous assurer qu'une dizaine de pays sont
prêts à participer ou en tout cas
déclare être prêt à participer au
prochain débarquement
c'est un mécanisme temporaire c'est un
mécanisme volontaire je rappelle ici
pour la bonne compréhension de tous que
les le nombre de personnes concernées
par ces débarquements a été de 600
personnes pour la France 300 personnes
pour l'Allemagne 60 personnes pour le
Luxembourg donc nous sommes bien face à
un enjeu humanitaire ce qui vous
explique qu'il y aura un effet
d'attraction une submersion comme
certains M a appelé et je pense en des
termes qui sont exclusivement
condamnables il y a bien là d'abord et
avant tout un enjeu humanitaire à nos
portes au port de notre continent et
puis troisièmement nous devons agir
ensemble sur le sol européen nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts pour mieux
contrôler nos frontières extérieures
l'agence Frontex pourra désormais
mobiliser 10 000 gares de côtes et garde
frontières dans les prochaines années
afin d'aider les États membres en
matière de contrôle frontalier et de
reconduite il y a là un enjeu de
souveraineté européenne évident il faut
bien sûr refonder Schengen Schengen est
né sur deux jambes la liberté intérieure
de circulation de et de réel contrôle
une frontières extérieures depuis
maintenant 30 ans ce système est boiteux
la jambe de liberté intérieure est forte
la jambe de protection de frontières
extérieures est faible il nous faut donc
refonder ce système pour préserver notre
liberté de circulation en Europe si nous
voulons que la règle selon laquelle le
pays de première entrée et l'État membre
chargé de l'examen des demandes pour que
ce soit mieux appliqué et bien il nous
faut créer de la solidarité l'Italie la
Grèce l'Espagne ne peuvent pas seul
gérer le système tel qu'il est conçu
aujourd'hui car il est profondément
déséquilibré c'est l'un des enjeux de la
révision du régime d'asile européen le
fameux règlement de Dublin qui doit nous
permettre d'harmoniser nos systèmes
nationaux et de limiter ces demandes
multiples et parallèles de plusieurs
demandes d'asile dans plusieurs pays à
la suite qui on le voit crée des
mouvements secondaires qui sont
extrêmement difficiles à contrôler c'est
la l'essentiel de notre action pour les
prochains mois de Liona annoncé vouloir
impact Asie l'immigration la France est
à ses côtés et je pas vous dire qu'il y
a eu aujourd'hui
uneanimité en Europe sur le besoin de
refonder profondément ces deux piliers
d'asile d'immigrations et des stages
Schengen alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs notre modèle d'accueil
d'intégration et je crois l'honneur de
notre République notre devoir est bien
de tout faire pour en préserver la
viabilité en plus d'y consacrer nos
politiques nationales nous y employons
vous le voyez nos leviers d'action
internationaux et européens mais pour
mieux répondre aux défis migratoires
d'aujourd'hui et de demain nous avons
également besoin de VOUS élus de nos
territoires et je sais à cet égard la
qualité des travaux du Sénat informé
sérieux sur les thèmes de nos débats et
je suis donc particulièrement heureuse
d'échanger avec vous sur ces sujets dans
la transparence et la responsabilité
sous le regard des Français je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant madame
Christelle Dubos secrétaire d'État
auprès de la ministre des Solidarités de
la Santé
de la parole Madame le Ministre le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
Madame et Monsieur le Ministre mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
l'occasion nous est donnée d'évoquer
sereinement et en responsabilité à un
sujet qui trop souvent des chaînes les
passions
ça je crois une bonne occasion de tordre
le cou à beaucoup d'idées reçues tout en
nous montrant vigilant et ferme quand
les situations l'exigent
si je pense qu'il est important que l'on
puisse débattre ensemble de cette
question c'est évidemment parce que
l'interpelle nos concitoyens mais c'est
aussi parce que pendant plus de 20 ans
comme travailleur social j'ai été
confronté à tout ce que
l'incompréhension et la confusion
peuvent provoquer comme rejet de l'autre
et comme dégâts dans notre cohésion
sociale ma conviction profonde c'est
qu'il faut ouvrir ce sujet puisque c'est
un sujet à tous nos concitoyens et ne
pas le laisser à une seule famille
politique qui dupe nos concitoyens avec
un discours aussi brutal que simpliste
dans la foulée d'un grand débat
historique le président de la République
n'a pas éludé la question migratoire
allant jusqu'à affirmer que le deuxième
grand combat européen après le climat
c'est le combat en matière de migration
parce que oui l'enjeu des migration
dépasse largement les frontières de la
France et l'Europe doit construire cet
espace commun parce que une Europe qui
sait maîtrisée les flux migratoires ce
sont des États membres qui accueillent
mieux
accueillir c'est respecter des
conventions desquelles nous sommes
partis et dont l'accès aux droits
fondamentaux est un pilier essentiel en
France nous pouvons en mettre fiers
chacun quel que soit sa situation peut
accéder aux soins c'est tout le sens
d'une protection maladive qui est
universelle puisqu'elle remet elle
permet pardon à chaque personne qui
travaille ou qui réside en France de
manière stable et régulière de
bénéficier de la prise en charge de ces
frais de santé
en France votre couverture maladie ne
dépend pas de votre emploi ou de votre
statut cette protection est donc
accessible quelle que soit la
nationalité de l'assuré et elle inclut
les ressortissants étrangers titulaires
d'un titre de séjour les réfugiés mais
aussi les demandeurs d'asile
des dispositifs sont aussi prévus pour
la prise en charge des soins des
personnes migrantes en situation
irrégulière c'est le cas de l'aide
médicale d'État qui permet de couvrir
les soins essentiels des ressortissants
étrangers en situation irrégulière en
médecine de ville comme à l'hôpital
cette couverture n'est pas immédiate
puisqu'elle nécessite une présence d'au
moins de 3 mois sur le territoire par
ailleurs elle est délivrée sous
conditions de ressources
si ces conditions ne sont pas remplies
la prise en charge est alors limitée à
celle des soins d'urgence ces procédures
sont indispensables et Agnès Buzin l'a
bien rappelé lundi à l'Assemblée
nationale en France on ne laisse pas des
personnes périr parce qu'il leur manque
le bon tampon sur le bon document elles
sont aussi indispensables et vous en
conviendrez pour des raisons de santé
publique et pour éviter la propagation
de maladies l'aide médicale d'étain
répond aussi à un impératif d'économie
si elle n'existait pas elle aurait pour
conséquence une dépense plus grande
parce que une prise en charge tardive
d'une maladie est toujours plus coûteuse
qu'une prise en charge attend par la
médecine de ville pourtant il y a des
caricatures qui ont la vie dure et
l'aide médicale d'État ni échappent pas
l'aide médicale d'État et même devenu au
fil des années un motif récurrent des
discours de peur et de repli
il est temps de clarifier les choses
avec l'ame le niveau de prise en charge
est moins important que les assurés en
situation régulière qui a ce même niveau
de ressources bénéficient de la CMUC
plus précisément les actes de PMA les
médicaments à service médical rendu
faible remboursé à 15%. et bien sûr les
frais de cure thermale ne sont pas
prises en charge par l'ame les frais
pris en charge en grande partie par les
complémentaires santé tels que les frais
dentaires ou optiques ne sont pas pris
en charge par l'ame enfin les soins
invisés esthétiques ne sont bien
évidemment pas prises en charge par la
mue
s'agissant des autres droits sociaux
l'objectif est de faciliter
l'intégration des personnes sur ce sujet
je veux mettre fin là aussi aux idées
reçues qui voudraient que les étranges
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
et un large accès aux prestations
sociales les personnes en situation
irrégulière non droit à aucune
prestation en dehors de la prise en
charge de leur soins je n'inclus pas
dans ce propos les demandeurs d'asile
qui ne sont pas considérés comme étant
en situation irrégulière sur notre
territoire
s'agissant des personnes en situation
régulière nous appliquons des principes
constitutionnels et des règles
internationales qui s'imposent à tous et
par lesquels ce matérialise l'accès aux
droits fondamentaux ces principes nous y
tenons pour autant l'égalité de
traitement n'est pas total la plupart
des minimas sociaux sont soumis à des
conditions de résidence plus
restrictives pour les ressortissants
étrangers en situation régulière que
pour les ressortissants français par
exemple pour percevoir le RSA une
condition de 5 ans une résidence sur le
territoire et requise cette différence
de traitement n'est pas au contraire
n'est pas contraire pardon à nos
exigences de cibler les besoins des
populations concernées parce qu'il en va
de leur santé et de leur intégration il
ne faut pas oublier que les personnes
migrantes sont souvent plus vulnérables
il est donc indispensable d'aller vers
ces personnes pour qu'elles puissent
accéder aux soins et aux droits
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
structuré un parcours de santé des primo
arrivants en lien avec le secteur
associatif les professionnels de santé
les travailleurs sociaux et avec les
agences régionales de santé pour
organiser une prise en charge des
besoins le plus rapidement possible
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
avons augmenté les moyens à louer aux
permanence d'accès aux soins de santé
que l'on appelle les passes qui
réunissent soignants et travailleurs
sociaux et qui accueillent de manière
inconditionnelle et qui ont eu cette
mission d'accompagnement médico-social
des personnes les plus vulnérables et je
profite de ce débat pour saluer le
travail remarquable les travailleurs
sociaux des associations qui œuvrent
chaque jour avec une énergie remarquable
au service de cette intégration quand
certains cultivent une rente en
alimentant le rejet d'autres sont sur le
terrain et trouvent des solutions pour
que la cohésion sociale soit autre chose
qu'une belle expression dans un discours
pour autant nous sommes vigilants comme
pour toutes les politiques publiques
nous interrogeons sur l'efficience du
système et nous nous fermons pas la
porte à l'identification d'éventuelles
abus cette démarche est indispensable
pour restaurer la confiance dans notre
système qui semble aujourd'hui faire
défaut je pense en particulier à l'aide
médicale d'État qui représente une
dépense de 848 millions d'euros en 2018
c'est une dépense importante pourtant je
rappelle que la dépense par bénéficiaire
de l'AME est équivalente à la dépense
par bénéficiaire d'un assuré alors même
que l'état de santé des bénéficiaires de
l'ami de l'ame et notamment notoirement
plus dégradé
une mission a donc été confiée aux
inspections générales pour faire la
lumière sur des ventelles fraude ou abus
et pour proposer des pistes de
progression ces pistes pourront tenir
compte des modèles en vigueur chez
principaux voisins même si au-delà des
comparaisons c'est bien le cadre de
prise en charge le plus pertinent et le
plus efficace qu'il nous faut étudier
plusieurs options sont actuellement
étudiées par la mission d'inspection
nous regarderons l'ensemble des options
proposées avec une grande attention mais
je souhaite préciser dès aujourd'hui que
nous ne retiendrons pas toute solution
reposant sur une participation
financière des personnes admises à l'AME
cela constituerait un obstacle trop
important pour l'accès effectif aux
soins l'introduction éphémère d'un droit
de timbre en 2011 a montré qu'une telle
mesure ne faisait que reporter les coups
de prise en charge sur les soins urgents
deux autres pistes sont étudiées par la
mission d'inspection la piste consistant
à subordonner un accord préalable
l'accès à certaines prestations en
dehors des soins urgents ou vitaux ou
encore la piste conduisant à ajuster le
périmètre du panier de soins prise en
charge par la hame
mais encore une fois ce ne sont que des
pistes et nous attendons que la mission
rendre ses conclusions à la fin de ce
mois mais nous n'attendons pas cette
attente pas cette mission pour renforcer
les contrôles l'ame et les soins urgents
ne doivent pas être détournés de leur
vocation ils doivent bénéficier à ceux
qui en ont effectivement droit ces
contrôles portent sur les conditions
d'éligibilité à l'AME comme le durée de
séjour les ressources effectives des
demandeurs mais peuvent également
avoir lieu à posteriori en particulier
sur les bénéficiaires qui ont le plus
recours aux soins le regroupement des
demandes d'ame dans trois caisses
primaires d'assurance Malaisie permettra
de mieux les contrôler nous allons ainsi
déployer un plan de lutte contre les
fraudes l'une des mesures de ce plan
permettra de lutter contre le phénomène
des détournements de procédures de
ressortissants étrangers bénéficiant
d'une assurance privée dans le cadre
d'un visage Schengen mais qui demande
l'ame pour bénéficier de soins
considérés comme étant meilleur en
France
les caisses d'assurance maladie auront
accès dès la fin de l'année à la base
visa bio du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
permettra d'identifier les demandeurs
dissimulant un visa et n'ayant donc
aucunement vocation à bénéficier de
l'Ame ni aux soins urgent
voilà de manière très concrète et
pragmatique comment nous voulons
redonner confiance dans un système
auquel nous sommes très attachés
s'agissant du cas particulier de
demandeurs d'asile le régime est celui
d'une affiliation à l'assurance maladie
et donc souvent à la CMU C et de le
début et dès le dépôt à la demande une
autre signification des demandes d'asile
a été observée par des personnes en
provenance de pays signalés d'origine
sûr ce qui signifie que dans l'immense
majorité des cas c'est demande d'asile
n'aboutiront pas l'abus est donc rendue
possible par cette affiliation immédiate
à l'Assurance Maladie seule une étude
approfondie nous permettra d'en savoir
plus sur l'exigence l'existence de ces
filières et donc de repenser si cela est
nécessaire les conditions d'affiliation
à l'Assurance Maladie pour les
demandeurs d'asile cette étude est en
cours est la mission d'inspection est au
travail un des délais de carence pendant
lequel nous prendrions éventuer
évidemment pardon en charge les soins
urgents pourrait donc se concevoir comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs pour les
Français qui rentrent de l'étranger sans
activité professionnelle
lutter contre les fraudes c'est mettre
fin à une suspicion qui nuit à tous les
autres ça n'est donc pas remettre en
question notre obligation
constitutionnelle d'un accès à la santé
pour tous c'est surtout le moyen le plus
sûr de mettre enfin un terme aux idées
fausses qui circulent
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
faire vivre les grands principes sans
être naïf c'est être fidèle à nos
valeurs sans laisser prospérer des
discours de peur
notre exigence doit être celle de la
justice envers les populations
vulnérables plus pour que la manière
dont nous les accueillons soient
conformes à l'image que nous faisons de
la grandeur de la France je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de notre débat je le
rappelle
la parole des orateurs des groupes un
orateur par groupe un temps défini pour
chaque groupe et je vais appeler le
premier orateur et il s'agit de notre
collègue Jean-Yves Leconte pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
le Président Monsieur le Premier
Ministre madame mesdames des ministres
monsieur ministre mes chers collègues le
président de la République devant les
parlementaires de la majorité c'est
livré une action de populisme d'État qui
a étonné et qui a choqué
pourtant peut-être grâce à la
mobilisation d'une partie de sa majorité
de votre majorité monsieur le Premier
ministre le gouvernement a fait par lors
de ce débat d'une très grande mesure et
c'est heureux car nous devons si nous
voulons réussir l'accueil ne pas avoir
l'accueil honteux mais assumer notre
notre politique et nos valeurs il est
pourquoi cette précipitation malgré tout
dans dans ce débat veut-on éviter
d'attendre une évaluation objective de
la loi colon voter à l'été 2018 et en
particulier de ces mesures les plus
controversées je pense sont pas tuer la
doublement de la durée en centre de
rétention qui n'a fait que compliqué les
conditions de rétention mais aussi
celles des agents de la PAF et les
vidéos durant sans consentement des
personnes qui ont été le vecteur des
grèves que vous avez évoqué nous devons
pas avoir l'accueillante honteux et les
associations les collectivités les
citoyens qui se mobilisent pour réaliser
cet accueil doivent être accompagnés par
l'État
la France Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous l'avez dit lors à l'Assemblée
nationale ne doit pas être ni plus ni
moins attractif que ses voisins mais il
ne semblait que la politique du
président de la République était
justement de renforcer l'attractivité de
la France et cette attractivité il faut
l'assumer sur tous les aspects et en
particulier sur celui-ci car finalement
tous lisent les mêmes articles et
regarde les mêmes les mêmes discours les
simplifications vous avez évoqué il y a
quelques temps une mission que vous avez
donné au Conseil d'État pour
simplifier le droit des étrangers j'ai
pris ça pour votre sens de l'humour
légendaire dans la mesure où quand je
regarde la manière dont dans la loi
colon on a construit une usine à gaz
pour supprimer le
fait que un appel à la CNDA a été
suspensif pour doubler les procédures
administratives en même temps faire
appel à la CNDA et un tribunal
administratif pour tenter d'éviter de
tomber en dehors des exigences de la
CEDH j'ai trouvé ça quand même un peu
étonnant alors que c'est votre
gouvernement qui a compliqué un certain
nombre de procédures
mes chers collègues toutes les
migrations sont légitimes mais l'asile
qui protège le combattant de la liberté
la personne menacée dans son existence
est un droit un engagement et un devoir
pour notre nation nos principes
constitutionnels et nos engagements
conventionnels sont une partie de
nous-mêmes et toutes les migrations ne
peuvent pas être mises sur le même plan
pour déterminer si une personne de
relève de la Convention de Genève une
instruction de sa demande doit être
diligente
l'asile est un droit et l'immigration
est une politique il faut bien séparer
les choses l'immigration c'est aussi une
richesse qui accompagnait notre pays
dans ces années de croissance le Canada
qui n'a pas oublié que c'était une
richesse continue à prospérer c'est
assez étonnant d'ailleurs de réformer
les retraites qu'elle n'y aura plus
assez de cotisant bientôt et refuser de
constater des forces vives qui
travaillent parfois clandestinement dans
notre pays nous nous engageons ainsi
dans une spirale du déclin mais ce
premier ministre la loi Cazeneuve à
parier sur le fait que plus de droits
c'était plus d'efficacité dans le
traitement des demandes d'asile une
demande d'asile rapidement société c'est
une c'est plus facile il est plus facile
de dire non c'est aussi l'amitié aussi
la mise en place d'un dispositif
national d'accueil qui exigeait des
moyens des moyens qui ont été supprimés
par la loi que vous avez votée au
parlement l'année dernière la le
doublement de la durée ancra a aussi
compliqué
le travail et les conditions de
rétention des personnes Monsieur le
Premier Ministre l'Europe effectivement
et le cadre aujourd'hui de la politique
d'asile vous avez cité l'Albanie et la
Géorgie qui sont dans le tiercé de tête
des pays d'origine de la demande d'asile
en France c'est effectivement un
problème mais si en particulier notre
pays refuse à certains pays européens
une perspective européenne ce sont
parfois les citoyens qu'il apprennent
par eux-mêmes et c'est ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui se passe avec l'Albanie
c'est ce qui se passe avec beaucoup de
pays des balcons occidentaux c'est ce
qui se passe avec l'Ukraine vers la
Pologne
nous devons avoir une politique
européenne qui prend ceci en compte
il faut aussi avec ces pays-là pouvoir
signer des accords de sécurité sociale
permettant de répondre à un certain
nombre de difficultés que nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui et je signale
aussi que la mise en place des tias qui
a été
mise à nestigation de la France et qui
sera probablement développé d'ici 2 ans
permettra d'ici peu de pouvoir vérifier
pour les personnes les ressortissants
des pays qui n'ont pas besoin qui sont
pas soumis à l'exigence de visage si
effectivement il dispose des assurances
leur permettant d'arriver dans l'espace
Schengen donc sur ce point
comme sur le renforcement de Frontex qui
a été mis en oeuvre depuis 2016 oui
l'Europe n'est pas une contrainte pour
notre politique d'Asie l'immigration
mais bien une solution une solution qui
nous a permis de faire face en 2015 mais
qui aujourd'hui effectivement doit faire
face à deux inquiétudes d'une part la
situation en Turquie et en Grèce avec
une situation qui d'une Turquie qui n'a
plus la capacité de porter seul ce que
l'Europe lui demande et d'autre part un
pays l'Espagne qui doit faire face à lui
tout seul à la aux effets chez lui de la
crise migratoire américaine et en
particulier avec des ressortissants
vénézuéliens et nicaraguayen je voudrais
aussi préciser un peu les précisions qui
me semblent de voir être faites en ce
qui concerne la politique d'asile
européenne
Dublin pose deux difficultés d'abord
parce que il pose la responsabilité de
pays qui géographiquement sont au sud de
l'Europe et doit faire face pour tous
les autres
d'ailleurs s'ils ont accepté ça au début
c'est parce qu'ils ont jamais pensé
qu'on allait mettre en place un jour son
texte des hotspots et qu'on allait
obliger à l'enregistrement tout le monde
et si je le dis c'est parce que on doit
aujourd'hui faire preuve d'une plus
grande responsabilité et d'une plus
grande solidarité vis-à-vis de ces pays
on a vu les conséquences que ça pouvait
avoir en politique intérieure italienne
mais aussi parce que à partir du moment
où chaque demandeur d'asile chaque
personne qui rentre sur le territoire et
et et enregistré sur Eurodac ça a des
conséquences
et la deuxième difficulté c'est que ça a
été signalé il y a des mouvements
secondaires mais on ne peut pas traiter
de la même manière une personne qui est
rentrée en Italie et qui va dans un pays
pour faire une demande d'asile et dont
on dit bah il est dublinable en Italie
et une personne qui est allée vers
l'Allemagne qui a fait une demande en
Allemagne qui a été déboutée par
l'Allemagne qui revient après en France
ce sont deux choses différentes hors du
blinde fait pas la différence il faut
changer du blinde ce point de vue là et
d'ailleurs dans notre comportement à
nous nous avions proposé lors de la loi
la discussion de de la loisir
l'immigration l'année dernière que la
France prenne sur elle d'étudier les
demandes de ceux qui n'avaient pas une
demande d'asile et étudiée dans un pays
de première entrée en particulier
l'Italie à la Grèce pour les soulager et
la deuxième chose c'est que il n'est pas
possible de stigmatiser un certain
nombre de pays de l'espace Schengen qui
n'ont pas la même histoire que nous
si on ne peut pas avancer tous ensemble
mieux avancer plus loin à certains et je
pense que sur ce sujet une coopération
renforcée est possible on ne peut pas
demander à des pays qu'une étudiant pas
les demandes d'asile correctement de
participer à
d'accepter des personnes dont ils ont
étudié la demande ils vont pas le faire
correctement il convient d'abord de
faire en sorte que on est une
reconnaissance mutuelle des instructions
des demandes d'asile dans un dans avec
entre un certain nombre de pays
européens quitte à ce que ça soit une
coopération renforcée
cette coopération renforcée elle est
possible et pour que ce soit
suffisamment reconnu il faut faire une
cour européenne du droit d'Asie entre
ces pays de manière à assurer à tous les
demandeurs que leurs dossier sera prêté
de la même manière la deuxième chose
c'est assurer à une personne qui a
obtenu l'asile
quel a le droit à la même liberté de
bouger
d'installation qu'un ressortissant
européen enfin la troisième c'est de
développer les visas pour asiles en tout
cas dans le cadre de cette coopération
renforcée parce que la France le fait un
peu mais il faut essayer de normer un
peu plus tout cela il est pas logique
que beaucoup de ceux qui sont sans
statut et sans moyens dans nos rues soit
simplement des dublinés
qui ne savent pas où aller
quelques idées quelques rappels aussi
vous l'avez dit Madame la Ministre les
médicaments
des pathologies du sida en France sont
par des étrangers
50% des pathologies du sida des
étrangers ont été contractés en France
c'est toute l'image de la précarité et
toute l'importance de cette politique
qui est une politique de santé publique
ni plus ni moins
vous l'avez dit les quotas si on veut
respecter nos exigences on peut pas
faire grand-chose et on peut d'autant
moins faire grand-chose
qu'on a moins de 30 000 personnes qui
ont chaque année un premier titre de
séjour pour des raisons économiques
la Pologne en œuvre 20 fois plus
alors c'est quand même difficile de
faire en sorte de pouvoir le faire je
rappelle aussi que sur les étudiants le
grand succès de votre politique j'étais
au Brésil il y a peu de temps
cette année - 40 % d'étudiants
brésiliens arriveront en France par
rapport à l'année dernière voilà les
effets de la politique d'attractivité
sur ce sujet de de notre pays on a vous
avez aussi précisé les conditions du
regroupement familial qui sont
franchement pas favorables et qui
assurent que les personnes qui viennent
avec leur famille sont des personnes qui
contribuent au budget de la Nation et je
rappelle que les familles de Français
qui sont une partie importante des
personnes qui obtiennent des premiers
types de séjour ça n'est pas si simple
je vous le dis en tant que Français
d'étranger représentant des Français
étranger ce n'est pas si simple
d'arriver en France quand on est
conjointe français monsieur le Premier
ministre il faut aussi arrêter de dire
que en France c'est le droit du sol
c'est pas le droit du sol c'est le
double droit du sol
ou alors le droit du sol avec action
volontaire après condition de scolarité
et de stage c'est très différent parce
qu'il faut pas laisser croire aux gens
qu'il suffit de mettre en France pourra
devenir français parce qu'après on a la
situation de Mayotte
l'accueil aussi est une préoccupation
aujourd'hui plus de trois fois plus à
Paris qu'il y a quelques qu'il y a deux
ans et il a fallu qu'un décès soit
constaté à Saint-Herblain pour que la
Préfecture se mette enfin à faire un
recensement des besoins des personnes
qui étaient sur un campement nous avons
le sentiment que le gouvernement veut
exploiter cette situation au seuil des
municipales et Monsieur Griveaux n'a pas
échappé à ça hier les associations
collectivités ont besoin d'une
mobilisation des moyens qui viennent de
l'État et tout cela Monsieur le Premier
Ministre est absolument essentiel pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que elle se passe
correctement
je dirais aussi dans notre pays si on
veut réussir l'intégration
il faut arrêter de faire bienvenue chez
Kafka
les mineurs isolés qui sont accompagnés
par les départements ils ont 18 ans ils
ont laissé à eux-mêmes pour leur
prochain titre de séjour les difficultés
procédurales pour accéder aux droits du
travail qui favorise l'esclavage les
réseaux et qui sont totalement
hypocrites et qui favorisent ceux et les
employeurs qui ne veulent pas respecter
les droits
il n'y a pas d'intégration sans égalité
de droit et ça c'est particulièrement
important pour les personnes qui
naissent en France qui n'ont pas connu
leur pays d'origine et qui doivent se
sentir chez eux sinon on a un problème
et quoi dire des files d'attente qui se
multiplient et qui font qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup se retournent contre l'État
alors monsieur le Premier ministre il y
aurait encore beaucoup à dire
mais il est essentiel
de faire preuve de courage
l'asile c'est pas une charge
c'est un devoir c'est finalement quelque
chose qui vient de de ce que nous ont
appris ceux qui ont souffert au 20e
siècle de tout ce qui s'est passé en
Europe et qui nous disent que pour que
chacun ait des droits ils ont construit
un système d'accueil qui mérite qui est
aussi issu des principes de la
révolution française mais qui est aussi
issue de la réflexion des normes et mon
européens et que nous donnons pour
finalement faire en sorte que chacun
puisse se sentir citoyen du monde nous
n'avons pas à avoir peur
donnons-nous les moyens pour faire en
sorte que l'immigration soit une chance
que l'asile soit correctement assumée et
cela Monsieur le Premier Ministre nous
avons noté l'évolution de votre discours
entre celui du président de la
République il y a quelques semaines et
aujourd'hui mais il est absolument
indispensable il est absolument
indispensable de de marquer cette
attachement à l'accueil et que l'État
s'engage complètement
dans un cadre européen à faire en sorte
que sans stigmatisation nous puissions
arriver à choisir cette opportunité pour
en faire un acte et un vecteur de
progrès
la parole est
au président Jean-Claude Roquier pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social et européen
c'est le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres les chiens collègues
en juin dernier vous êtes engagé
monsieur le Premier ministre à tenir un
débat annuel ça politique migratoire
devant les assemblées parlementaire nous
nous félicitons donc de cette discussion
d'aujourd'hui dans cette question
véhicule d'inquiétude mais aussi de
fantasmes de contre-vérité un moment où
les valeurs de la République doit être
raffirmé et surtout appliquer avec force
et détermination la question migratoire
nourrit de nombreux populismes en France
comme chez certains de nos voisins et
l'argent moi-même de dangereuse fracture
au sein de l'Union européenne pour notre
part nous abordons ce débat en toute
responsabilité sans algérisme ni
aveuglement fort des valeurs de dignité
que nous avons toujours défendues
car cette question est complexe elle
pose à nos sociétés des défis inédits
dans leur ampleur comme dans leur durée
depuis le pic migratoire de 2015 le
nombre d'arrivés au frontières de
l'Europe a fortement faibli cela a été
rappelé et là ce reflux n'évite pas de
nouvelles tragédie comme encore
récemment la noyade 18 personnes au
large de Casablanca nul ne peut
évidemment rester insensible face à de
tels graves ce qui ne doit pas nous
interdire d'aborder aussi la question
migratoire sous l'angle de la sécurité
de la politique intérieure et de
l'intégration pour autant le premier
facteur des migrations et économique ou
pour tout dire le motard fondamental de
vivre dignement aussi bien que aussi
bien que le taux d'extraire pauvreté
dans le monde était divisé par près de 4
depuis 30 ans 800 millions de personnes
vivent encore dans un déniement total on
compte encore trop d'états failli ou en
proie des conflits de capacité pour
envisager un tarissement des flux de
réfugiés n'oublions pas non plus que les
migrations climatiques ne feront
qu'augmenter dans ces conditions il est
évident que pour beaucoup de ces femmes
de ces hommes migrés est avant tout une
nécessité vitale de même pour nos pays
développés accueillir dignement et
garantir l'intégration sont
indispensables et appellent une réponse
adaptée avant ce débat ils ont été
utiles de dresser un premier bilan de la
loi asile immigration 2018 d'autant
qu'une nouvelle réforme du contentieux
des étrangers
semble-t-il en préparation la politique
migratoire comporte deux axes la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière en lien
avec les pays de départ et la politique
d'accueil et d'intégration sur notre sol
le premier acte axe qui se déploie à
l'échelle européenne apporte ses fruits
en réduisant je l'ai dit les flux depuis
2015 lieu a mis en œuvre un certain
nombre de mesures comment gros par a
prouver pour la plupart encore avec la
Turquie en mars 2017 mise en place du
sport création du Centre européen de
lutte contre le trafic des migrants et
bien sûr les dispositifs de
relocalisation néanmoins le Conseil
européen avait préconisé fin 2018
d'action qui la lutte contre les
trafiquants où en est-on sur ce point
qu'en est-il du renforcement du mandat
de l'agence européenne ex-fontex et en
particulier du déploiement des gardes
frontières et des experts en matière de
retour
s'agissant de l'accueil des migrants
certains points font certes polémiques
derrière des questions légitimes
sommes-nous en capacité d'offrir un
accueil digne aux personnes qui arrivent
en France
comment bien accueillir en fonction de
nos capacités pour permettre une réelle
intégration en notre sens rien ne doit
être tabou des dispositifs peuvent être
ainsi discutés tant qu'il s'inscrivent
dans les valeurs et les principes de
notre République je pense en particulier
à l'aide des médicaments à laquelle
l'ensemble de mon groupe reste
profondément attaché d'abord parce
qu'elle participe du droit inalignable
la santé pour toute personne ensuite
parce qu'elle contribue à la protection
des populations comme instrument de
prévention des maladies contagieuses
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas naïfs notre
généralité notre générosité n'est pas
illimitée nous pouvons balayer de revers
de main l'idée de réformer ce dispositif
pour mieux le calibrer et surtout lutter
contre les abus pour notre part nous
attendons les conclusions de la mission
d'inspection mandatées par madame la
ministre de la Santé le regroupement
familial et lui aussi soit un pointé du
doigt pour de mauvaises raisons les
chiffres en réalité très stables depuis
au moins 2011 avec même pour se situer
autour de 90 000 admissions par an sur
un total de 256 000 titres de séjour
délivré en 2018
durcir d'un coup les conditions de
regroupement familial et certaines vend
pas la bonne solution pour réguler les
migration légale d'autant que nous
sommes également liés par des
engagements bibli latéraux et
internationaux sommes-nous condamner à
ne rien faire je ne crois pas peut-être
pourrions-nous explorer des pistes
d'évolution respectueux de nos principes
par exemple à l'introduisant comme
l'Allemagne le critère d'une maîtrise
minimale de langue française ou à
renforçant le contrôle du respect par le
candidat auront familial des valeurs de
la République un sujet qui nous
préoccupe celui des quotas un thème que
vous avez évoqué Monsieur le Premier
Ministre avec beaucoup de vertus il nous
paraît pas illégitime de réfléchir à
fixer des priorités en fonction des
besoins de notre économie comme le font
déjà d'autres pays
que les marges d'amélioration existent
quand on sait qu'une partie demandeur
viennent des pays sûrs le cas des
ressortissant albanais et georgien et
souvent cité on peut en tout cas se
féliciter de l'amélioration du
traitement des dossiers ainsi que de
l'augmentation des capacités
d'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile
même si nous donnons mieux faire
néanmoins aucune réponse de ces
référennes si elle ne s'inscrit pas dans
un cadre européen le règlement de Dublin
qui permet de défausser ce quelques pays
en première ligne notamment l'Italie et
Malte n'est pas digne de la solidarité
européenne malgré les petits
arrangements consentis au fil de la
crise migratoire avec mes collègues du
RDSE nous l'espérons que la corde
répartition qui s'est dessiné fin
septembre La Valette distingua les
demandeurs d'asile des réfugiés
économiques aboutira concrètement à
faire mes chers
de l'aide publique au développement
aider les pays d'origine des migrants
est une nécessité à deux égards par le
biais d'une coopération pour la question
des frontières des pays de départ mais
aussi par renforcement des soutiens au
développement des pays qui offrent peu
d'espoir à leur concitoyens les
priorités se situent essentiellement à
l'Afrique subsaharienne se donne
rediscuterons dans le cas du Triat du
projet de loi de programmation et
d'orientation de l'aide au développement
en ce qui concerne le niveau de l'aide
avec nos 0,44% du revenu national brut
nous sommes encore loin des objectifs de
0,7 défini par le Comité de
développement de l'OCDE mais signe alors
l'effort d'atteindre les 0,51% en 2022
notre pays l'homme déjà fait nous devons
nous envoyer au delà des enjeux de
migrations et aussi question de sécurité
car le sud développement et le terreau
de délinquance des états du terrorisme
avec les conséquences que nous
connaissons mes chers collègues dans un
pays monde de plus en plus ouverts les
migrations ne cesseront jamais notre
pays c'est un orgueilli sa tradition
d’accueil en conformité avec ses
principes humanistes toutefois les
réalités des montres bien que nous
accueil doivent être revus en profondeur
que l'intégration doit retrouver un
nouveau souffle ce défi est un défi
majeur pour notre pays Mango veillera
toujours à ce que soit relevé un accord
avec les valeurs qui honorent notre pays
en résumé et en conclusion
niangélisme ni catastrophisme mais un
humanisme réaliste merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant notre
collègue Alain Richard pour le groupe de
la République en marche il a 8 minutes
de la parole président
mes chers collègues le débat qui nous
réunit à l'initiative du gouvernement
et je crois nécessaire pour clarifier
nos choix collectifs
tenons-le à la bonne hauteur et faisons
en un guide partagé de notre politique
c'est la responsabilité première d'un
État démocratique de décider sur son
territoire quelle personne peut y être
accueillies et avec quel accès aux
droits qui sont reconnus
une limitation et une régulation des
entrées sont de la nature même des
missions d'un État souverain
tous les pays neufs dans l'histoire qui
se sont peuplés par l'immigration sur le
modèle des États-Unis dès le 18e siècle
ont tous fixé des limites au droit
d'entrée en les adaptant suivant les
périodes et suivant la consolidation de
leur société nous-mêmes aujourd'hui
avant tous conscience de la nécessité de
faire respecter de telles limites à
l'accès à notre sol pour maintenir les
équilibres humains et la cohésion de
notre société seul des doctrines
extrémistes réclament l'abolition de
toute frontières et tout contrôle
territoriale observant d'ailleurs que
ceux qui les défendent ne sont pas parmi
les plus pacifiques lorsqu'ils défilent
dans nos rues
cette régulation est la condition pour
que la France assure avec succès
l'intégration
républicaine qui est notre tradition et
qui reste notre impératif pour garantir
à nos comptes compatriotes une société
ouverte et solidaire
l'immigration sous ses diverses formes
représentent entre 250 et 320 000
personnes par an suivant l'estimation
que l'on peut faire des entrées
irrégulières
c'est le même ordre de grandeur que
l'augmentation régulière de la
population française qui se situe entre
280 000 et 300.000 habitants
supplémentaires par an bien entendu les
deux chiffres ne sont pas uniques il y a
d'autres mouvements mais notre
connaissance à tous ici des réalités
locales nous fait bien percevoir que ce
chiffre de nouveaux arrivants est un
facteur de tension pour notre situation
du logement tout particulièrement bien
sûr la Paris périphérie des grandes
villes et pèse sur nos principaux
services publics en premier
l'enseignement et la santé la régulation
du nombre d'entrants et donc une
condition première d'une intégration
accomplie pour chaque personne admise
sur notre sol
nous pouvons constater une large
convergence sur ce principe simple les
divergences commencent quand on cherche
d'abord à estimer le nombre préférable
et surtout quand on veut décider et
appliquer quels moyens concret seront
employés pour écarter les entrées que
nous ne voulons pas que nous devons
refuser
à ce sujet je souhaite marquer une
distance Monsieur le Premier Ministre
face à l'idée de quota d'immigration qui
revient encore la plus grande part des
entrées sur notre sol vient de processus
de rapprochement familial d'accès aux
études supérieures et d'asile politique
seul le séjour étudiants peuvent faire
l'objet d'une limitation légitime et
c'est déjà fait et aussi l'immigration
professionnelle qui comme ça a été dit
est le plus la plus faible composante à
peine plus de 10%. on ne fixera pas de
quota ni d'entrée familiale ni le titre
de réfugiés les points noirs de notre
situation sont à trois niveaux le
traitement des demandes d'asile le
mouvement des mineurs isolés et la
coordination européenne insuffisante
dans l'espace de libre circulation
l'asile politique est une obligation
souscrite par notre pays comme 140
autres pour protéger les personnes
menacées dans leur vie par la violence
régnant dans leur pays
nous ne pouvons faillir cette obligation
qui répond impérativement à nos
engagements et au fondement humaniste de
la République en revanche la lucidité
élémentaire nous oblige à constater que
chaque année les deux tiers des demandes
d'asile présentées en France se révèle
injustifiés après pourtant un examen
scrupuleux par l'OFPRA et par la justice
avec d'extrême garanties de droit de la
défense et ce n'est pas un hasard
malencontreux la plupart de ces demandes
à justifier sont présentés pour obtenir
en réalité une voix d'immigration non
contrôlée l'abus organisée du droit
d'asile est un défi à notre système de
droit auquel nous avons le devoir de
remédier faute de quoi l'exercice de ce
droit d'asile sera lui-même atteint
le déroulement de l'examen des demandes
la situation dans laquelle sont placés
les demandeurs pendant la procédure et
les modalités de leur contrôle sont à
réexaminer encore plus rigoureusement
car la situation actuelle certes on
évolution aboutit à ce qu'une grande
majorité des personnes dont la demande
d'asile injustifiée et rejetée se
maintiennent sur le territoire en toute
irrégularité c'est un effectif entre 50
et 70 000 personnes chaque année qui se
trouve installées sur notre territoire
sans en remplir aucune condition nous ne
devons pas laisser se perpétuer un
circuit de fraude qui mine l’application
de tout notre droit nous avons légiféré
pour rétablir la norme nos voisins de
l'Union européenne non pas ce phénomène
de détournement en tout cas pas du tout
à la même ampleur nous devons donc avec
vous mesdames et messieurs du
gouvernement pour suivre nos efforts
pour une véritable application de la loi
sur l'asile
nous avons une autre source préoccupante
d'entrée irrégulière qui est le
mouvement des mineurs isolés c'est aussi
de manière massive le résultat de
filières organisée ce n'est pas par une
démarche individuelle et improvisée que
des milliers de jeunes détruisent leur
document d'identité juste après avoir
franchi le contrôle à l'aéroport et se
dirige directement vers le service
d'aide à l'amphion en France dont
l'adresse est enregistrée sur leur
téléphone portable la manière purement
sociale dont nous essayons de gérer
cette fraude organisée ne peut suffire
et monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
je suis obligé de répéter une édition
une question à laquelle je n'ai pour
l'instant pas eu de réponse de la part
de l'exécutif ce flux d'entrée me paraît
être de l'ordre de 15 à 20 000 personnes
supplémentaires par an et je ne sais pas
je n'arrive pas à savoir si on constate
des phénomènes de même ampleur dans les
autres pays de l'Union européenne ou
s'ils n'ont pas de même les chiffres
comparables
comme je le crois quelle méthode
conforme au droit ont-ils mis au point
qui nous seraient à nous inaccessible
nous dans ces deux domaines il n'est pas
viable que nous continuions à énoncer
une politique largement partagée et que
nous échouillons à la faire passer dans
la réalité
j'en termine par le sujet est trop large
pour notre temps de débat d'aujourd'hui
le rapprochement entre européen je
voudrais simplement sans casser
l'ambiance insister sur une réalité
contrariante il s'agit d'une compétence
souveraine des États de l'Union
européenne qui n'a été mise en partage
communautaire par aucun traité
donc nous pouvons tous en choisissant
des mots rassurants et j'ai encore
entendu parler de politique européenne
de telle ou telle composante de
l'immigration mais attention à ne pas
être trompeur Schengen est un traité
Dublin est un traité ce sont des accords
entre État souverain laborieusement
négocié jusqu'à ce qu'on est d'accord de
pays aux approches et aux situations
profondément dissemblables
notre groupe ne peut donc qu'encourager
le gouvernement suivant les engagements
du Président qui font tous leurs efforts
pour établir des positions communes mais
comme le disait madame la secrétaire
d'État tout à l'heure conclure des
accords partiels ou temporaires nous en
avons impérativement besoin pour faire
converger un contrôle digne et équitable
de l'immigration avec la libre
circulation dont jouissent nos 460
millions de concitoyens mais pendant ce
travail si contraignant si lent et pas
toujours promis au succès parce que
j'entends toujours chacun expliqué qu'il
faut refaire Dublin de A à Z qu'il faut
compléter ou refaire Schengen mais quand
trouvera-t-on l'accord de l'ensemble des
pays membres
et que fera-t-on tant qu'on ne l'aura
pas donc
pendant ce temps là au moins développons
les coopérations pratiques entre état
volontaire les comparaisons
professionnelles pourquoi par exemple
avons-nous des taux d'acceptation si
différents entre ce qui sort de l'ofpa
pour les mêmes nationalités et ceux qui
sort des organismes équivalents dans le
reste de l'Europe et en tout cas
essayons de retrouver un contrôle qui
partiellement nous échappe cette méthode
qu'on pragmatique mais exigeante je
termine président
sur l'efficacité à chaque étape du
procédure du processus et la seule voie
pour garder notre politique
d'immigration la boussole qui doit la
guider fixer des principes clairs
d'ouverture et combattre lucidement les
mécanismes qui cherchent à les
contourner si le débat d'aujourd'hui
nous aide à clarifier ces principes en
dialogue de façon rationnelle de
tolérante entre nous et avec l'exécutif
nous aurons accompli notre devoir
d'éclairer l'avenir du pays
merci
cher collègue je vais appeler monsieur
et Fun Radio qui va s'exprimer pour 5
minutes titre de la réunion des
sénateurs m'appartenant à aucun groupe
il s'exprimera son nom personnel bien
évidemment
mais les paroles pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues et les migration est une
chance pour la France
tel est depuis une trentaine d'années la
devise sinon de la République du moins
d'une classe politique qui a tout renié
jusqu'à laisser mourir l'identité du
peuple français regroupement familial et
facement des frontières discriminations
positives à l'embauche assistant social
droit d'asile faux mineurs mais vrai
clandestins majeur vous avez créé toutes
les conditions d'une véritable
submersion migratoire alors
l'immigration est une chance mais pour
qui assurément pas pour nos compatriotes
pour une caste politique elle a permis
de sauver quelques élections grâce à ses
nouveaux français pour d'autres elle a
permis de recevoir des subventions
publiques et d'affriter des bateaux pour
ramener des clandestins des côtes
libyens jusqu'en Europe les chiffres
sont éloquents en 2016 seul 7% des
étrangers qui se sont installés chez
nous étaient munis d'un contrat
d'embauche les migration n'est plus et
depuis longtemps une immigration de
travail mais une immigration de
peuplement pour assister sociaux pour
nos compatriotes la facture est
exorbitante je vous le dis
solennellement mes chers collègues je ne
crois pas à la théorie du Grand
remplacement en revanche je suis
convaincu de sa réalité je m'évoquerai
pas moi le bruit le bruit et les odeurs
si cher au président disparu mais ces
zones qui se comptent par centaines à
travers le pays qui sont devenus des
enclavés étrangères des zones de
non-frances ou la haine de tout ce qui
est français se répand comme une traînée
de poudre nos lois notre culture notre
identité notre savoir-vivre notre
savoir-être nos libertés celles des
femmes en particulier comme les libertés
sexuelles et religieuses sont rejetées
combattues pour être elle aussi
remplacée sous les coups d'un
communautarisme islamistes militants
l'idéologie du vivre-ensemble s'écroule
sous le poids de la réalité d'une
immigration chaque jour plus violente et
conquérante et met en danger notre unité
nationale et républicaine
seuls ceux qui en ont les moyens en
réchappent et parmi ceux-là vous tous ou
presque mes chers collègues car si la
classe politique est favorable aux vivre
ensemble elle ne s'inflige pas le vivre
avec l'immigration c'est comme les
éoliennes ceux qui ont défendent
l'installation refusent d'en voir à côté
de chez eux votre politique
d'immigration mes chers collègues a
aussi le coup du sang du Bataclan à Nice
de Laura Morane à Timothy ou à Théo
c'est notre jeunesse qui est sacrifiée
sur l'hôtel d'une idéologie destructrice
sur le plan social la politique
d'immigration relève de la provocation
alors que chaque jour de nouveaux
sacrifice sont exigés des Français
l'immigration continue d'être un tonneau
des Danaïdes le coût de la hame qui
bénéficie au seul clandestin est passé
de 400 millions il y a 15 ans à un
milliard d'euros aujourd'hui les
Français ne s'y trompent plus ou plutôt
vous ne les trompez plus ils sont
majoritaires à refuser se suicide
national les Français en ont marre les
Français en ont assez 40 ans qu'il se
pousse qu'il consente les sacrifices
qu'ils accueillent l'autre et quand il a
obtenu un retour le développement d'un
insupportable racisme anti-Français
anti-blanc anti-chrétiens nos
compatriotes refusent la submersion de
devenir des étrangers dans leur propre
pays alors vous menacez vous censurer et
vous traînez devant les tribunaux c'est
résistants qui refusent de collaborer
comment pouvez-vous avoir les yeux aussi
grand fermés devant le ce phénomène
unique dans l'histoire de l'humanité et
des nations celui de l'explosion
démographique mondiale loin d'en prendre
conscience et fidèle à son en même temps
Emmanuel Macron parcourt l'Europe pour
sanctionner les pays qui refusaient les
quotas de migrants et ils s'apprêtent de
faire à faire pardon de Marseille un
port d'accueil pour les clandestins de
la Méditerranée Marseille
qui subit déjà une situation migratoire
sociale et sécuritaire explosives une
provocation que je continuerai à des et
à dénoncer pardon comme c'est le cas
depuis comme c'est le cas depuis
longtemps et même si cela doit me coûter
une mise en examen comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui car dans ce beau pays de
France un parlementaire qui dénonce un
trafic d'être humain se retrouve devant
les tribunaux face à ce danger mortel
qui menace notre nation et l'Europe de
Charlemagne de Charles Martel de Charles
Quint personne à nous fera taire mais
nous attendons bien autre chose que de
se faux débat les seules questions qui
devraient vous animer sont celles-là
avons-nous nous Français le droit de
vivre en France selon nos traditions et
notre identité avant nous le droit de
rester ce que nous sommes et de
transmettre à nos enfants ce que nous
avons reçu de nos parents avant nous le
droit de demeurer français dans une
France française nous connaissons la
réponse et le sursaut national ne peut
donc venir d'aucun d'entre vous aussi
pour toutes les victimes de votre folle
politique d'immigration pour les
victimes sociales économiques et
identitaires pour toutes ces familles
dans la vie était détruite sous les
coups de l'immigration sauvage je vous
demande mes chers collègues de droite
comme de gauche car vous êtes tous
responsables de ce désastre je vous
demande de vous excuser excusez vous
pour avoir menti excusez vous pour avoir
il va falloir conclure
je conclus monsieur le Président merci
excusez vous en instaurant la préférence
nationale dans tous les domaines en
rétablissant les frontières en mettant
en place des quotas non pas
d'immigration mais des quotas
d'expulsion excusez vous en inversant le
courant de l'immigration si vous refusez
pas votre
idée c'est la France qui vous maudira
merci
la parole est maintenant
à madame la Présidente Eliane assassy
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et Monsieur
les ministres
l'immigration n'est pas un tabou mais
bien votre totem pour preuve après près
de 20 réformes sur l'immigration en 30
ans et alors que la loi agile et
immigration de Monsieur Collomb a été
promulgué l'année dernière nous voilà de
nouveau à débattre de la politique
migratoire de la France et de l'Europe
pas besoin donc de trouver un
justificatif pour se débat alors on peut
s'interroger que s'est-il passé depuis
le vote de la dernière loi pourquoi un
débat sous ce format précis est-ce pour
revenir sur les dispositifs les plus
graves de la loi Colomb tel que la
suspicion généralisée à l'égarder
demandeurs d'asile la multiplication du
recours à l'enfermement administratif y
compris d'enfants ou contre les
expulsions vers des pays en guerre
est-ce pour améliorer les conditions
d'accueil dans les préfectures monsieur
le Premier ministre je vous ai écouté
lundi à l'Assemblée nationale et donc
cet après-midi ici au Sénat est
visiblement ce n'est pas le voulu en
résumé la dernière loi adoptée en
matière d'immigration a été déjà très
dure et vous venez aujourd'hui nous
expliquer comment être encore plus dur
je ne m'y attarderai pas longtemps mais
les visées politiciennes et
électoralistes évidentes que portent en
lui ce débat sont dangereuses car elles
ouvrent comme on l'a encore entendu il y
a quelques secondes les vannes de
logorrhée
violente vulgaire mais l'encens vergogne
religion et nationalité par des
négationsnistes et des personnages
condamnés pour propos racistes mais
revenons à notre sujet la crise
économique sociale et environnementale
que traverse notre pays et profonde elle
génère colère et angoisse à l'origine en
particulier et des mouvements du
mouvement des gilets jaunes le fameux
grand débat national nous aura pourtant
au moins enseigné cela
les questions migratoires sont loin
d'être parmi les premières
préoccupations des Français ces Français
que le président essaie d'opposer aux
immigrés bien sûr responsables de tous
les mots des classes populaires qui ont
sauvé les victimes les bourgeois étant
exonérés de tout soupçon raciste au-delà
du mépris indécent que révèle de telles
propos ce discours est pour le moins
simpliste les immigrés constituant aussi
le tissu social des classes populaires
s'il veut se soucier des classes
populaires le président de la République
ferait mieux d'agir pour développer les
services publics pour améliorer
l'urgence d'urgence et conditions de vie
en termes de logements de santé de
transport par exemple et pour lutter
contre la précarité et le chômage dans
le territoire en Seine-Saint-Denis par
exemple je l'invite d'ailleurs à venir y
constater que malgré des conditions de
vie quelques peu difficiles le vivre le
ensemble le vivre ensemble subsiste
c'est aussi cela regardez en face
l'immigration est un vrai sujet
mais pour moi ce n'est pas un problème
pour relancer ce débat vous agitez et
manipuler les chiffres du droit d'asile
François
errant professeur au Collège de France
titulaire de la Charte de la chair
migration et société considèrent pour sa
part que s'il y a problème c'est parce
que le diagnostic initial est faux la
France est loin très loin d'être le
premier pays d'Europe pour la demande
d'asile raisonné en chiffre absolu n'a
aucun sens quand il s'agit de comparer
des pays de taille inégal et de richesse
variable ainsi en passant des chiffres
bruts au chiffre relatifs les 400 000
demandes enregistrées sur notre sol
depuis janvier 2015 ne représente que
10% du total européen et dans
l'hypothèse où tout serait resté en
France ils l'ont accru notre population
que de
0,6% contre 2% en Allemagne et
0,8% dans l'Union européenne
aussi à l'échelle de l'Europe d'une
autre population et notre économie on se
fourvoie quand on imagine que des
facteurs d'attraction exceptionnelles
comme l'aide médicale d'État ou le
regroupement familial mettrai notre pays
en première ligne je voudrais m'attarder
un peu plus longuement sur la réforme
annoncée de l'aide médicale d'État faire
resurgir ce débat et largement
révélateur de la logique politique
stigmatisée encore et toujours la figure
du migrant jusqu'à la caricature après
le shopping de l'asile la République en
marche et le gouvernement nous ont parlé
de tourisme médical mais sachez que
toute mesure qui contribue à réduire
l'accès de toutes et tous à la santé et
contraire au respect des droits
fondamentaux et porte atteinte à la
dignité individuelle de plus cela
soulève d'importantes questions en
matière de santé publique la ministre de
la manière Buzin se veut rassurante sur
le sujet mais quand même ne soyons pas
dupe les conclusions des rapports
demandés aux inspections concernées
interviendront juste au moment de
l'examen du PLFSS nous veillerons aux
mesures qui seront à leur adoptées
tous ces reculs proposés au niveau
national ne sont bien sûr que le reflet
de la politique migratoire européenne en
vigueur l'approche uniquement
sécuritaire de l'immigration par l'Union
européenne est plus à démontrer elle est
parfaitement assumée depuis la création
de l'agence Frontex que vous n'avez de
cesse dans son C sans parler des accords
avec la Turquie suite à la crise
syrienne dans ce cas deux points doivent
être soulignés soulevés au niveau
européen premièrement la définition des
pays d'origine sûr je pense que cela
doit être revu je pense évidemment aux
prétendus détournement du droit d'asile
que vous évoquez en boucle pour les
Albanais les Géorgiens l'asile n'a été
accordée qu'à 8% des Albanais et 5% des
Géorgiens pour chasser bien souvent pour
des raisons de vendetta d'orientation
sexuelle ou même d'engagement politique
comme le rappelle la Cimade ou lardis
mais d'autres pays bien peu sûr
cette liste je pense par exemple au
Bénin qu'en pensez-vous deuxièmement le
règlement de Dublin que vous appelez de
vos vœux à renforcer est obsolète un
autre système doit le remplacer à
plusieurs reprises le Défenseur des
droits a appelé le gouvernement à
suspendre l'application de ces
règlements pour permettre à des
personnes extrêmement fragilisées par
des mois des ronces de demander la ville
il rappelle qu'il existe je cite en
Europe plusieurs centaines de milliers
de personnes dont le retour dans le pays
d'origine du fait de leur nationalité
est impossible mais qui en application
de ces règles ne trouveront jamais déçu
juridique et humaine à leur situation or
en 2017 la France a été la championne
européenne des refus d'entrée aux
frontières terrestres renvoyant
massivement des personnes en quête de
protection vers l'Italie quoi qu'il en
soit la question de l'immigration se
reposera très rapidement dans des termes
internationaux il nous faudra alors
défendre une interprétation plus large
des critères de la Convention de Genève
notamment pour tenir compte des nouveaux
codes des nouvelles causes d'exils
forcés qui affectent des groupes entiers
de personnes notamment les conséquences
du dérèglement climatiques renforcer les
opérations de police aux frontières et
la politique d'expulsion ne changera
rien à cet état de fait pas plus que
l'instauration de quotas révélateur
d'une vision néo-colonialiste et assez
étroite de nos frontières je vise je
vous invite au contraire à prendre
connaissance de l'éloge des frontières
de Régis Depré pour de Régis Debré pour
qui je le cite la frontière rend égale
tant soit peu les puissances inégales
les riches vont où ils veulent attirent
d'elle les plus pauvres vont où ils
peuvent en ramant ceux qui ont la
maîtrise des stocks peuvent jouer avec
les flux en devenant encore plus riche
ceux qui n'ont rien en stock
sont les jouets de ces flux
tout à fait président la France plutôt
que de se replier sur elle-même
sonorerait à mieux travailler et faire
des propositions à la représentation
nationale pour agir efficacement en
faveur du développement et dans la
réparation de dangereuses décisions
géopolitiques comme en Libye par exemple
pour mieux accueillir celles et ceux qui
ne demandent pas le monde et qui ne
viennent pas manger notre pain mais nous
demande asile aide respect et dignité et
participent au développement de notre
pays et ne l'oublions pas aussi de leur
pays d'origine
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président Claude
Malhuret
il a 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
fallait-il ouvrir ce débat
pour les professionnels de l'indignation
c'est non
le seul mot d'immigration tel le marteau
du médecin sur un tendon rotulien
déclenche la phrase réflexe vous faites
le jeu du Front national
les donneurs de leçons qui aiment les
mots pompeux on en trouvait un qui fait
florès depuis 15 jours il paraît
qu'Emmanuel Macron triangule
ils veulent lire par là qu'il Braconne
sur les terres des autres je sais pas où
est-ce qu'il y a un triangle mais pas
son
quand est-ce que les détenteurs du
monopole du cœur comprendront ce qui les
a entraînés en salle de réanimation
idéologique
l'angélisme et le victimisme qui mettent
les faits en fuite et qui ont conduit en
déclarant tabou l'immigration et
d'autres sujets à ce que les classes
populaires leur tournent les talons
comment on abandonne un matelas usé
devant sa porte
le réel ne cessant pas d'exister parce
qu'on l'ignore on laisse à l'extrême
droite le champ libre pour protéger avec
une fixité de poteau indicateurs ces
absurdités montées sur des échasses et
ses pulsions xénophobes nous venons d'en
avoir un exemple tout à l'heure
c'est ainsi que les populistes sont
aujourd'hui aux portes du pouvoir
je ne vois donc pas de raison de me
mêler au coeur des pleureuses et je vais
parler de la politique migratoire et de
l'intégration bien sûr ce débat n'est
pas sans risque premier danger les deux
bouts de l'omelette comme disait Alain
Juppé sont en embuscade ouvrez les
frontières contre immigration zéro les
fonds de commerce du gauchisme
irresponsable et de l'extrême droite
intolérante deux rhinocéros au cuir
épais à la vue basse et toujours prêt à
charger vont resurgir
et l'opposition républicaine à gauche
comme à droite sera tenté de pimenter
ses discours d'un peu de cette
radicalité je voudrais inviter à y
renoncer voici 40 ans que l'immigration
et l'exemple même de l'impuissance
publique 40 ans que nous faisons ce que
dénoncer Richelieu qui disait faire des
lois et ne pas les exécuter c'est
autorisé ce que l'on veut interdire ceci
doit nous inciter à l'humilité
le deuxième danger c'est le risque
Dalida paroles paroles
les Français veulent les actes
il y a d'abord selon qu'ils ne veulent
plus ils ne veulent plus voir à la
télévision des réfugiés noyés et échoués
sur les plages après avoir été
abandonnés par les passeurs ils ne
veulent plus voir les pays européens se
livrait à des querelles de cour d'école
chaque fois qu'arrive un bateau de
migrants il ne veut plus voir qu'elle
est et Vintimille il ne veut plus voir
les centaines de tentes alignés le long
des boulevards et des quais ils ne
veulent plus voir les prostituées
albanaises ou africaines esclaves
tragique de mafia dont on avait cru
notre pays débarrassé à jamais
ce que veulent les Français c'est
d'abord comprendre il voit bien que le
maintien des illégaux sur notre
territoire est un fléau pour les
sans-papiers eux-mêmes forcés à la
précarité à la clandestinité et une
épreuve pour la population contrainte de
voisiner avec les squats ou les ghettos
il souhaite donc que les reconduites à
la frontière soit effective
les Français ont compris que le sujet
n'est pas seulement national mais
européen mais ils ne comprennent pas que
l'Europe n'est ni le mandat ni les
moyens de le traiter Frontex va voir ses
effectifs assez de 2000 à 10000 agents
très bonne nouvelle moins bonne quand on
apprend que le chiffre de 10000 sera
atteint en 2027
les Français veulent qu'on trouve des
solutions pour faire cesser le
détournement des procédures d'asile
quand les deuxièmes et 3e nationalité
par le nombre sont les Albanais et les
Géorgiens pays considèrent comme sûr
entre guillemets c'est le signe que là
aussi les mafia et les passeurs ont mis
la main sur le système
mais l'essentiel est ailleurs
le président de la République a
parfaitement compris mais le sujet est
tellement inflammable qu'il a dû
l'aborder comme disait Nietzsche avec
des pattes de Colombes
il l'appelle l'insécurité culturelle en
langage direct ça veut dire la crise de
l'intégration
au début des années 80 sont apparues
deux mouvements de jeunes antiracistes
leur but était les mêmes mais les
méthodes les opposées la première France
plus dareskidamani avait pour mot
d'ordre l'intégration républicaine son
slogan nous voulons le droit à la
vraisemblance à la vraisemblance
la seconde elle serait racisme est
proposée le multiculturalisme abreuver
de subventions sur médiatisée par tous
les relais du Jack languisme triomphan
elle fit une entrée fracassante dans le
paysage politique ou intellectuel France
plus privé de tout moyen disparu au
début des années 2000 un nouveau
président des SOS Racisme malekbouti
homme de gauche responsable propose un
virage à 180 degrés s'oppose
radicalement à ce qui était devenu le
politiquement correct multiculturel
condamne le différentialisme et fait
l'éloge de l'intégration républicaine
mais le mal était fait et malekbouti
sera rapidement congédié le victimisme
et le dolorisme sont devenus l'alpha et
l'oméga du discours d'une certaine
intelligenceia sur l'immigration un
discours qui aboutit au prétexte
d'atténuer le déracinement des immigrés
à les laisser à la discrétion de leur
communauté un discours qui au nom de la
tolérance renonce à les protéger contre
les abus de la tradition dont il relève
c'est ainsi que la France est devenue un
pays au monde chaque jour un peu plus le
communautarisme et les discours
anachroniques de l'indigénisme de la
racisation ou de l'islamo-gauchisme
le défi de l'intégration est immense
comme l'indique les sondages récents
selon lesquels 27% des musulmans pensent
que la charia est supérieure aux lois de
la République française mais ce chiffre
montre aussi que la grande majorité
d'entre eux pensent le contraire et les
très nombreux exemples chez les enfants
et les petits-enfants d'immigrés ne
parcours scolaires et professionnels
réussis chacun d'entre nous on connaît
autour de lui apporte un démenti aux
victimes qui explique l'échec de
l'intégration par les obstacles
rencontrés
voilà les défis qui vous attendent
monsieur le Premier ministre et l'on ne
peut que vous souhaitez de les relever
parce que si au bout de 40 ans vous
échouillez à votre tour alors demain ce
pourrait bien être rhinocéros à la vue
basse que les Français s'en remettent
pour les régler
une dernière question enfin les vagues
précédentes d'immigration du début du
20e siècle concernait des arrivants aux
cultures proches des nôtres mais s'ils
ont été à l'époque assimilés rapidement
c'est aussi parce que la France était
sûr de son modèle républicain de sa
conception de la laïcité de sa façon de
vivre ensemble et de sa place dans le
monde le plus grand défi aujourd'hui
n'est-il pas de réussir l'intégration
dans un pays qui voit ses valeurs
s'estomper comme s'effacent peu à peu à
la surface de la mer un visage de sable
le plus grand défi n'est-il pas celui de
convaincre français et comme immigré que
ces valeurs ne sont pas seulement celles
du passé mais aussi celle de l'avenir
cette question n'est pas posée qu'à vous
Monsieur le Premier Ministre elle est
posée à chacun d'entre nous elle est
posée à notre démocratie
si monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est Philippe bonnecarère pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste et il a
10 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur Premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues
que faire comment convaincre nos
concitoyens que notre pays est apte et a
toujours la volonté d'appliquer les
règles qu'il a défini notre groupe
écarte tout déni et se veut force de
proposition pour combattre le sentiment
d'impuissance de l'État en matière de
droit des idées de migration sujet qui
touche à l'essentiel à la souveraineté
et donc à l'état à la citoyenneté comme
à l'identité et par conséquent à la
nation nous refusons l'alternative qui
voudrait que pour les uns l'immigration
soit une chance pour la France et pour
les autres une menace ou une invasion
notre ligne directrice sera considérée
que la modération des idées n'écarte pas
la fermeté de l'action et qu'en
particulier en matière de droit des îles
un nom doit être non un oui doit être un
oui
autorisez-moi dans cet exercice
contraint à me concentrer sur nos
propositions notre première proposition
porte sur la construction d'un droit
européen de l'asile convergent vous y
travaillez monsieur Premier ministre et
vous nous l'avez dit entre le niveau le
plus bas d'harmonisation un soutien de
logistique financier technique par le
Bureau Européen d'appui et le niveau le
plus haut une harmonisation totale avec
une agence européenne de l'asile et un
droit à 100% européen en l'état un vœu
pieux nous suggérons deux solutions la
première qui a notre préférence serait
une coopération dites renforcée avec 9
pays au minimum une sorte de Premier
Cercle du droit d'asile juridiquement
possible pour moi Schengen a bien été
intégré aux articles 77 à 80 au TF1 est
annexé d'ailleurs au traité d'Amsterdam
avec des référentiels communs et une
reconnaissance mutuelle des décisions
prises sur les demandes des îles elle
permettrait à ceux qui veulent avancer
de le faire une solution plus modeste
serait travaillée à la convergence par
la technique par des définitions
communes des critères des îles ou encore
par des référentiels partagés sur les
niveaux de risque dans les pays
d'origine l'élaboration des référentiels
pourraient être confiées à un organisme
européen de l'asile et permettrait de
converger à minima vers une culture
commune de la pratique du roi des îles
en résumé la convergence faute
d'unification nous suggérons aussi un
travail particulier avec nos amis
allemands ils ont accueilli un million
600 000 étrangers dans la période
récente mais en ont débuté 700 000 je
valais très vite l'article 16A de la loi
fondamentale allemande garantie aux
personnes politiquesment persécutés un
droit individuel des îles l'article
16a22 interdit aux personnes provenant
d'un pays tiercieux n'appartenant pas
l'Union européenne de faire appel de la
loi fondamentale mais dans une décision
du 14 mai 1996 la Cour constitutionnelle
fédérale a élargi considérablement les
notion de pays tiersur en énonçant que
quiconque arrive d'un pays qui assure
n'a pas besoin de la protection car il
aurait pu trouver une protection contre
les versions les persécutions politiques
dans le troisième étage exactement ce
qui n'est pas permis dans notre droit
constitutionnel nous avons en bref
besoin que les cours constitutionnels
françaises et allemandes essaient de
rapprocher leur point de vue par exemple
dans le travail réalisé au sein de la
Conférence européenne des cours
constitutionnels proposition de la
renégociation de l'espace Schengen vous
y travaillez aussi je voudrais formuler
deux suggestions donner plus de moyens
l'agence Frontex et pertinent mais à la
condition qu'elle est une politique
migratoire appliquée la définition de la
mission doit être préalable au
renforcement de l'outil seconde
suggestion
l'interopérabilité des systèmes
d'information rien n'est réglé en cette
matière je vous donnerai pas le détail
des systèmes ce serait trop long mais
disons pour simplifier que le caractère
essentiel de ce travail
d'interopérabilité couplé à une histoire
informatique française qui a pu avoir
ses défaillances me conduit à vous
suggérer une maîtrise d'ouvrages
particulièrement robuste dédié à cette
mission sur un autre plan nous ne
serions pas opposés aux principes de
hotspot dans le cadre d'une révision du
paquet du loisirs proposition 3 chers
collègues réformer et simplifier le
droit de l'éloignement avec 9 régimes le
droit de l'éloignement est complexe
mobilise beaucoup de moyens et
curieusement ça refonte n'avait pas été
intégré au texte de 2018 alors que le ne
poserait pas de problème constitutionnel
nous saluons la mission monsieur Premier
ministre que vous nez de confier au
Conseil d'État afin de proposer des
solutions de simplification nous sommes
ouverts à l'idée déjà débattue au Sénat
suivant laquelle le rejet de la demande
d'asile par la Cour nationale de droit
d'asile vaudrait au qtf à la manière de
la force et victoire attachée à tout
jugement civil ceci me semblerait plus
difficile à envisager pour les deux
décisions non judiciaires de l'offre
proposition 4 la non coopération des
pays d'origine pose un problème majeur
et la politique de réciprocité via les
conditions d'octroi des visas et limites
cette question peut être traitée sous
forme bilatérale l'Espagne fait mieux
que nous par exemple avec le Maroc ou un
autre sens au niveau européen en
s'appuyant sur la conditionnalité des
aides au développement cette
conditionnalité serait efficace si elle
était couplée à haut niveau d'ambition
sur le plan du développement à l'égard
du Maghreb ou de l'Afrique ceci a été
évoqué bien sûr dans les présentations
ministérielles tout à l'heure ce que
j'appellerai une sorte de route de la
soie à l'européenne proposition 5 sur la
question des
notre groupe y est plutôt favorable même
si nous en connaissons depuis la mission
menée par Pierre Mazeau à l'initiative
du président Sarkozy le caractère assez
limité puisque les cotons seraient
opposables ni aux demandeurs d'asile ni
aux demandeurs au gros groupement
familial nous serions à minima favorable
à l'idée d'un des manuels devant le
Parlement avec des orientations voir des
objectifs chiffrés dans l'administration
pourrait rendre compte en compte non
réalisation nous sommes aussi ouvert à
l'idée d'un statut de migrants
temporaire avec permis de séjour et de
travail à la manière d'une Green Card
européenne ce qui est assez proche de
l'autorisation temporaire pour des
métiers en tension que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure monsieur bromistre
proposition 6 sur la meule regroupement
familial la naturalisation nous sommes
sur des symboles politiques qui relèvent
largement de principes constitutionnels
notre groupe est favorable à une analyse
ciblée des conditions de résidence de
ressources
d'intensité des bien familiaux ou encore
du des durées sans remettre en cause les
principes proposition 7 nous souhaitons
la simplification des régimes
d'hébergement à ce jour existent les
cadas les CPH les UDA les CAES les CAO
les CHU m le tout sous l'égide des
Pradas avec des coups différents des
prestations différentes une
rationalisation de l'hébergement nous
semble indispensables Proposition 8
comment améliorer l'intégration alors
nous reconnaissons le travail réalisé
pour améliorer la formation aux Français
l'intégration professionnelle avec le
plan investissement et compétences et
toutes les pistes qui nous ont été
présentées tout à l'heure nous formulons
deux suggestions la première concerne le
fait travailler beaucoup plus en local
sur l'intégration et pourraient par
exemple prendre la forme de contrats
locaux d'intégration républicaine dont
il m'a semblé trouvé la trace dans
l'intervention de Monsieur min à
l'intérieur tout à l'heure l'autre piste
concerne la question du travail un
demandeur d'asile ne peut envisager de
travailler en vente délai de six mois
vous savez que c'était avant 9 mois nous
serions prêts à examiner la banque dont
pure et simple de ce délai et pensons en
effet qu'il a finalement plus
d'inconvénient que davantage quel
intérêt à priser les demandeurs d'asile
de revenus possibles de la possibilité
d'une certaine manière de faire leur
preuve n'est-il pas préférable de sortir
de l'hypocrisie et de légaliser ce
travail notre neuvième et dernière
proposition concerne l'exigence de
globalité ou de transversalité que nous
parlions d'interopérabilité de
conditionnalités de situations des
mineurs d'un accompagnés que j'aurais dû
développer nous faisons face aux
éternels difficultés françaises des
silos de décision avec des sujets qui
appartiennent
Premier ministre au seul ministère de
l'Intérieur je m'excuse monsieur
ministre au seul ministre des Affaires
étrangères au seul ministre de la
justice etc notre groupe insiste sur la
nécessaire prise en charge transversale
de la question du droit des îles et des
migrations un peu à la matière à la
manière de ce qui est fait pour les
questions européennes qui elles aussi
par définition sont transversales avec
le SVL que proposons nous en conclusion
chers collègues de recentrer et
d'harmoniser le droit d'asile pour mieux
le préserver de réguler les migrations à
la mesure de notre capacité
d'intégration et Monsieur le Premier
Ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues notre groupe
est disponible pour continuer à y
travailler
merci
la parole est maintenant pour le
président Bruno Retailleau
et il dispose de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre madame monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
un débat sans vote Monsieur le Premier
Ministre cela nous laisse sans voix ou
presque
je sais que c'est une commande du
président de la République et vous
pourrez considérer que parfois la
complexité de la pensée présidentielle
nous laisse dans une certaine perplexité
perplexité d'abord parce que mes chers
collègues veulent tout juste un an que
la loi asile immigration a été
promulguée vous aviez qualifié ce texte
monsieur ministre de texte solide
à tel point solide qu'un an après il
faut le consolider
d'une solidité telle que le Président de
la République lors de la conférence des
ambassadeurs je crois que vous y étiez à
dû reconnaître un échec nous sommes
devenus la France le pays de rebond le
premier pays de rebond en Europe pour
les déboutés du droit d'asile 22% de
plus en Allemagne près de 17% de moins
en Europe ou à 10% et Amélie de
Montchalin nous a illustré superbement
tout à l'heure le ciseau qui s'est
ouvert entre le flux européen qui baisse
le flux français qui augmente voilà ce
débat finalement c'est en quelque sorte
la reconnaissance d'un échec
permettez-moi de vous le dire même si je
sais très bien il se serait injuste de
vous rendre coupable de tous les échecs
en matière de politique maigratoire mais
en politique on est toujours comptable
de ses choix de ses décisions et lorsque
pendant le texte qui était apprenant
défendu à l'époque par François Noël
buffet rapporteur par notre collègue
karucci vous avez d'un revers de main
systématiquement mais systématiquement
refuser toutes les propositions du Sénat
il y a un problème refuse sur
l'augmentation des moyens consacrés au
centre de rétention ou plus exactement
aussi à l'expulsion refus pour les
plafonds fixés annuellement
démocratiquement par le Parlement refus
pour le resserrement du regroupement
familial vous avez fait pire puisque
vous avez ouvert le regroupement
familial au moment où tous les pays et
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure je parle
pas de l'Italie de Salvini je parle de
la Suède je parle de l'Allemagne
resserrait leur groupement familial
quant à la me mes chers collègues avec
une régularité métronomique tous les ans
nous votons sa transformation en aide
médicale d'urgence avec un panier
resserré et avec la même régularité
métronomique votre gouvernement s'y
oppose alors
vous avez dit non pour la transformation
de la me j'ai compris que le Président
de la République avait dit plutôt oui et
j'ai entendu depuis madame Busin dire
plutôt non donc aujourd'hui c'est ni oui
ni non bien au contraire on ne sait plus
où on en est en réalité je pense que
vous n'avez pas la majorité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pour une politique de
fermeté la réalité elle est là vous
n'êtes pas dans une logique de rupture
en matière de politique migratoire vous
êtes dans une logique de posture de
faux-semblants comme souvent sur des
sujets pourtant importants pas toujours
mais souvent vous semblez faire mais
vous faites semblant or sur ce sujet là
particulièrement l'immigration
ne peut pas se laisser accommoder de
faux-semblants parce que c'est un sujet
explosif
démographiquement explosif oui mille
fois oui
les chocs migratoires que nous avons
connu il y a deux ans il y a trois ans
ne sont que des prémices de ce
coustelluriques beaucoup plus violente
lorsque le rapport a perdu la fin du
siècle 100 millions d'habitants que
l'Afrique en aura gagné près de 2
milliards bien évidemment Auguste conte
disait que la démographie celle destin
et bien l'honneur de la politique c'est
non pas seulement de subir les effets
les conséquences et d'essayer de les
traiter de courir après mais traiter les
causes et si on ne veut pas nous que
notre destin soit réduit précisément à
la fatalité où est notre politique
familiale où est-elle elle est
détricotée vous le savez parfaitement
vous avez de ce point de vue là suivi
avec une forme de Constance le
détricotage commencez par vos
prédécesseurs alors bien sûr explosive
démographiquement explosif politiquement
mes chers collègues parce que certains
ont utilisé
le migrant l'immigration comme un sujet
politique
certains ont utilisé la figure du
migrant comme la figure idéale du bouc
émissaire d'autres à l'inverse comme la
figure de substitution de remplacement
d'un prolétaire devenu introuvable et
d'autres encore ont vu dans chaque homme
un individu interchangeable et dans
chaque migrant une ressource économique
bon marché déplaçable et corvéable à
merci et le sujet est devenu explosif il
est aussi devenu explosif
démocratiquement ça n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est un philosophe que je respecte
énormément martial gaucher il a très
bien expliqué c'est sans doute
l'immigration de masse le phénomène
social qui a le plus transformé le plus
bouleversé nos sociétés et c'est
pourtant ce phénomène qui était laissé
totalement à l'abri à l'écart de la
délibération du peuple français sans
doute parce que le peuple pense mal sans
doute parce que son opinion est peu
convenable sur leur sujet peut-être dans
son dernier livre Christophe guéduit ne
se sahiti site ses grandes enquêtes
international 25 pays d'Ipsos qui
demande régulièrement dans 25 de ces
pays ce que l'on peut penser de l'impact
positif ou non de l'immigration sur la
société 20% seulement des peuples et des
sondés pensent qu'il y a un impact
positif et en français moins mes chers
on peut se cacher bien sûr derrière
notre petit doigt et je dois finalement
dire que je suis assez d'accord avec le
constat du président de la République
lorsqu'il partent dans bourgeoisement
lorsqu'ils parlent dans bourgeoisement
et de ce risque d'une société française
coupée en deux avec des catégories
supérieures éduqués qui ont les moyens
de se protéger des effets de
l'immigration par des stratégies
d'évitement de résidentiel par des
stratégies d'évitement scolaires et
d'autres catégories plus populaires qui
n'ont pas les moyens de financer des
frontières invisibles pour se protéger
le résultat il est là et mes chers
collègues craignons craignant ce moment
qui parce que les gens d'en haut le
monde en haut ne pourra pas dire
éternellement que ceux d'en bas se
trompent que leur diagnostic et
politiquement incorrectes et qu'il faut
de toute urgence les rééduquer ça n'est
pas possible ça n'est plus possible je
pense que au contraire il faut réagir
c'est la raison pour laquelle sur la
question des plafonds votés par le
Parlement annuellement nous l'avions
proposé avec François à Noël buffet je
pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important j'ai vu d'ailleurs j'ai lu
dans la presse que vous pensiez en tout
cas que vous n'aviez pas peur d'y
réfléchir fichtre c'est décoiffant vous
n'avez pas peur de réfléchir à cette
idée là il faut la faire parce que on
doit réintroduire le sujet de la
migration de ses effets dans le débat
démocratique au Parlement parce que s'il
n'est pas ici au départ dans le
Parlement il est dans la rue il est
ailleurs il est instrumentalisé bien
évidemment et nous vous proposons la
démagogie me sers collègues la
démographie elle cessera quand la
démocratie reprendra ses droits de même
que la démagogie cessera quand on mettra
fin à l'impuissance publique au fiasco
de la politique migratoire française
pas depuis hier certes mais il faut en
parler droit dans les yeux et de ce
point de vue là on doit se poser la
question qu'est-ce qu'une politique
migratoire
qu'est-ce que la bonne politique
migratoire pas une politique qui se
réduirait uniquement à ses effets
humanitaires un état un gouvernement ça
n'est pas une ONG c'est pas une église
non plus
ça ne peut pas être seulement répondre à
la question auquel j'espère on sera tous
d'accord est-ce qu'on va laisser se
noyer
c'est pauvres gens femmes enfants
vieillard au milieu de la médaille non
la politique encore une fois ça n'est
pas de réparer les effets
seulement c'est d'aller aux causes
directement et traiter les causes c'est
évidemment les traiter en amont le plus
possible et je vous accorde un
satisfaite lorsque vous avez
indiqué que vous étiez prêt à lier à
corréler une politique humanitaire de
développement de l'Afrique avec une
politique par ces pays-là politique pays
source notamment de maîtrise de leur
propre imagination il faut bien sûr un
plan massif de développement de
l'Afrique évidemment et avec le
collectivité de regard à regard de
territoire à territoire c'est plus
efficace je crois mais il faut aussi que
nous exigeons une conditionnalité par
exemple en matière de laisser passer
consulaire
pas de ces classes consulaires pas
d'aide au développement les choses
doivent être claires qu'est-ce qu'une
politique migratoire trois choses mes
chers collègues des frontières
les frontières maîtrisées des lois
appliquées quand on a moins de 10% des
déboutés du droit d'asile qui sont
reconduits qui sont expulsés peut-on
dire que l'alouette appliquée elle ne
l'est pas bien sûr et puis ce sont des
valeurs des valeurs républicaines j'y
reviendrai à la fin de mon propos
d'abord des frontières je pense qu'on a
besoin de trois contrôles d'un triple
contrôle le premier contrôle il est dans
la profondeur de ces territoires payent
transit pays d'origine je viens d'en
parler mais on doit pouvoir généraliser
les hotspots plus le contrôle est loin
et à l'extérieur et moi on expose ces
gens là justement au péril de leur vie à
être finalement une forme de marchandise
humaine pour les trafiquants les
nouveaux esclavagistes étant modernes
ensuite un autre contrôle c'est l'Europe
l'Europe bien sûr
l'Europe avec Frontex et je considère
que nous aurons dans quelques semaines
chers madame la preuve oui ou non si la
nouvelle Commission va mettre à
disposition de Frontex les vrais moyens
vous devez vous battre sur ce sujet là
c'est très concret de même que casser
les filières c'est assumer des
opérations policières et militaires
personne ne sait ici sans doute ou très
peu qu'en juin 2015 l'opération Sofia a
été déclenchée par l'Union
voter par le Conseil
elle disposait de quatre phases pour
détruire y compris des moyens militaires
et y compris jusqu'au plage des pays de
transit les infrastructures de ces
esclavagistes dont je parlais il y a
quelques instants elle a dû s'arrêter
mais il faut la reprendre et si besoin
d'ailleurs parce que j'ignore pas les
problèmes notamment internationaux on
devrait pouvoir saisir le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU pour avoir une
résolution en matière de lutte contre
toutes ces filières là et puis bien sûr
troisième niveau de protection pour nos
frontières nos propres frontières
Schengen autorise en situation de crise
pour des durées déterminer le maintien
le rétablissement des frontières on vit
sur ce régime là pérennisons-le parce
que trois protections c'est mieux que
une seule protection des
frontière bien sûr maîtrisée ensuite des
lois des loises appliquées et il faut
revoir de toute urgence Monsieur le
Premier Ministre notre arsenal
législative bien sûr il faut l'appliquer
mais il faut le revoir parce que nous
sommes désormais en décalage total avec
les grands partenaires européens vous
avez lu j'en suis sûr le petit ouvrage
de Didier leski il dit tout il dit tout
il est Parfaitement Connaisseur il est
le patron de l'Office français de
l'immigration et de l'intégration et il
vous donnera de nombreux exemples de la
Suède à l'Allemagne en passant par
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres pays qui ont
fait le job et nous on l'a pas fait
preuve que lorsque vous dites il faut
que l'Europe il faut que bien sûr moi
aussi je suis d'accord pour qu'il y ait
des formes d'harmonisation mais pourquoi
par exemple sur le regroupement familial
vous dites ah non pas de quota sauf que
l'accord de la grosse coalition l'accord
de gouvernement du 1er août 2018 c'est
1000 regroupements 1000 pour les
réfugiés et pas plus donc l'Allemagne ne
peut pourquoi nous ne nous pouvons pas
la aide à impromper une autre voix etc
etc notre impuissance c'est notre propre
faute ne nous déchargeons pas mes chers
collègues sur l'Europe c'est parce que
nous n'avons pas le courage de
transformer nos propres règles de les
adapter le regroupement familial bien
sûr le droit d'asile encore mais aussi
les séjours pour soins il y a des
exemples qui sont extraordinaires ici tu
es à la Fondation service politique vous
pouvez vous le procurer c'était en
octobre 2018 il y a des exemples qui
sont parlants heureusement d'ailleurs
que les Français ne savent pas parce que
ça les révolterait évidemment parce
qu'il y verra une sorte de rupture au
principe d'égalité donc il faut des lois
les appliquer et nous les avions proposé
je ne ferai pas la
la liste de toutes nos propositions
simplement en matière d'expulsion de ces
étrangers qui commettent des actes de
délinquance grave et qui sont condamnés
bien sûr il faut une peine
complémentaire bien sûr un certain
nombre aussi de moyens pour les
expulsions bien sûr nous les avons fait
ces propositions nous les tenons à votre
disposition nous sommes prêts allez
revoter dès que vous voudrez aider
d'ailleurs le pdfss ou le PDF et puis je
terminerai par le plus important les
valeurs républicaines parce
qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment des Français
c'est que une immigration qui n'est pas
maîtrisée est en train de provoquer une
insécurité culturelle parce que elle
ébranle notre modèle culturel il y a
quinze jours ou trois semaines cette
grande enquête annuelle fracture
française
64%, 64% des Français qui trouvent que
on ne se sent plus chez soi comme avant
on peut le déplorer on peut s'indigner
mais c'est un chiffre c'est un chiffre
et il nous appelle à une rédac une
réaction le problème
c'est qu'on a renoncé assimilé et nous
échouons à intégrer il est là le souci
intégré à assimilé dans une logique
républicaine de la citoyenneté avec les
droits et les devoirs assumés par les
uns et par les autres évidemment c'est
un échec et c'est que chaque là nous
devons là aussi le regarder en face
alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre de ce
point de vue là nous devons là aussi
évidemment agir sans que notre bras
puisse si j'ose dire trembler il y a
deux modèles il y a un premier modèle
qui est un modèle du multiculturalisme
c'est un modèle centrifuge qui divise
qui dresse les communautés les unes
contre les autres il y a le modèle
républicain la citoyenneté et bien je
pense que ça nécessite évidemment que
nous relions ce défi parce que nous
avons trop reculé nous avons trop reculé
sur la laïcité est-ce que par exemple
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
renoncé à modifier la loi 1905 nous
devons tenir coûte que coûte et on voit
bien que l'attentat la préfecture de
police nous appelle à cette résistance
chaque jour nous devons aussi reculer
nous avons reculé sur l'assimilation
regardons les choses en face quand il
s'agit de valeur républicaines l'égalité
la liberté la laïcité la fraternité
civique
on les assimile on les intègre pas comme
disait Dominique Snapper que personne
accusera l'extrémisme on a oublié que
certes l'assimilation c'était parfois
une contrainte mais c'était aussi une
promesse généreuse une promesse de
devenir complètement français alors mes
chers collègues relevons la tête soyons
fiers de nos convictions ne cédons rien
parce que les Français nous le
reprocherons oui la générosité fait
partie du patrimoine de l'héritage
français mais faut-il encore avoir
quelque chose à donner une histoire à
offrir des valeurs communes à partager
un pays à aimer rien ne serait pire
parce que ce serait inhumain qu'un monde
sans frontière un monde justement ou de
déracinement l'affrontement on
dresserait les populations les unes
contre les autres alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre si vous souhaitez que
ce débat ne soit pas simplement une
habileté politique agissez prenez des
décisions d'autres pays européens l'ont
fait vous pouvez le faire parce que
sinon vous ajouterez énormément de
défiance à la désespérance merci de
votre attention merci
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
après l'intervention
des orateurs des groupes la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
pas de consensus peut-être
mais des convergences
sans surprise
je constate et nous l'avons tous entendu
que la question du la définition de la
mise en œuvre d'une politique migratoire
dans notre pays n'appelle pas dans cette
émission comme d'ailleurs dans celui de
l'Assemblée nationale un consensus et au
fond personne n'en est complètement
surpris entre les positions qui ont été
développées par l'âme la présidente
assassy et les positions développées par
Monsieur le Sénateur ravier
il n'y a pas de consensus et avec les
autres voilà il y a pas de consensus ça
fait c'est un constat j'ai été il y a
pas de consensus j'ai même été surpris
monsieur le Président mais peut-être
malentendu d'entendre sur le sénateur
ravier évoqué
dans une série qui se voulait cohérente
Charlemagne Charles Martel et Charles
Quint puisque dans
ma mémoire Charles Quint avait été
plutôt caractérisée par un conflit avec
avec la France et je me souviens du
reste enfin je me souviens je n'y étais
pas mais que le roi François 1er avait
pour faire contrepoids à l'influence de
Charles Quint plutôt été chercher ses
alliances à l'Est voire même du côté de
ce qui est aujourd'hui la Turquie ceux
qui montrent que le sujet et finalement
plus complexe qu'il est parfois présenté
mais pour revenir à l'essentiel car au
fond là n'est pas l'essentiel pour
revenir à l'essentiel pas consensus mais
un certain nombre d'éléments qui sont
intéressants et qui je crois peuvent
peut-être relever de la convergence
d'abord je voudrais et le faire très
très sincèrement remercier l'ensemble
des orateurs pour la qualité des propos
qui ont été tenus je trouve que d'une
certaine façon
c'est probablement la meilleure façon de
démontrer que ce débat est utile les
propositions qui ont évoquées les
positions qui ont été tenues encore une
fois elles appellent les commentaires on
peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord mais
je veux dire combien j'ai
aimé entendre ces propositions et et et
essayer d'y répondre maintenant
quelques-uns ont évoqué l'opportunité du
débat la question de l'opportunité du
débat
je crois que ce débat est
utile et opportun je l'ai dit en
introduction et je le redis ici au
moment de conclure pas seulement car il
m'aura donné l'occasion rare de voir le
président malgré cité Dalida
mais parce que
parce que sur ce débat difficile
et utile
et bien bien évidemment sur ce débat
difficile et utile on a dit beaucoup de
choses et bien évidemment ça n'est pas
la première fois ni au Sénat ni à
l'Assemblée nationale que l'on parle des
sujets d'immigration
c'est pas parce qu'on en a déjà parlé
que ce débat serait inutile au contraire
ce sujet de l'immigration est au cœur
d'interrogations françaises est au cœur
d'un processus législatif
depuis longtemps continue à interroger
les Français continuent à structurer
parfois le débat public et je trouve
qu'il serait extravagant que nous ne
l'évoquions pas ici et je veux dire une
fois encore l'intérêt qu'il peut y avoir
évoqué ce sujet non pas sur un texte non
pas sur une mesure mais bien dans la
totalité dans la globalité de ce qu'il
représente s'agissant d'instruments
publics ou de problématiques politiques
est-ce que est-ce que de ce de ces
interventions et je peux retirer
quelques convergences d'abord une
certitude
beaucoup d'entre nous avons évoqué le
sujet en termes de son impact sur la
citoyenneté c'est à dire sur le lien
fondamental qui régit nos compatriotes
avec la nation
beaucoup aussi ont dit leur volonté je
vais le dire de façon un peu général de
conjuguer
un humanisme une fidélité à nos valeurs
une ouverture et un réalisme une fermeté
ou la capacité à maîtriser des
phénomènes migratoires les termes sont
différents mais il y a bien quand même
me semble-t-il et ensuite on peut
débattre des mesures mais il y a bien me
semble-t-il la volonté
très largement partagée dans cette
émission de concevoir la politique
migratoire de la France entre ces deux
points de tension que sont la nécessaire
fidélité
aux valeurs auxquelles nous croyons qui
sont que la France est un pays qui est
ouverte qui sont que la France est un
pays qui croit fondamentalement au droit
d'asile par exemple et une certaine
forme de fermeté c'est à dire la
capacité que nous avons à choisir et à
ne pas se voir imposer qui a le droit de
résider sur le territoire national et de
cette tension qui est difficile à mettre
en œuvre
mais qui est rappelé sur tous les bancs
je veux voir une forme de convergence
qui est plutôt réjouissante alors sur
les points de convergence plus
explicites ou plus exactement plus
prometteur encore
le sénateur Richard et le sénateur
bunker ont dit combien aussi mais
le président Ruquier l'avait dit
également combien
la nécessaire le nécessaire
rapprochement
des positions nationales en Europe
ou la nécessaire construction d'une
politique européenne était indispensable
s'agissant du contrôle des flux
migratoires et de l'harmonisation de la
fluidification de l'efficacité d'une
véritable politique d'asile
nous le sentons tous
beaucoup d'entre vous ont évoqué la
question de l'asile comme une question
centrale qui se posait à la question à
la politique migratoire et en matière
d'asile nous devons
utiliser les pistes qui sont à notre
disposition prendre des initiatives
diplomatiques en Europe pour rapprocher
les conditions d'accueil
harmoniser peut-être en tout cas
coordonnée les procédures d'instruction
entre les pays utilisez le cas échéance
je ne crois pas que ce serait des choix
et je ne crois pas que ce serait
incompatible avec notre conception du
droit d'asile utilisez les instructions
réalisées par d'autres pays pour pouvoir
le cas échéant prendre des décisions qui
nous reviennent bref construire un
mécanisme des mécanismes des politiques
qui permettent
d'harmoniser ces bien le c'est bien le
mot l'approche européenne en matière de
droit d'asile et en matière de
traitement des demandes d'asile et
d'accueil de ceux qui font la demande
d'asile
ça me semble un point de convergence
très fort et une nécessité pour nous
tous la deuxième question qui est posée
et qui est délicate et qui a été posée
en des termes très clair par plusieurs
d'entre vous c'est la question
de l'intégration
la question qui n'est pas simplement
l'accueil matériel au moment où
l'étranger qui a le droit de rester fait
sa demande et ensuite est admis à rester
au séjour mais la question du creuset
culturel
du partage effectif des valeurs qui sont
au cœur de notre société un mot parce
que ça a été évoqué je crois par le
président malgré cette intégration des
étrangers en France elle a toujours été
difficile
on dit souvent
en se retournant dans le passé quelle
était plus simple lorsqu'il s'agissait
d'une immigration
essentiellement
d'une géographie plus proche de la
France
parfois plus proche de nos convictions
religieuses ou identiques dans ces
convictions religieuses il est vrai tout
cela est vrai mais cette intégration a
toujours été difficile le modèle
républicain entre guillemets pardon
n'était pas stabilisé au moment où les
Italiens ou n'étaient pas si stabilisés
au moment où les Italiens ou les
Polonais sont arrivés en masse dans
notre pays et leur conception de la
pratique religieuse était bien
différente souvent de celle qui
prévalaient en France et ces difficultés
ont donné lieu à des violences à des
discriminations à des phénomènes de
réaction dont nous savons parce que nous
les avons lus à défaut de les connaître
qu'ils étaient également difficiles
autrement dit cette question de
l'intégration elle se pose dans des
termes qui sont plus compliqués
aujourd'hui que dans le passé sans aucun
doute mais ça n'a jamais été facile ça
n'a jamais été simple et c'est pourtant
le combat qui est devant nous si nous
voulons faire prévaloir à la fois notre
capacité d'accueil et le tissu et la
solidité de notre modèle social alors
quels sont les suites à donner à ce
débat parce que au fond c'est
l'essentiel auquel je veux venir il ne
s'agit pas de répondre à l'ensemble des
questions techniques ou précises qui ont
été posées je voudrais dire que la suite
au fond elle relève de trois aspects
d'abord d'abord d'une logique de travail
et pas de posture et je veux le dire au
président Retailleau la posture c'est
d'une certaine façon toujours la
position de l'autre
il ne s'agit pas de posture en la
matière et il ne s'agit en rien de
posture en la matière il s'agit
d'essayer de trouver des instruments
efficaces une approche équilibrée
certains la trouveront déséquilibrer
mais une approche que je équilibré sur
ces sujets en prenant en compte des
contraintes qui sont multiples des
contraintes qui sont juridiques et dont
il faut parfois essayer de se défaire en
prenant en compte le fait que nous
vivons parfois avec des contraintes
juridiques qui viennent d'il y a
longtemps dans le passé prises parfois
dans des circonstances différentes mais
qui reste très strictes et très fort je
l'ai dit à l'Assemblée nationale je le
redis
la décision de supprimer l'obligation de
visa pour un certain nombre de pays de
l'Union enfin pas de l'Union européenne
pardon mais qui aspire à rentrer dans
l'Union européenne vous allez citer
l'Albanie on pourrait citer la Géorgie
également cette décision vous le savez
bien monsieur le Président d'Auteuil n'a
pas été prise par ce gouvernement et
peut-être quand elle a été prise
la-t-elle été dans un contexte bien
différent enfin pas si différent car
elle date en la matière s'agissant
l'Albanie de 2010 mais aujourd'hui elle
se traduit effectivement par une demande
par une demande considérable
d'asile de la part de ressortissants
d'un État dont nous considérons qu'il
est sûr et dont certains y compris nos
partenaires européens veulent pouvoir
commencer avec lui des négociations pour
l'admission dans l'Union européenne je
dois dire monsieur le Président
Retailleau et je le dis très
tranquillement
que j'ai du mal à saisir comment alors
que nous avons une donnée le très grand
nombre de demandes d'asile émanant de
ressortissants albanais on pourrait dire
que par définition le pays en question
est au niveau de préparation qui
justifie le début des négociations
avec l'Union européenne pour une
éventuelle admission de deux choses
l'une s'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes d'asile c'est qu'il y a un
sujet et si un sujet c'est compliqué de
rentrer dans l'Union européenne et si il
y a pas de sujet pour rentrer dans
l'Union européenne alors dans ce cas là
il devrait pas y avoir de demandes
d'asile
nous voyons donc nous voyons donc qu'il
y a là quelque chose qui ne résulte pas
monsieur le Président Retailleau de
décision qui aurait été prise par ce
gouvernement mais que nous devons gérer
que nous devons regarder en face dont
nous devons quantifier l'importance et
essayer de trouver des solutions
efficaces donc pas de posture mais un
travail un travail sérieux et je
voudrais saluer dans les propositions
qui ont été faites les propositions
formulées par le sénateur bonne carrière
les 10 pistes de travail que vous
évoquez donc beaucoup me conviennent
parfaitement beaucoup me conviennent
parfaitement parce que je crois que
justement elles essaient à cadre
constitutionnel fixé de trouver des
solutions pratiques lesquelles ne sont
pas toujours spectaculaires d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas prétendu qu'elle
pourrait l'être mais qui sont je le
crois efficaces il me paraît que il y a
la des pistes intéressante et le
gouvernement est évidemment prêt et
disposer à travailler sur ces
propositions et sur d'autres je le cite
parce que ça ne peut pas laisser
insensible les sénateurs que vous êtes à
l'Assemblée nationale un député a évoqué
la possibilité de d'améliorer la
communication entre les services de
l'État qui sont compétents en matière de
politique migratoire et les mères
pourquoi parce que nous demandons au
maire de formuler des avis dans un
certain nombre de cas mais que bien
souvent après avoir demandé ses avis le
retour d'information la qualité de
traitement dans la durée n'est pas là je
n'ai pas inventé ces procédures mais je
les ai mis en oeuvre quand j'étais mère
je sais qu'il y a là quelque chose comme
un hiatus nous pouvons peut-être
travailler je dis peut-être parce que je
ne suis pas sûr que nous trouvions la
bonne solution et surtout je ne suis pas
sûr qu'elle soit immédiatement efficace
mais je pense que nous pouvons
travailler pour améliorer le dispositif
et améliorer la qualité de l'information
et du travail entre les collectivités
territoriales puisqu'elles sont appelées
à participer d'une certaine façon à
cette politique migratoire et et l'État
troisième chose
quelles seront les textes ou les
supports des décisions à mettre en
oeuvre nous ne sommes pas venus dans ce
débat annoncé un grand texte général qui
serait le la grande loi ou le grand soir
législatif de la politique migratoire
qui irait depuis je l'ai dit la relation
diplomatique avec les pays d'origine
jusque
au retour vers les pays d'origine ou à
l'intégration ou à la citoyenneté
mais certains textes spécifiques vont
pouvoir porter l'ambition et les
questions que j'évoquais l'année
prochaine le texte sur la loi de
programmation sur l'aide publique au
développement nous permettra
effectivement j'étais sensible
satisfaite qui m'a été adressée nous
permettra effectivement de réfléchir à
la façon
dont nous armes dont nous conjuguons
dont nous conjuguons une politique
migratoire et le développement de l'aide
publique au développement car nous
allons consacrer des ressources
supplémentaires chaque année à cette
aide publique au développement intégrer
cette aide publique développement dans
une logique de
d'accompagnement au développement des
pays d'origine ou peut-être
d'accompagnement des États dans la mise
en place d'instruments qui seront utiles
à ces états et à la France dans le
contrôle des flux je pense par exemple
au disposition d'état civil de
numérisation tout cela évidemment a du
sens et pour être examiné l'année
prochaine au moment de l'examen de cette
loi de programmation pour d'autres
mesures pour d'autres de mesures il y
aura des mesures réglementaires elles
sont de la responsabilité du
gouvernement et une fois que ce débat
aura mûri nous pourrons annoncer les
décisions et les prendre lorsqu'elles
sont de nature réglementaires où elles
pourront s'intégrer dans des textes
législatifs après que bien entendu
l'Assemblée nationale Sénat en auront
discuté de ce point de vue là ce débat
particulier sera je crois nourri par le
débat général que nous venons d'avoir je
voudrais mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le Président je vous
remercier très vivement et très
sincèrement pour la qualité de ce débat
merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
intervention clos notre débat je tiens
vraiment à remercier tous ceux qui sont
intervenus et saluer
l'importante présence des collègues
sénateurs tout au long de l'après-midi
pour débat intéressant nous allons
suspendre notre séance jusqu'à 19h20 il
sera reprise pour permettre monsieur
Lecornu de s'échauffer et voilà pour ce
débat de 2h30 sur la politique
migratoire qui s'est tenue dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat on va revenir sur
les temps forts de ce débat avec Jérôme
du Rhin bonjour sénateur socialiste de
Saône-et-Loire membre de la commission
des lois également sur ce plateau
Sébastien Meurant vous êtes vous
sénateur les républicains du Val-d'Oise
vous êtes également je le précise
rapporteur des crédits immigrations
asile et intégration pour le projet de
loi de finance et également sur ce
plateau et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
Béatrice Giblin vous êtes géographe
directrice de la revue Hérodote une
revue de géographie et de géopolitique
on va discuter tout de suite et bien de
se débat tous ensemble mais d'abord je
vais rejoindre Alice Pardo vous êtes
dans l'hémicycle vous avez suivi pour
nous tous ce débat quels étaient pour
vous et bien les principaux
enseignements alors oui thème le débat
sur l'immigration vient de se terminer
et ce que l'on peut l'en retenir c'est
que comme l'avait prédit Édouard
Philippe dans son discours le sujet
écrivain alors mais peut-être qu'il ne
s'attendait pas à ce qu'il le soit
jusque dans son camp ainsi le sénateur
de la majorité Alain Richard a tenu à
marquer sa distance vis-à-vis de l'une
des grandes orientations de la politique
migratoires présentées par Edouard
Philippe qui a déclaré être ouvert à une
réflexion sur la mise en place de quota
pour l'immigration professionnelle alors
son collègue socialiste Jean-Yves
Lecomte opposé au quota lui aussi
considère qu'une telle mesure ne
servirait à rien du fait du faible
nombre d'immigrés économiques en France
environ 30 000 par an autre mesure
clivante évoquée lors de ce débat l'aide
médicale d'État alors comme le rappelait
la secrétaire d'État auprès de la
ministre de la des solidarités et de la
santé Christelle Dubos un plan de lutte
contre les fraudes à l'AME l'aide
médicale d'État devrait être mise en
place mais la ministre a surtout insisté
sur la nécessité de maintenir cette aide
je cite en tordant le cou aux idées
reçues Agnès Buzin se veut rassurante
mais nous verrons au moment du vote du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale c'est pour sa part
inquiéter la sénatrice communiste Éliane
assassy enfin pour Bruno retaillod
sénateur les républicains l'exécutif
joue à ni oui ni non sur la question de
cette ame enfin donc Édouard Philippe en
réponse au sénateur à sensiblement donc
répéter ce qu'il avait dit à l'Assemblée
nationale et a terminé en disant donc
pas de grands soir législatif mais
seulement quelques textes spécifiques à
venir
merci beaucoup Alice pour ce décryptage
décryptage que nous poursuivons en
plateau d'abord et bien c'était
d'ailleurs le premier point de la
réponse d'Edouard Philippe la question
de l'opportunité du débat d'abord
fallait-il ce débat le gouvernement n'a
cessé de répéter vouloir l'aborder en
conscience en responsabilité car il ne
faut pas le laisser à un seul parti
politique Jérôme Durance que vous êtes
d'accord
une des formules qu'on a l'habitude
d'utiliser quand on commente un texte en
séance ou un travail parlementaire c'est
de dire il y a le contexte il y a le
texte bon là il y a pas de texte donc on
parle dans le vide en plus il y a pas de
vote franchement il y a pas de texte
donc pour vous c'est pas utile ce débat
étrange si si c'est utile politiquement
d'ailleurs le gouvernement si il conduit
ce débat c'est qu'il a une
arrière-pensée il y a un contexte donc
le contexte c'est sans doute de miser
pour le deuxième quinquennat de Monsieur
Macron sur autre chose que sur ces
résultats économiques et sur les données
économiques et sociales et d'ouvrir un
nouveau champ pour essayer de sans doute
conforter une partie de son électorat à
droite voilà moi je trouve que c'est un
mauvais calcul et que c'est très
dangereux est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec Jérôme Durand sur le fait que et
bien ce débat et vous avant tout bien
pour le geste politique qu'il représente
c'est une commande du président de la
République
qu'on annonce ce genre de débat faut
arrêter de dire que l'immigration est un
sujet tabou on en parle extrêmement
régulièrement
qu'est-ce qui serait tabou de quoi ne
parle-t-on pas c'est certainement pas au
fond de ce qu'on suppose comme une vague
migratoire massive ce qui n'est pas le
cas en France je crois qu'il faut le
dire et le redire en simplement en
comparant avec ce qui se passe dans les
États voisins d'une autre donc pour moi
c'est pas du tout nouveau c'est nouveau
dans la forme mais on a toujours parlé
d'immigration depuis très longtemps je
trouve que c'est plutôt agité un chiffon
rouge qui est pas forcément
utile en ce moment voilà on va écouter
les temps forts de ce débat et revenir
justement à l'intervention tout à
l'heure de Bruno Retailleau en le
président du groupe LR au Sénat lui
aussi a dénoncé dans ce débat une
habilité politique on l'écoute en
réalité je pense que
vous n'avez pas la majorité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pour une politique de
fermeté la réalité elle est là vous
n'êtes pas dans une logique de rupture
en matière de politique migratoire vous
êtes dans une logique de posture de
faux-semblants comme souvent sur des
sujets pourtant importants pas toujours
mais souvent vous semblez faire mais
vous faites semblant or sur ce sujet là
particulièrement l'immigration
ne peut pas se laisser accommoder de
faux semblants parce que c'est un sujet
explosif
démographiquement explosif oui mille
fois oui
alors on va justement revenir tout de
même et bien à ce qui a pu dire Édouard
Philippe lors de ce débat comme lundi il
est revenu et bien sur l'idée des quotas
et il a également un petit peu précisé
sa position on l'écoute mieux accueillir
c'est aussi assumer un pilotage par
objectif de l'admission au séjour nous
savons que la logique des quotas ne peut
s'appliquer ni en matière d'asile ni en
matière d'immigration familiale
mais pour attirer les talents qu'il
s'agisse d'étudiants ou de compétences
rares
ou de compétences dont nous avons besoin
on doit pouvoir réfléchir à des
objectifs quantitatifs c'est là notre
cinquième orientation on doit pouvoir
adapter et dynamiser nos procédures
d'immigration professionnelle en
fonction des besoins des secteurs
d'activité on doit pouvoir se fixer des
objectifs en nombre d'étudiants
accueillis en nombre de passeports
allant délivrés ou encore sur la
proportion de l'immigration qualifiée au
sein de l'immigration professionnelle
des propos qui en tout cas un en guerre
inspiré Alain Richard pourtant sénateur
de la majorité présidentielle qui lui
est opposé au quota et surtout parce
qu'il juge que ce n'est pas efficace
écouté
je souhaite marquer une distance
Monsieur le Premier Ministre face à
l'idée de quota d'immigration qui
revient encore
la plus grande part des entrées sur
notre sol vient de processus de
rapprochement familial d'accès aux
études supérieures et d'asile politique
seul les séjours étudiants peuvent faire
l'objet d'une limitation légitime et
c'est déjà fait et aussi l'intimigration
professionnelle qui comme ça a été dit
et le plus la plus faible composante à
peine plus de 10%. on ne fixera pas de
quota ni d'entrée familiale ni le titre
de réfugiés les points noirs de notre
situation sont à trois niveaux le
traitement des demandes d'asile le
mouvement des mineurs isolés et la
coordination européenne insuffisante
dans l'espace de libre circulation
Sébastien meurt qu'est-ce que vous
inspire ce débat au sein de la majorité
sur la question des quotas les quotas
c'est un marqueur important dans une
politique c'est un terme symbolique
important et le fait qu'il soit allé
dans le débat est important aussi je
crois que notre président Bruno
retaillod exprime cela c'est que il y a
pas une unité de vue concernant cette
question c'est lié à la composition de
en marche le nombre de gauche de droite
la question c'est quand même une
question essentielle je suis pas du tout
d'accord puisque nous voyons bien que
l'immigration est un sujet majeur qui
n'est pas traité depuis des années et
aujourd'hui un détournement de nos
procédures notamment concernant l'Asie
concernant également tout ce qui est
étudiant et nos lois sont pas appliquées
quand on prend une obligation qui était
le territoire français aujourd'hui 12
13% des personnes sont effectivement
expulsées quand on a l'année dernière on
accueilli plus de 400 000 personnes par
an il reprenait vous représentez ce que
ça peut parce qu'après ce que ça fait
donc quand on y a quand même on parle de
la question des quotas
je suis pas sûr que cette question est
fondamentale la question c'est de
maîtriser qui rentre de maîtrise
également parce que la question aussi
d'acquisition de la nationalité qui est
lié forcément qui est pas abordé et qui
est nécessaire et on sait très bien les
quotas la question de l'acquisition de
la nationalité
français devait être un préalable mais
il devra aussi parler aujourd'hui le
nombre de personnes qui acquièrent la
nationalité et sous les différentes
formes ça c'est important et on voit
très bien parler du fantasme du
remplacement sur certains territoires il
y a effectivement Chevènement le dit
Hollande dit colon quand il a
démissionné écouter ce qu'il dit en
sortant donc cette question est question
centrale et moi qui travaille sur la
question des finances simplement qui
travaille sur la question des fraudes
notamment la Cour des comptes sur les
retraites par exemple on va parler des
retraites avait pointé en 2017 donc ce
gouvernement était déjà en
responsabilité un chiffre quand même
significatif de 200 millions de
centenaires
par les trois pays essentiellement
l'Algérie le Maroc et le Portugal 200
millions d'euros donc la question de
savoir les quotas la question c'est déjà
d'appliquer la loi
qui n'est pas appliqué et le Premier
ministre le reconnaît et la question
après des quotas c'est une question
Annette qui porterait si on écoute
monsieur Richard sur 30000 personnes
les quotas que la on sait c'est un
signal politique de l'aborder ou pour ce
qui est l'immigrations économiques c'est
vrai c'est exactement 32000 et des
poussières donc c'est donc des quotas
sur 32000 c'est pas très utile ce qui
veut pas moi ça me choque pas à les
limites le Canada fonctionne avec des
quotas depuis très longtemps et
accueille un nombre de gens au combien
plus important que nous avec une
population qui est moitié moins
importante bon donc ça veut dire que
c'est faisable pour moi alors là pour le
coup le quota n'est pas un tabou mais
dans ce que dit à la Richard c'est juste
c'est que ça ne changera rien quand un
certain nombre de perceptions que l'on
peut que peuvent avoir les Français à
tort ou à raison mais vous savez
certaines perceptions même si elles sont
fausses acquiert une réalité par le fait
que les gens sont absolument convaincu
que c'est ça qu'ils vivent et comme vous
l'avez très justement dit monsieur le
sénateur dans certains territoires c'est
tout à fait juste qu'il le perçoivent
comme étant menacé ou qu'il y ait une
sorte de grande vague migratoire alors
que c'est faux répartis à l'ensemble du
territoire national et à l'ensemble de
la population du territoire national le
problème de la vérité sur les chiffres
justement
vous comprendrez comme moi quand on a du
mal à avoir des chiffres bon voilà par
exemple on peut avoir un peu une idée
par effectivement l'aide médicale
étranger puisque il y a une partie
d'entre eux seulement une partie d'entre
eux qui en ont besoin de
bénéficie je prends bien le terme qui en
ont besoin parce que quand vous avez des
gens qui sont tuberculos ou qui ont le
sida ou qui ont le paludisme il vaut
mieux les soigner que de pas les soigner
donc ça déjà des risques épidémiques
c'est quelque chose extrêmement
important et ça coûtera beaucoup plus
cher si on ne le fait pas bon je
passerai sur les prothèses mammaires et
autres il me semble absolument dérisoire
compte tenu du sérieux de ce sujet donc
la polémique a été lancée par Stanislas
guerrier
je crois heureusement aussi vite que
qu'elle était venue mais la question
double question que je vois si vous
voulez c'est que effectivement une
grande partie des gens qui rentrent sur
notre territoire rentre légalement sur
le territoire alors à moins que la
France ne respecte pas ses engagements
quant au droit d'asile d'une part quand
on regroupement familial d'autre part
quant à vouloir développer la
francophonie son accueille pas des
élections je vois pas très bien comment
va développer aussi la francophonie et
l'influence de la France donc ça c'est
extrêmement important et la question qui
se pose c'est la question de la deuxième
génération et de l'intégration c'est la
question de l'intégration on va venir
sur l'intégration mais d'abord tout de
même un mot et bien sûr sur est-ce que
les quotas lorsque tel que ça a été
abordé c'est surtout un marqueur
politique ça ne sert pas grand chose par
rapport à l'ensemble de la politique
migratoire qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Jérôme Durand je pense que poser la
question telle que vous la posez c'est
apporter une réponse c'est une une
réponse qui est périphérique par rapport
au sujet
la question centrale c'est la question
de la dignité des gens qui sont sur qui
arrive sur notre territoire la question
des moyens qu'on se donne pour les
accueillir et c'est la question des
intentions qu'on a dans ce débat
politique autour d'immigration quand on
pose la question française est-ce que
l'immigration est un sujet important ça
n'est jamais le premier sujet je crois
qu'un des sondages il y a quelques
semaines indiqué que c'était le 16e
sujet
prioritaire qu'il est pas si prioritaire
que ça mais quand le gouvernement entre
dans ce débat avec le shopping de
l'asile la submersion les prothèses
mammaires
l'eldorat d'eau sociale ça prouve quand
même que on est dans un calcul qui est
un calcul politique et au cours derrière
l'extrême droite et à ce jeu là c'est
toujours l'extrême droite qui gagne donc
moi je pense que ce débat il est il est
mal engagé parce que les intentions
elles sont façon politicienne et donc
c'est un débat d'opportunité c'est un
débat d'opinion et d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de soutien du président de la
République que son François sureau que
son Jeannine Ferri ce sont des marqués
très fortement parce qu'il considèrent
que on n'avait pas élu Emmanuel Macron
pour ça moi j'ai pas voté pour lui au
premier tour mais en tout cas ceux qui
l'avaient choisi considèrent qu'une
forme de trahison sur sur le programme
je voudrais que l'on parle également de
ce dernier sujet qui est très important
la question de l'intégration à ce propos
on va rejoindre Alexandre Poussard vous
êtes avec Claude malurey qui d'ailleurs
a consacré une bonne partie de son
discours à la question de l'intégration
l'écoute concernant l'intégration vous
avez pris l'exemple de ces générations
issues des baux de people venus d'Asie
dans les années 80 qui ont réussi à
s'intégrer avec une deuxième génération
qui a maintenant un mode de vie égal à
tous les citoyens français l'intégration
c'est un problème culturel selon vous
c'est très très largement un problème
culturel effectivement il y a un modèle
français d'intégration qui est
l'intégration républicaine qui vise à ce
que il n'y ait pas de communauté
dispersée et puis il y a un modèle qui
n'est pas le neutre mais qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui en France
est en train de se développer avec eux
et un modèle communautaire c'est
évidemment un modèle un modèle qui
divise alors que le modèle de
l'intégration républicaine est un modèle
qui unit et ce modèle d'intégration
républicaine j'étais j'ai travaillé
longtemps un Médecin sans Frontières
dans les camps de réfugiés asiatiques je
les ai vu arriver en France et des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés du
Sud-Est asiatique qui ne parlait pas
français en arrivant qui en une
génération dont les enfants sont
aujourd'hui médecin avocats
polytechnicien pourquoi pas sont des
succès professionnels des succès et
d'éducation ça montre bien et eux ils
fuyaient des tyrannies dans une qu'ils
avaient qu'il voulait absolument fuir
par tous les moyens et il rêvait de
notre pays comme celui qui était un
modèle et ils ont montré que ce modèle
républicain qui le souhaitait ce modèle
démocratique lorsque l'on y adhère
lorsqu'on en fait pas ils peuvent
d'ailleurs être
avoir des connaissances dans leur
communauté bien entendu mais le modèle
lui-même le modèle qu'ils ont suivi à
l'école et dans les promotions c'est le
modèle républicain et c'est un exemple
même qui contredit ce que j'appelle les
victimesocrates c'est-à-dire ceux qui
expliquent que de toute façon il n'y a
pas de possibilités de s'adapter et
qu'on excuse tous les échecs par le
biais de la condition sociale ou des
difficultés de l'immigration très bien
merci beaucoup Claude malure pour votre
éclairage
voilà on va consacrer à dernière partie
de ce débat à la question de
l'intégration Jérôme du Rhin on dit
beaucoup que la France a raté son
intégration ces dernières années est-ce
que pour vous c'est le cas
je sais pas si il faut se préoccuper de
ce qui s'est passé ou de ce qui va se
passer et je pense que quand on a des
débats sur l'immigration qui partent sur
ces bases là on est en train de préparer
l'échec de la prochaine intégration
parce que laisser entendre des gens qui
sont déjà sur le sol français qui sont
peut-être né sur le sol français que
finalement ils n'ont pas leur place chez
nous c'est se condamner à rater cette
intégration dans un modèle républicain
effectivement qui évite le
communautarisme qui permet à chacun de
se sentir français d'être en phase avec
la culture de de ce beau pays que la
France en revanche laissez croire que
en étant dur durcir les lois comment on
le fait systématiquement revenir sur ce
débat avec de mauvais arguments c'est
sans doute le meilleur moyen d'échouer à
intégrer des gens qui ont vocation à
s'intégrer chez nous Sébastien me rend
non mais il y a un rapport parlementaire
de nos amis coco et Cornu gentil de 2018
mai 2018 député
ce rapport parlementaire il faut le lire
l'État ne sait pas dans la
Seine-Saint-Denis à 150 000 à 400 000
personnes combien il y a la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui passe pour un
département pauvre c'est le troisième
département le plus riche de France en
collecte de TVA il faut quand même être
aveugle pour pas voir le lien entre les
flux qui rentrent et la difficulté
d'intégrer d'assimiler et d'accueillir
correctement aujourd'hui
regardez la porte de la Chapelle
regarder la misère qui s'étend regardez
des zones en France où les femmes n'ont
plus le lieu de citer mince est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est pas un si
suffisant pour dire que ça marche pas
alors après l'intégration la simulation
c'est une volonté individuelle et c'est
effectivement par l'école de la
République contre l'idéologie du
multiculturalisme et bien moi je suis
pour l'ordre républicain et je sais plus
pour qu'on refasse ce qui a fonctionné
pendant des années mais qu'aujourd'hui
ne fonctionne plus
que ça ne fonctionne plus je pense que
ça fonctionne encore que la question qui
se pose je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
une question de répartition de la
population et que faire ces abcès de
fixation avec 2500 3000 personnes qui
sont dans des conditions effectivement
indignes comme on l'apporte de la
chapelle ou à l'entrée de l'autoroute
c'est effectivement
insupportable et qu'il y a une
répartition à faire rapidement de ces
populations qui qu'on laisse
s'agglutiner par exemple la jungle de
Calais qui était arrivée à plus de 10000
personnes bon puis on a fini par la
démanteler on a dit ils vont tous
revenir ce n'est pas vrai on compte en
ce moment sur quel est elle est un peu
moins de 1000 personnes c'est déjà une
situation difficile dans laquelle un
certain nombre de mineurs sont à peu
près presque la moitié mais c'est ayant
les a répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire vos qui a dit on va mettre
décalés partout sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est pas vrai on n'a pas eu
à la condition de cette répartition
l'immigration et l'intégration peuvent
être une chance aussi pour la France on
sait que l'immigration était une chance
pour la France que serait la France il y
avait jamais eu d'immigrés depuis la
France est un pays d'immigration depuis
le 19e siècle
mais il y a eu des flux extrêmement
important moi je reviens mais la France
ne faisait pas 67 millions d'habitants
non plus monsieur ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui alors effectivement quand on
est dans une France de 40 millions
d'habitants comme on sortir de la guerre
la proportion n'a jamais temps varié que
ça on est à elle est entre 10 et 12% de
population étrangères ce pourcentage
pour ainsi dire pas varier la question
c'est quels moyens mettons
essentiellement à l'école si on veut
continuer à faire nation il faut mettre
les moyens pour l'intégration
j'ajouterai à la fin et à s'occuper des
femmes merci beaucoup Béatrice
Jérôme Durin merci Sébastien Morand
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivie très bonne soirée
sur Public Sénat
[Musique]